It was voluntary sometimes, but it's time for you Gao!!
Tch, I'm not even getting to the th-
Bruh I fucking her that-
I forget that these stupid Doos
need to be trained in these days
So you can't just jump into it
I'm not sure what to do
Although many of these more videos
are really easy for us
it's performing four out of ten at two thousand views
impression quick click clearly rate is low but the watch time was high
sorry that's just a little humble
oh it's me oh my god
i'm sorry there's so many of me there are so many of me did you hear that
is that kept going that was not stopping
oh wait sorry i was i was supposed to pretend i'm a peripherist
oh wait where's my
fucks sake my stinger's all flying okay right forget that
right i have made an error these multiplayer games and their inability to claim if you're a freaking
player or not why can't i not just say i'm a new player i am a seasoned veteran
i they'll i fucking have to do the tutorial
i have two thousand hours in this game and over watch one
learn the basics of movement i'll go and then i'll see no fucking entertain me you slag
i don't know how long the training is doing a lot behind played games
ah it's so where to go if she's fucking
who's your favorite you mean is that a second account is that a module
you mean how many accounts do you have you mean i swear to god
oh my god i'm soldier 76
okay hold on let me move my little you know we try hard
hi i'm athena hi athena no explain it's me all right fair fair real real true true
oh my god wait they actually have it made now
oh my god i'm not gonna lie
i've not done this before this is cute as anything i didn't know they did this
the tutorial in overwatch one is oh my god i'm watching it look at the wiggling on my mouse
that's when you know i've got the parking soon oh oh oh hit him with it oh hit him with a melee
oh well i've not unlocked him oh follow tracer she moves around the hanger oh oh look at these
skills look at these skills and the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
actually tracer's got my build kind of thanks she ain't got no chest but she got them
um
what we're doing give me that gun hi hi there i'm tracer
hey this this looks like what we had
she got that damn follow the
where did i close i've closed my ui by accident
oh i'm sorry mommy if you pull your friends you don't have to do it oh thank god really
legend thank you guys oh oh oh i'm a bit rusty i'm a bit rusty nicely done okay
that's me that's my moosh button
i'm a little harder to hit than natural i didn't
oh my god i just woke up i just woke up before anyone says anything i've literally just woken
up i've just woken up i've looked i've not played overwatch in literal years and i've just woken
up give me a second give me a give me a second okay okay my my super soldier side is
ready oh my god e for biotic field
ah yeah we've been healing oh the vibration's going i'm fucking with you by the way we we
did not do that sign her up for esports bro i'd be the i'd be the ray gun for the olympics for
the e-girls of esports we should go from rusty to still got it
look at that look at that oh look at that jukes right make sure your crosshairs up off the ground
because that i'm a 10 prize q you've never played overwatch who's playing overwatch for the first
time just because of me uh give me ultimate now ethina is she loud enough or am i too loud for
ethina so in order to get see it sounds really loud when i'm shooting from my pov but ethina
actually talking isn't that loud bro bro you're taking too long wrap it up ethina just hand me
my ultimate i get it i'll go make it a charge we have kills and heals and stuff in case you're
reborn ready oh that was my heel sorry sorry that was my healing instead of mario re mario
i'm a coming this is the best ultimate in game because you don't have to do anything i love the
sounds i used to think ethina was the echo same but never happened oh my gosh
wait it's still not wrapped up come on i want to play with a reef lens ethina wrap it up ethina
how is there not a button that says i have played before ethina i've played before i might not be
the best but i've played i want to play with refling i literally gave blizzard on your phone
number just so i could play with refling please uh the uh why did i wait thank you wrap it up
jesus okay now i can play with a reflet
what what do you mean oh what do you mean it's not done
let me play let me please let me play stop hitting heels down god it's been that long
i can't stop freaking fat fingering e and r
what heroes rely on team work yes team work team work with the reef flings
come on ethina give me one one ethina come on ethina
i think it's tutorial practice no rules rules ranked are you freaked i want to play with
oh wait hold on okay let's go tracer time
you're a bit of an act right what hero detail f1
passive aren't wait why is it considered wait that's considered passive damage
oh her idiot passage in general they got like hover jets all right 10 for Zarya
oh my god i'm playing ices the wrong as a mountain oh i need to select the healer now
oh my gosh oh my wee vibrator's going oh i need to stop making jokes
i'll be right behind you oh my god oh my god i promise you i didn't go on github okay i'm not
github mommy's going feral for reef let me get my refund stop making me do this freaking tutorial
right i'm fucking dps okay so the best thing about going against people that have never played
the game before oh wait that's right you put that down left shift it's over hey mama left work early
because i was sick but on the bright side i am able to watch the stream after the tutorial is done i
hope you win we're gonna have to carry me the reef blend it's sure you need to take responsibility
and not in the pregnancy sense but in the in the hold c to open the comms wheel i need healing
hit them with a moe oh hit them on the tourbillon
i'm pinging i'm to kill 10 training bot i feel like um what's her name tracer has really good
quads that go with their cheeks whereas i don't really have good thighs in terms of like any strength
they're working out are we done are we done can i play with the reef ones you may know you may
now leave the practice range you can see it top right okay that's what it says
no no i don't need to replay the tutorial i'm satisfied with my gaming experience you better
wrap it the fuck up Athena okay okay okay okay hold on let me type in my name it's hold on let me
type my name and say careful okay okay oh fish number fucking hell you guys are fast i didn't
even get a chance to see my own numbers one one three eight okay okay and then i'm gonna invite
i've got my pen and paper so i know who's had a chance and who's no okay okay now you guys are
thank you so much for wanting to play with me what the fuck thank you i love you
i feel very loved right now thank you i know the game is pure brain rot but thank you
oh my god i had a yeah begin adding friends no like show me oh my god you filled up an entire
page already holy shit how's it right everyone's good is there not an accept all button oh my gosh
thank you i'm adding i'm adding i'm adding i'm adding okay right okay and then that's it right
me being like hmm who's got the profile picture oh you little reef ones oh my gosh it's almost
like that's the basis of what you are are you a patch of marion disguise right how do i get
you in is it just uh is it just random how many are you available play which region
they made it one region 22 minutes left left on what no you're coming into my group don't be
right i'll just do oh no it's alphabetical can it not be randomized i feel like oh no it is
no you just a lot of you thank you right is it no it's randomized just a lot of you randomly
have d at the start your name d d b b c e element of p that's it oh wait it's only the people who are
in game what the fuck is eldritch nightmare i have no idea right who's on battle now in menu in menu
right how do we do it fairly did we just go ding ding ding i feel like if i did it alphabetically
that's who the fuck is accolade of a moosa i'm just adding that random good fucking luck
we'll figure it out i don't know how to do it fairly because like as fast as possible whoever's
on the game friends are in so i can't pocket mercy you sorry mama oh my god i can't believe
you're not writing for me chair i can't believe it right so wait for squadron number one b u l
fabry matty and to get no someone came down kooky fumble yeah you fumbled that invite that's
what you fumbled change your name right now and you should noob lord you're in right where's kooky
fumble you get one more chance i get it you were nervous to click except i get it you're allowed
to be nervous you don't have to accept cookie fumble declined one absolute chad adds someone
to play with them and then doesn't i've been rejected in 4k hearthstone to get in here right now
brah one absolute chad gets added on the friend are you shitting that's what it is he's he's he's
scared he's shitting himself right now um right okay our squadron is together it looks like two
of us are new and then the others uh well i'm not new mr savage ooh mr steel you girl right unranked
i can't play yet
wait what do you mean unranked unranked can't hear for that type of match there's too many
players in your group what type of match one two three four five oh sorry so wait what oh i make the
six player okay right uh hearthstone i'm so sorry um what you say
i don't know what you say i'm so sorry hearth i will take your name out out of that list
you're not considered it okay two moons that's my ass okay we're gonna do it team number one
is called newbie booby because it's been a very long time since we've played so newbie booby team
don't let me down actually what are my voice comms for shouting down the mic to the reef
ones hold on hold on wait i need the sentence no not career profile i don't have any settings
is am i being trolled are sentence not part of this game is it under a different word
is sentence not called sentence an overwatch hit escape on the menu ah setting
i mean options fine right how do i shout down the mic to the reef ones hold on a minute sound
oh my god reef ones i did not know how many of you played overwatch yeah didn't you
right voice chat i need auto join team that's fine push to talk is on but what button is push
to talk i want to make it caps lock so controls communication push to talk is caps lock yeah
i always use caps lock i don't know why i'm just quirky like that i'm just i'm just so quicky
there they can hear me i'm gonna fuck them up i'm gonna start screaming at them in game
hold on how many reef ones play overwatch this was it right no hold on a minute you're not all
annihilating me for being like overwatch bad and you're all adding me on overwatch no no you're
not you're not saying to me overwatch bad if i'm getting this many it's a free to play game
yeah but i never had this in the other free to play games as well i don't remember being so biased
bro come on we already make up one side of the team just give us five more players blizzard
blizzard we beg of you give us five more players that's all we need i hate overwatch anyway i'm
ready to play with you real real okay let me drink my tea because i've already forgotten it's been
okay
how long are you gonna be stream sniping okay right i have a confession so tomorrow stream is
getting swapped about um if you know you know the schedule um but it's getting swapped about
i'm not doing the membership stream either i'm just gonna stream snipe for as long as i'm able to
this will be my first time playing in probably years to be fair i would say literally same crazy
jc we're like the exact same we should like make up something i don't know a yeah i'm not very well
right now on the sad sad fact that i have xx chromosome what should i say so anyway i'm just
going to play for as long as i feel like i'm going oh my fellow americans uh and then tomorrow's stream
has to get extent like swapped out to our first game together oh my god not finished my tea yet
oh where the fuck are we america midtown yeah this town is mid oh right obviously because i'm
scottish i have to go with irish solidarity with moira oh wait my tank do you want me to go tank i
don't know what you want me to do i can do anything for you baby um oh wait hold on let me be nice and
good luck everyone and have fun i'm gonna be that positive person that really annoys you when
you've had a lot of um i will find the key you're unable to perform this action because your
account is too new they counter toxic folk the flames of your vengeance they counter toxic folk
how
i'm trying to be nice and now i look like a freaking i look even worse oh my god look at them right
we've got anna oh check out we've got reparting all right and we've got zarya oh oh oh we've got
a moe oh it's golden oh my god it's golden and then we've got we've got a soldier that's halfway
across the map oh my god he's getting wigs night he's getting wigs night i can't heal that sorry i
can't heal that from here that's why you're getting a ball of death oh it's been a while
we're playing together some overwatch together in midtown because it's mad and no one reaper
what are you doing reaper i hardly know i'm spraying i'm spraying oh god oh god the zarya's
field charge oh no but we have a diva and the right heart there we have two tanks back it up back
it up oh oh that's okay that's okay i have passive fields oh oh look at them passive fields
i'm sucking the soul how many tanks do they got i can't do this uh we do have a reaper that's the
yummy news oh my god that's right break his shield break that right heart make him regret being born
fuck the diva make that diva heart right and then diva can't suck away my balls yes yes annihilate
the reflux it might be 4 a.m in the morning but i'm fucking buzzing i'm so happy right now we're
fucking them up hold on i eat delicious tea though oh they're changing tactics are they
oh they've changed tactics reflux heads up they now have the fox one oh oh oh oh that's right i'm
doing comms that's we're try harding and quickly that's right okay we're gonna break that shield
okay okay oh my god so good no suck them out i'm oh oh i'm gonna make oh i'm gonna make a regret
being born oh my god my controls are far too um sensitive they are far too thin oh i don't have
i know we heal slot oh my god i'm raising you
okay okay oh my god team team newbie booby more like team xp back up back up back up back up we
don't have a tank we don't have a tank you crazy reflux you crazy reflux but uh everyone's also in
bound as well diva all in bone rain heart all unbound sorry all inbound i fucking told you
i fucking told you i've got too much game sense i've got too much game sense
i need i just woke her up i just woke her up i just woke her up i'm keeping her alive
oh my god my sensitivity is too high for this please get the fire no the fucking cat the fuck right
sensitivity options right sensitivity right let's make it let's bring you down to a 12 let's bring
you down to a 12 i'm fucking hype damn right i'm talking to the board oh no that's not how it works
in overwatch i'm sorry i'm coming oh my god the reflux clutched up
they didn't need us oh my god you guys are so good at this game i'm so proud of you are you
suffering no i'm winning this is amazing i'm so happy i'm so happy to play games with you
um monkey monkey key monkey key now there is yeah that's right that's right level up mazaria
level up mazaria i dare you i dare you you wet you wet toad i dare you um that's right oh i'm
giving you the good stuff that's right merci oh that's right merci oh that's right merci
i want a five kill street can i call in a care pack now
i don't get i literally woke up so like quickly ago and i'm so excited i'm like so happy right now
look at that 2k damage and 2k heals oh the perfect balance so we're fucking
oh we're gonna do a little heal on that i can see that okay we've got ultimates on our way but what
one oh we might have a we might have a sombra all oh dear oh dear i'm going oh unless reaper unless
what who's oh is that is that the fox girl it is it is oh my god oh my god our tank is down
our tank is down oh my god you're going in no i'm going in mate i'm going in i'm boss deep so
is that was my kill and i'm that was my kill and i'm 30 seconds okay okay we don't have a tank but
don't you worry i've got my ultimate i'll be that tank for you baby girl then you so wet reflin
okay sombra all back away from each other i repeat back away from each other there's a
sombra all inbound oh there she is sweet flag oh there she is um she's under that bridge she
teleport away she's a slag okay okay heals okay let's make a shirt let's make a shirt let's
start let's not get too juicy now oh team noobie boobie what a fucking easy win
what a fucking easy win what 10 out of 10 10 out of 10 the teamwork even when the tank is down
the dps said now hold my ultimate astra endorsing astra i'm endorsing is um oh look at that oh look
at that he hits the mercy first make sure he gets to kill by hitting the floor and he goes back
for the team but he makes he's aiming he gets the shot he gets the crossfire let's go let's fucking go
yes oh my god you guys are doing amazing okay i unlocked genji oh thank you for the permission
to play genji thank you team uh moobie boobie moobie boobie that's not your name noobie boobie
thank you team noobie boobie i will now remove you from group and then we will cycle in new reeflings
now don't don't panic if i sound disappointed when we lose i go through the motion of the ocean
okay right so who have we not had in team number two up you come dot car cookie fumble you we're
gonna try you again you felt a bit nervous but that's okay cupin is an assassin but your sister
in menu you're in a custom lobby well your problem wait one two three four five six fuck i've done it
again don't no i'm sorry i'm so sorry flame arrow forgive me i've done it again i've done it again
right okay we've got dot god i'm not gonna have a voice by the end of the stream i'm just warning
you now cookie fumbler made it in the family i'm so sorry i'm so sorry to who i had to remove
crazy yes as you as you can tell i have not finished drinking my tea right cupid and together
we're gonna be called the rebound because surely we're gonna win twice in a row surely we'll win
twice in a row unranked let's go did you get my friend a quiz i might have
uh crazy yes i've got 40 refunds so far
well i'll play you guys but i think i'd rather be the one to tell my brother that our mom is dead
in person then have to play this game for a minute you'll have fun though i don't know if i'm allowed
to laugh at that i don't know aah am i allowed to heal for that or is that it's 40 the maximum
friends list that cannot be i don't believe it for a second but wait 40 is the maximum friends list
that's not true what oh no i have to remove you as i go along then right i'm gonna have to remove
who i played with when did they do that that's so silly i'm just checking my list hank hill wait
isn't that guy that goes barbie uh barbie i'm so sorry i'm gonna have to remove you as i go along
which isn't how i wanted to do it but when did they do that is that to save server space
god game really uh where's noob lord i can't find them did you play one game and uninstall
instantly ah did you did you remove me oh maybe he removed me to make it faster
oh my god no i can i can't consider it recently okay oh you're all can't consider it please don't worry
yeah 36 so yeah that would have been four removed okay there we go why would they do that 600 maximum
bruh wait max number of friends is 40 apparently yeah can hear a heartbreak with every kick i was so
sorry oh her name's so jorn and she's canadian actually and she's a chicken nugget i've only
done mystery heroes since it became overwatched too don't worry we're gonna make it that'll
right i'll repost my like ad add me but be warned my uh the limit is 40 so i'm cycling
through i'm running i'm gonna put brackets running a terrain on you and then that's
what oh my god i love this so much please pin right i'll put add me but be be warned the limit
is 40 so i'm cycling through reeflings running a train on you just over and over again plop plop plop
plop soldier and brigita is not canadian you are you now as much as i've been at the game for
a wee hot saying i assure you i assure you brigita lindholm lindholm oh my god my freaking thing
isn't twisting please twist i'm sorry i'm twisting the microphone so i don't creeps me out i don't
like flesh colored machinery in this art what the fuck bro don't make me drop fucking more
just so i could be like uh it's not what oh my fellow americans it's not what it looks like
twist his balls brigita is not region for the last time they're swedish brigita and her pops
is her pops is torbjorn in game by the way father daughter joe me if me if my dad
gamed and played overwatch but he doesn't he plays like fort sunship he goes around the racetrack
okay come on come on quick play don't be come on pc pool we call upon you pc pool pc plums torb is
a bad i will pick from page two next if they're in the menu and yeah yeah okay i'll pick from page
two because i've picked like from the adc the battle net friend limit is actually 400 players can
someone else contradict that information i'm battled battled i have one practice round with
bots so don't judge me to harshly long i don't worry i wouldn't i wouldn't literally if we do roll
queue it'll be faster than open queue i don't have the option unlocked darlin uh it's not unlocked
for me because my dumb ass i thought you could just say that you've already played before it let
unrank okay no wait it looks like i can't have more friends oh i'm sorry to the reeflands i
removed i didn't have to remove you yet i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry again i didn't have to remove
you yet i apologize thank you anonymous for the tip yes i think you might actually be right
what's this hey roll logs after five days we have we just need to do that four more times
okay finish this cup of tea it's been
mmm it's room temperature it's worse than room temperature it's almost cold so i'm gonna just
have some water instead there are purge for no reason yeah it's the pc pool that makes it so long
wait how did i change that
right escape options gameplay enable post-match auto-cube um a limit client sent with the
fuck does that mean the heads up display okay well so short career visibility oh my god everyone's
gonna know i'm new to the game um hurry i have room temperature i cute you do thanks for them
um mama was a little excited to start no i was excited is no one legit playing overwatch
um oh my god subtitle size get that oh i love being able to read i love being able to read
without putting my glasses on oh it's my favorite thing ever are we colorblind feel a little color
blind today okay i don't know how to do the cross platform enable high precision mouse input uh
no that's a bit too much for me i need all the assistance and by that i mean i'm sticking to
moira for the good suck uh reeflings queues the opposing team i think you guys might have to
fucking throw yourselves into the unranked uh roll queue thing because yeah reeflings versus
reefling whoa overwatch roleplay yeah right fucking now uh you've made a dog's dinner of that one
you're fucking cunt that's moira i'm so sorry that was moira right oh my god right who about it
i just don't want genji but i actually didn't want to play genji i'm sorry but
i want to see xaria still even viable damn i remember enjoying her design and now i'm still
enjoying it muscle mummy win muscle mummy win for feeler i'm fucking waiting i'm um oh my god
my mic won't stop on screen itself please i'm not moving it that much i promise
oh my god it's a horse oh my god it's a horse no oh wait it's this map
oh you're new i don't really recognize you much oh my god what are you
you're a healer oh i didn't mean to use my barrier so so it's got a bit i was a bit pre-emptive
oh he's off oh he's away he's away he's off he's off on one muscle mummy for realer when you
pick up some dumb bit real i'll get it i'll be on it right okay we've got a roadhog a
roadhog sighted genji sighted oh oh and he give them call it oh that's right reaper
oh lay into me oh lay into me okay not that much not that much
right they might know how to play this game oh dear i got my i got my 40 maximum energy
from that bubble but oh wait i have two bubbles in a row now oh i forgot i forgot i have two
bubbles i have two bubbles now reaper is in spawn soldiers in spawn get to fuck you mad dog
we jumped off the map
yeah and the shadows are up oh my god they're coordinated oh they're coordinated but i'm not
doing call outs they're so right now i'm coming this way so i'm coming this way i'm too scared
no my baby my reef fling no it's just getting up to me oh that reef one's going for it
there's a bloody reaper where the fuck is he
oh my god we're getting massacred bro is this because i'm not on healer i'm sorry oh
wait he went above i didn't even see him right that's it no no right i'll give tank another shot
oh my god we're gonna massacre didn't spawn this is embarrassing hold on we're gonna soldier
i'm helping i'm helping yeah hold on i was trying to shoot them oh my god oh oh who's here
oh oh i'm going for the headshots okay got him got him oh my god mlg pro
oh okay
no i put my healer station down he's to the left to the left he's damaged at the healer station
i pulled you to the left bro i put down my healer station my healer station
i've seen tougher spots i'm gonna love more the tank is the most important in this game i better not be
me
oh oh go on then arisa go on then go on dolphin get that point
how that fuck do you feel i literally i sneeze yellow and then i start healing myself
i'm actually just so good this game i cannot no i need to heal her first
oh my god i don't have the aimbot for this
i'm trying to help i'm so sorry i don't know how to shoot for it first okay we got healer
there's so much happening please i got soldier a little low bro i couldn't pick a target i was
panicking i was like if i get this end the heals are down but the soldier is spraying at me
but re-present behind me and then there's a tank on point with arisa i couldn't pick a target
i'm sorry me please oh he's up there he's up through the b-ball bag i'm off i'm off
i'm off i'm actually off i'm off i'm off
i'm doing i'm doing i'm doing i'm a big girl i'm a big girl i'm a big girl
i'm a big girl oh my god right okay okay sorry that's all i had to do i don't care what anyone
says that's all i had to do i did it lock in i tried my inner cord wasn't enough but that's
okay we're gonna do if we're against the reaper who did i even have access to though
so soldier can get me from the sky if i was far i can't do again jay because i'm dumb
soldier and reaper can kill my turret really easily should i just go the old sucky sucky
should i just pocket a rifle oh my god no you're so low oh my
how do i get you unlock via a hero challenge if we do this right oh my god she's so cute
i like her suit as well like i like how no skin is showing but there's still like
definition to her oh wait i can literally look at it right in front of me because you're the character
a v sucky over what you went do we don't make her dive and have her unlocked i don't i don't
even think i have her unlocked i'm so fast i'm fast well that wasn't lucy it must be her ability
oh yeah oh my god it's again jay should i pick again jay should i pick a your footsteps and i don't
like him the oldest trick in the book what's going on yeah that's right up mars up mars
oh my god i'm scared we don't have a healer oh wait i'll start self healing after a couple of
minutes don't worry i'll heal you with my heal station there you go i saw him no i'm going around
no go away go away you went far i'm the better soldier that's right that's right oh get that
discord orb on get that this oh sorry oh oh i got stuck on the spot i felt like a snowman
but there was no ice this time it was like sludge
i can't get away with this all right they gave everyone slow healing and healers fast slow healing
oh that's not nice that's so stinky oh my god my pain am i going mental right hold on i'm gonna
pull up my ping in a minute just so you guys know i'm fighting i'm fighting i'm shadow boxing i'm
actually shadow box i give up i'm shadow boxing sorry right options hold on how do i display my
fucking thing how do i display my ping how do i display my ping i need you i need you to know
what ping i'm against right now because i feel like i'm shadow boxing in the game it's not it's not
looking good bro it's not looking good i think i'm gonna go moira and ironically just to suck the
game
oh but i've almost got my ultimate on soldier oh decisions decisions
oh wait how did you claim that who are you
did you kill them all what the fuck bro pocket pocket the ass not fucking me
oh unless
unless
yeah he says yes we get him
okay
yeah up mars up mars up mars
can i get one of them right i've got the healer i've got the healer
and they got my healer
oh is this ping bro this is ping so i'm blooming ping i'm blooming ping you can't prove it you
can't prove i'm bad oh you can't prove i'm bad it's ping it's ping i'm telling you i'm losing my
mind it's ping i'm telling you
can anyone make it on the other point in town it's me it's me i'm the speedy gonzales i'm going
oh i need him with the 260
i'm fucking scared
i'm spraying oh sorry that was me that was me sorry sorry that was
sorry i just shot into the reflect and genji i'm sorry i'm sorry that was me
look it's just we beg in your pardon and we bet a desolate here in there oh
oh i hear i hear him oh oh that was me again sorry that was me again got me excited
got me excited eh right okay okay soldiers gonna all from right side under the lighthouse
well i've won just
can they not hear me no one's here you fucking twat bags soldier
microphone is muted because i'm a new player are you serious let me communicate with the
i want to win i want to win so badly
i want to win i want to win my own game
i'm gonna spit them who are what what is her little arch thing i have no idea
okay i killed a healer you're welcome oh my god yes no no no no it's all crumbling apart
it all comes crumbling apart oh i can't believe it i can't believe it
what you say i type gg but i'm not allowed to type oh my god the rebound did not work but that's
okay that's not going to stop me okay if i matter what's that symbol what is this this is new
oh that's right oh that's right oh wait no you're the enemy bad genji bad genji
look at me try to spray them oh that's so embarrassing i said gg five times oh can i not see it
i guess i can't see anything i are they like we're not alive anyone to see any toxicity until
you're at least seasoned by via tent how'd i get bro can i get out so i can pick up new reef ones
got it oh i've got diva are we cheeky diva right how you get how you get roof from group how you
get how you get roof from group how you get how you get oh oh oh alright alright next team right i
will pick from the the other bits because i was picking from the like the first section but that's
not how it works okay boom and i boom and i'm at mean boom right uh in menu in menu in menu
and fuken in meaning anymore catch the tiger by the toe if it squeals let it go in meaning
well i've already played with you so i don't care okay okay we've got Aussie we've got
bruv very creative name we've got mr silent you don't talk do we call you no voice and then
not to be confused and then together we are going to make team shopping because i'm going to forget
to and also ping is a a word in a slang chinese term for a willy how do i display my ping to show
you it's not me i must i must redeem myself options diva is a seer on the season you
invited five again i did it what i didn't did i invite terracotta terracotta did you know
terracotta did you invite yourself into my lobby i don't have your name down
details display everything framerate 60 oh now you know network latency get that one so i can show
what the fuk is in her pool isn't that the polis internationally oh you're just specating
like again i'm afraid i'm sorry okay don't don't spectate well you can spectate but you can't be
surprised if i get confused i'm so sorry terracotta forgive me which i'm gonna sing that every single
time i stay for reflin you guys are gonna hear it all stream well you wait you can try out new heroes
no i can't because you've hidden them from new players network latency is ping are you ready
interpolation guessing numbers between two numbers we're all just specating i mean you
could boot it up if you want right our team is shopping and are we gonna win i don't know but
is that gonna stop me from being hype uh no obviously not we ain't going offline until
every reflin has had a train run on them do i make myself clear do i make myself clear
i would technically have 50 reflins right now to run a train on if i didn't delete
or maybe was it 53 54 52 i can't do math oh my fellow americans i cannot do mathematics
why is that so tiny can you even read that number how big am i big on your screen right
now i cannot read that uh well i can't read it but if i was like watching someone um
uh are you playing on pc i am i assume you can still oh no can you add me if you're on pc if
it's battle net i can't if i squint oh you're so bad
oh we're in we're in fucking canada let's go
oh to the maple leaf and the protein take away i'm trying evil i'm trying do you i'm going in
yeah pc and console complete okay if you don't have time you could do 5v5 custom
yeah yeah we'll do that then 177 ping is that good or bad uh did i win the world record of pain
huh did i wind up in the world game on game on oh my god have you ever written on lyrics before
oh oh oh hit him hit him break into what the fuck is this oh oh my god oh my god oh my god what is
this she's hold on get the ui off right now oh my god what was that do it again do it i don't
even know what that was i'm just happy to be here please escort the robot beepity boop boop i see the
robot you can't beat me my pings over 9000 okay spray where's enemies come on don't be shy
do we try right who we got we're gonna do this
please don't die right away refling that makes me nervous
am i a matrix already oh my god they have so many tanks is the matter just to have tanks
it is it looks like the matter is tank say oh my god i'm getting bullied i'm getting bullied
i'm getting bullied oh my god oh my god look at these jerks look at these juke daisy
juke's bikini's on top no are you kidding yes yes oh my god refling love sorry you should have
thought about that before being a healer i'm sorry you should have thought about that before being
a healer you should have thought about it before being a healer
oh my god there's another healer oh my god right back up back up lucio get away get away
right push this robot
no i'll take that help thank you very much get get the fuck off my tanks
i'm pushing them i'm pushing them you don't fuck it your take it's your problem now
it's your problem now take it i love handing off the fucking all like a sure problem right
don't go on that step stop going on the staircase i know you can only hear me through the stream
okay because my voice comms are broken okay they're coming behind they're coming behind
back door back door back door back door ultimates back door back door ultimates five
okay two front door two back door do the front door do the front door front door first front
door first okay back door back door back door yes yes yes make them regret being born
you're dead in darlings oh my god give me that robot you belong to me
well you got a fuck i'm so fucking happy right now can you tell can you tell
i was so fucking happy i'm gonna get a cool after this round brah don't be surprised if this
turns into an endurance stream i've not played over watching such a long time and it just oh no
reaper no reaper hardly even nor right okay you're fine you're fine
i uh i uh yes yes i'm rallying so hard right now i'm rallying so hard oh my god how do you predict
how do you predict the ultimates i i don't i don't know
i'm out of my mecca oh my god my vtuber model was destroyed i can't in the in the grave
please don't pick on me oh it's in his hands pick it on me i hear his balls
right actually no it's better to die with the team please think of the team it's better to die with
the team it's better to die be warmed with the team
oh this is gorgeous egg house more like tomo gaki house because that's what egg means the japanese
oh oh hit him with a hit him with a oh no panic panic oh no where's toky where's toky oh no okay
i'm in trouble i'm a wee bitch i'm spraying i'm spraying okay get the bot get the bot
where's it get the robot get the ai oh oh we're doing it we're nerf this
me when i throw my ult it doesn't actually do anything i'm just gonna pretend that my ultimate
like oh my god it's sigma and the name it's mccree oh my god i've not seen you in years how you've been
buddy hold on a minute and arissa hold on a minute they're tryharding that's illegal only
we're allowed to try i'm like oh dear uh they are they are mowing my my bot down i'm trying very hard
to keep up i don't think they like me that much at the oh i'm pretty sure she like shoots out her
no arissa sorry but i'm too small for this arissa this feels targeted
i don't know arissa that feels hold on i'm almost back in toky i'm almost back in my vtuber model
i promise i'm almost in i'm in i'm not in fuck i'm fucking and he ate my my pistole my pistol
shoots what is that on the floor look like a spider who the fuck has a spider on the floor
there's no widow me bro i'm coming back i've got i've got a cheeky oh oh oh Canada oh Canada
land of the maple tree
oh it's been a while since oh my god they're doing back to back ults i don't know do you think that's
overkill come on buddy that's overkill knock off i keep feeding the sigma with this suck
get that yes i love when we make them regret being born it's the best part of this thing
that's right the spider's roadhogs trip oh for goodness sake what's going on
how am i on fire i'm literally didn't even do anything
i literally didn't even make it to the universe some things for my universe
oh my god i can't keep you up reaper you naughty boy i know you have a wee bit of
self healing but it's the bot still getting pushed yes okay i'm gonna throw my ultimate
very shortly replayings that are in game with me darling just prepare for it in after the all
after the all fuck you bitch fuck you in your shail oh no endowed that's really embarrassing
okay i've reconsidered my words after my actions i'm a wee bit embarrassed yeah see i enabled the
roadhog i enabled the roadhog it's fine that's that's embarrassing that's embarrassing i thought
that alt was gonna get four kills i'm leaving kidding you i'm i'm actually delusional playing
this game i'm like i'm just so good at this game oh my god kisses we're both divas love diva
oh do i have voicelines i don't want to accidentally do heroic pose because i know i'm
gonna end up accidentally doing a heroic that's it everyone's getting fucking ran over get ran over
by my mech fuck you bitch fuck you bitch i'm on the bus stop i'm in the bus stop i'm in the
bus i'm waiting on the bus i'm waiting on the carry bus by the refunds thank you oh my god oh my
god we did we did we did it we did it who got the play of the game though we got the play of the
who got the play of the game oh oh hit that hit that noise oh my god if it's the enemy so i don't
care right i'm gonna quickly run and get a can of cola i'll be a second
i probably see you
i need a knife
oh
you
Okay, I just uh, may or may not have it, so that Gimli is currently hiding under my bed
right now.
So I'm gonna try and be a bit tamer, cause I don't want to scare her.
She's okay.
Oh my god, that's right, he's trying, he's got a new name.
That's relax.
It's a dead name reference.
That's a dead name reference.
Relax.
His name's Cassidy now.
My apologies.
I just, she is fine, she's fine.
People couldn't give less of a shit, me being hyper.
Um, right, who, who is that, okay, thang, that was a really good game.
Remove from group, and then we'll go to page number three, one, two, three, four.
And then, and then we'll do page four, and then we'll do page one, then we'll do page
two, and then elementary P. You can still call Mikri, it's okay, you forgot about me.
I wonder if other members will be able to laugh at how toxic you get your game.
I don't, I don't think that, I would say one thing about being a steamer, you do not have
time to watch.
It's, it is so hard to watch, like, ah, now before anyone calls me a fake, um, oh it's
pro gamer, not programmer, pro get a meh error.
Hey mama glad I could help as much as I could, I'm just going for BTW.
Yeah, you did it, you fucking are rolling a wrecking a deck and dredging karma, thank
you for the super chat, um, yeah, that, what was I saying, I had a point, oh, um, you
could do custom 5v5 if you want, I think we might have to do that, so I want to give
everyone the opportunity to play like an actual game together, like live game against people.
Um, right, what is this team going to be called?
You go, you're, we're team nuca cola because I have a cola, don't mind me, nuca cola.
So, ah, I'm just going to play for as long as I can, I'm going to try and get everyone
in a game with me, like in a public match, however, if like we're getting to like ever
six and I'm starting to be like, I'm needing to go for a bath, I'll throw us into 5v5 and
then I'll start commentating because I'm about to unlock comms on game number 10,
who goes there? I'm burping and I'm not even drank the cola already, okay?
Um, why the eight hours ago someone sent a marshmallow, I just took a big job and I feel
and I feel good, do you know this feeling that feeling of pure bliss and happiness after taking
a nice job? I feel amazing, I could conquer the world right now. Sir, that was prostate
simulation. You said that with full confidence, that was prostate stimulation. What the fuck?
What the fuck? It hit it on the way out, that's why you feel euphoric.
What? Oh my god, what's a jobby? Jobby is a slang for poop in Scots. A jobby is what you do
when you finish work and then you sit on the toilet for 30 minutes in your home, that is a jobby,
a post-work jobby. You guys are turning Scots, I'm telling you, I'm starting to get more Scottish
slang in my marshmallows. No, it's true, it's true. Well, I hope I'm not late. Nah, the party
just getting started. Deeply departed, the party's getting started. I was still wondered where I've been.
Okay, come on, come on, find us that lobby. I don't know what my ping was last game but I
couldn't blame the ping because I was just, I was just doing so good. The Scotification is
taking, it actually is though, like how's the hypnosis going? Oh yeah, I know everyone's Scottish
and I was like, well, that's not what I asked and I was like, no, it is what you asked. Well, we
take a look at what we can... Is this fire? New Frontiers Season 12 news. Oh, I like her voice.
It is nice to meet you. What is she?
What's her accent? Oh, I thought Hanamura was back. I said Clash Map.
Wait, they have Team Deathmatch?
New Clash Map. Wait, it's not Capture Point? They never changed them? I thought they were bringing
them back. What's the Clash Map?
Oh, I like that music from the background. Do you hear that? She's an alien. Her accent is Martian.
Future is pissing me off. It keeps lagging the stream and she is mean. I mean, ah, it's Mercy.
Oh, wait, no, she's Canadian. Sorry.
That one is Mer. Poland? Is that Poland? Poland Mentioned?
Poland Mentioned? What color? What flag was that?
Oh, it's Indonesia. Oh, sorry. It's Indonesia. Sorry. My apologies. There's only any posters.
Right, okay. What am I going to do? I've played Zarya, so obviously I need to play some...
What am I going to do? Okay, we'll play characters that I've not played.
And then you can see how bad I am with the characters that I don't play in general.
The deadlock game. My name is McCree and I'm here to fix you. I wish McCree sounded like Mater.
Right, how do I... No, wait, hold on. It's been a while. Hold on. I'm trying to find my...
That's the logo. No, how do I do my communication wheel? Okay, I'm up. Oh, there we go.
My ping is 250. I should not be on DPS. I should be a... I should be a little Mercy heal bot.
Where did you go? 260 ping. I'm just aiming. I'm just aiming in the general vicinity.
There is... I am not able to shoot that far out of the sky.
I don't even hit one thing yet. Who is that? That's not a tank. Oh, that's a new tank. Go away.
Go away. Oh my god, this is terrible. What is he doing?
What is that? There's red stuff going on. Oh my gosh. No! Oh my god, there's no way.
So, we're not winning. I think I'm going to swap to Mercy. I'm not even kidding.
If no one's on Mercy, warning, you know, Reflins, I'm on Mercy.
Bruv. Nothing's happening. I'm just here for a good time. Is this, like, drop, fall off as well?
Did they change his, like, damage fall off? Bruv, make me a little heal slot. I kid you not.
I'm taking the L. I'm taking the L on this map, and I'll be a little slag for you, because what is this?
What is this? I'm better. I'm literally better doing this than fucking aiming. Oh god,
our tank is down. Monka is. Monka is. I'm trying. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Oh my god,
I can't wait to be Mercy, and I don't have to think. What is this? Who is? Go away. I'm scared.
Oh my god, Junkrat does not care. He's going for it. Junkrat said,
feel busy. What's going on up here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're right. Right, I have. What? How did, wait, Juno looks so funny doing that.
Bruv, I'm actually going to have to aim. Bruv, come on. I'm having to aim and, like,
Bruv, the fall off. Bruv, I might as well be Widow.
Oh, buddy, hope not. Oh my god, I'm sorry. I can't do anything.
I see an enemy too. What's going on? I'm spraying. I'm spraying. This is the, this is the gameplay.
I didn't know what was happening. I'm sorry. Oh no, no, no. Leave me alone, please. I'm just
a shame. I agree with you. Perfect. Leave me alone, please. What? I'm on fire. Oh my god,
he has Dragon's Breath. That's not against the Jeeves convention, so I'll let you have it.
Oh, get the tap off. Tap off. I repeat. I hit him once. I hit him once. I did my job. I did
my job as DPS. I hit him once. That's all I had to do. Come on. You know the rules. You know the
rules. That's all I had to do. Hit him once. The fire perished herself.
Okay, look at that aimbot. Gorgeous. I don't even know how I've not died yet. I'm not,
bruh, please. Tank, you better get back. You are going on a suicide mission over there, as am I.
Oh, not to... Oh, sorry. I didn't even know the... I'm sorry. This is not for me, right? I'm going
to stay on McCree. No. Can I go to Torbjorn? I'm going to Torbjorn because Torbjorn has a turret
that can automatically hit the enemy, so I don't have to aim. So then the pink problem is solved.
Five head. Five head. I don't have to aim when it's like this, so I'm going to put it right
back here, so it's really annoying, and the enemy team can't get it, and then I'm going to have
my ultimate and like... Hold on, let me focus up. Shimmy, shimmy, yeah, shimmy, yeah, shimmy, yeah.
Drank swalalala. Drank swa... Oh, yeah, piss. Oh my god, but my wee... Oh, my turret's down. No.
My five head move. Get your wood off my screen right now.
Last time, I'm speedish. Oh no, are they going to push it? I don't have my ultimate. I can't stop it.
I don't have my... I don't have my ultimate. Hold on. Pop that right there. No. I reached it. No.
No, I reached it. We messed up. We did a booboo. Oh my god, sorry, but I'm going to have to stick
to Torbjorn. Give me Australian servers and give me D.Va right now. You know exactly what's
going to happen. You know it. You know, they're scared to give me the low ping, because they
know exactly what happens when I have low ping. I should have fucking asked, okay.
Right, we must group up together, and by group up together, I mean stuff and things. That's right,
Farrah, I dare you to fly again. I dare you to fly. Would be a shame if you flew up in the sky,
wouldn't it? Yes. I think she was waiting to get healed.
No, leave the payload alone. Go away. That's not even hurting anyone. Oh, that's right. I'm
applying real pressure. This is some real pressure. I'm actually the tank. I'm actually the tank.
I'm going for Mercy's ankles. I'm backing up. I'm backing up. I repeat. I'm backing up. I'm
getting the fuck off his. Oh my God. And then my tank comes in clutch. Oh, what? Was that not
behind that? Or am I going mental? Was it fire? Was it incinerary? It must have been incinerary.
Okay, I'm learning. I'm learning. I'm learning. I'm coming. I'm coming back. I'm coming up the
stairs. The payload might be moving, but my turret is shmoving. Oh, actually, absolutely. Annihilium.
Oh, oh, that's what I like to see on the stairs. Soldier on the stairs. Soldier on the stairs.
Okay, I missed every shot. That's embarrassing. Don't look. Don't look. He never saw that.
That was embarrassing. Hydration check.
What's your ID? Damn, what are you? Fucking bartender? It's pinned. Sorry, I'm being cheeky.
It's pinned in the chat. You can see it above. This deep ruggle. Oh, here he comes. Here he comes.
Here he comes. He comes. Oh, yeah, you're going to ult, Pharah. Oh, yeah, you're going to ult.
What? Are you joking? Are you serious? Wait, so Mogas. Mogas is ult. Bro, I can't touch that.
I literally can't touch that. Maybe now. Maybe now. Maybe now. I'm stalling. I'm stalling.
I'm stalling. I'm kind of doing okay. I'm kind of stalling. I might have ultimate. No,
my turret's down. Maybe I should have put it further back in the hotel, and then it would have
been a bit more of a boulder. Ooh, they might be able to hold it. They might be able to do it.
Oh, no. Drag it right back up, back up, back up, back up, back up, back up. Back up like how I back
up on your tentacle. I'll be twerking on that shit. Okay, okay. Let's get right into the being an
annoying enemy. Right, they're going to destroy my turret. That's fine. I'm going to set up my
two rel to be at the back of the hotel. That's the weak casino bit, all right? Which means when
they cross this corner, we are going to artificially give them more space than we should. But when they
turn that corner, there's no way they're going to be hitting that shit, okay? The only thing
that can be hitting is me hitting your mom's sweet ass. Good night. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Let's spray them down. Okay, there's a soldier above, which I can't do anything about because
my fucking tank. Right, okay. Turns out Reflin's no what's up, so I'm going to replace the turret
here. D.Va is halfway across the map. That's okay. We're going to support her and her choices,
even though their spawn is right there, darling. That's right, Reflin. Their spawn is right there.
So they spawn back. Yes. Okay, my turret is getting hits from, again, a few licks in far back as well.
Soldier going above for the ultimate. Soldier going above, above for the ult.
I told you, I fucking told you. And she said, no, we're back. No, this is my choice. It's my choice
to ult. Okay, we have, we have, we have, we're going to stall. We're going to stall the 60 seconds.
We're going to say hello at the mercy because we're not, we're not mean to mercies. I once too
was a mercy. I too was a mercy once. Okay, we're going to replace her turret. That was, sorry,
but that was actually such a good we turret place. An ultimate choice from me. Now, unfortunately,
Larry is in the enemy spawn. Reflin felt a bit cocky. That's all right. We do have D.Va bomb.
We do have Reinhardt, Shatter combination coming up. We have Junkrat, Tyre as well. Okay, the
mercies down. Stop it. Oh my gosh. Browie clutched up. Oh, overtime. Sorry. Wait, hold on. The game
was, I was waiting for it to be like, okay, there we go. Fucking app. Bravo. Bravo. We are unstoppable.
The play of the game right there. Brov, sin, get on. Even though I'm not allowed to talk and chat
because I'm a new player. Oh my God, let's see how good I did. Come on, show me it then. Come on.
All right, first take down the soldier that was going to ult from high up. Next fucking
ink all over the map. I was going to say the other version of the word, but I had to control myself.
Six minutes on Torbjorn is all I need. Bidum. Wait, hold on. I've got Bidums. Thank you. Thank you.
I'll be here all week. Oh, thank you. I know. I know. GG. Oh my gosh. Right, okay.
Oh, we've got Ana. Right, I'll play healer next game. I'll play healer. Get me on Ana.
Did he make me boot it up, brov? I actually get on it. Right, okay. We are now going to
pull from page four. Right, remove from group. Sorry, this is taking me forever to like brain
right now. Remove from group. Because who's watching? I'm just an average replay with an average
live. Okay. Okay. Okay. And then page four. Or is it three? I've taken from three. So page four now.
One and menu two and menu three and menu four and menu. Okay. Have I had any of these refunds
before? No, most of them I have not.
You don't look like you're from page four. You think you could sneak on in there? Huh? You
think I wouldn't notice? Yeah. You must wet your turn, Mr. You must wet your turn.
I saw you. You're sneaky. Right, two moon. Oh no. Someone timed out.
Who timed out? Get in here. And then Woody got in. And then who got in? Woomy. As in filling
up my... And then are you going to time that? Come on, Vanderland. Can I join please? Yes,
everyone is getting a turn. But there's only four at a time that I can... I can only handle four
refunds at a time. You know, the tentacles start getting a bit too out of control. You know what
I'm saying? Gotta keep the tentacles down. I like it. Yes, have you been in? No, you haven't.
Wait. Oh, fuck. All right. Okay, fine. No, you need to wait your turn. Bend over. Spank. You need
to wait your turn. I'm trying to give people a chance on the pages because I'm... Please don't
worry. I'm streaming a heck of a lot. Right. Okay, we've got our team. Our team name is gonna be...
It's gonna be what? It's gonna be Dart because I unlocked Anna's
darts, okay? Your download's halfway there. Halfway there. We get spanked if we join early.
Literally bend over. Team Cuntlefish. Is that because I... Oh my god. As in... You mean like as
in I'm serving, right? Surely. As in I'm serving. I'm just being so good. Can I join next game?
It's random how you get added. You just gotta be patient. And before anyone goes,
streamstipe... I literally do a streamstipe game every week. It's vermin tide the other week.
Next week is Elden Ring. The week after that, it's Deep Rock Galactica. The week after that,
it's the Minds of Moria. Denny, you come greeting me saying, Mummy, does they want to play with me?
Can we play Halo 2 instead? I might be able to do a streamstipe for Halo.
It would be incredibly hard though because there's only so many set missions.
I'm not sure how Halo would work out streamstipe. Unless we played the multiplayer
on Halo 5 or whatever game it is. There is a Halo multiplayer although I've never played it before
The missions? Yeah, you can call up missions in Halo. I love your accent. I bet you do.
You're like that Scottish twang to every word I'm saying. You're like, why does she
annunciate it like that? You want to know why? Spawnd in this country. Caught Scotland.
It's right above England. Next door at Ireland. Cross the wee bit of water. Northern Ireland as well.
I should do an arcade? No, I'm currently forced to do a quick play
roll queue because I haven't unlocked all the modes yet. Why, do you want to do an arcade?
Stormy didn't know that Halo had multiplayer? I mean...
Can you say water? Yeah, that's how I say water.
Wait, does she play with other people in Elden Ring? Yeah, you can invade me in Elden Ring.
We play together in Elden Ring. So what happens is if I suck at a game but then I can summon you
in to help me, then we play it together, okay? And that's exactly what we've been doing with Elden
Ring because there was a new DLC that came out but I had to take a break from it because I was a bit
too quick and there wasn't enough free ones to carry me. Well, actually, no, that's a lie. There
was enough free ones to carry me. But people... I was getting marshmallows saying like, I can't
carry you because I'm not that far ahead yet and I don't want to like... I still want to enjoy the
Come on, three minutes. I'm humping my screen. God, I've not been funny. I've never had so many friends
before. See, in 53, I've never had so many fucking friends before. Yeah, damn. You ever seen a friends
list of friends before? That's kind of... It's kind of nearly naughty. Not gonna lie.
I'm kind of nearly naughty.
Oh my gosh. Oh my god, Ray Anatame. I'm sniping from halfway across the map. It's up to you guys
what you want to be. Have fun. Have at you. Well, I just got home from falling off the stairs so
can't play. What? Do you need to go to hospital? You don't got any head damage, right? You don't
got a concussion. You'll be alright, right? No blood and stuff. If you ever sustain an injury,
especially if you walloped your head like a big knock to it, don't be shy to show up to the
the old accident and emergency. That's rather dangerous. My friends list is full of scammers.
Wait, what? How do you... Oh, I didn't know I meant to do that. Hey, do I need to turn down
in-game audio or anything? Or... What a booze. Oh my god, it is German Reflings. Hello. Oh my god,
got the tunes. I don't have an emote. Hold on. How do I dance? This is my best I can do to enjoy
your music. I better not be copyright or cry. Oh my god. Oh, we've got sneaky Sombra. We've got a
bit of a switch up. Okay, we've got enemy. Oh, dear. We've got... Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute. Get me on that floor. Get me on that floor. Get me on that floor, right?
Where's the other refling? There's a reefer? Don't fret. Don't fret. I'm not. Okay. Okay. Oh my god,
it's been a while since I've done Anna. Can you tell? Fuck it. I'm just eating that naive.
I didn't hit no one. Right, I'm just going to break the rain shield and heal my rain.
Oh my god, they're going to fucking come for me. Oh my god. They're doing the toy behind
strat. Right, hold on. I can do this. Hold on. I'm reloading. I'm scared they're going to start
looking at me. Oh, not bad. Not bad. Not bad. Not bad. I'm healing. I'm healing. I'm healing so hard.
Oh no, no, no, no. The enemy fucking bastard. The fucking Baptists took your heal. I could have
saved you. I let you down. Wait, how did you respawn so fast? Am I going mental or did you
respawn like so fast there? Fuck you, bitch. Who gets the nano? I don't know. Maybe I'll just,
I will go with my instinct. Right, I'm destroying the shield. Fuck you, go sleep.
I'm throwing an aid. I'm helping. I'm helping. I'm healing. I'm healing. I'm healing. I promise you
I was healing. I'm so sorry. I promise you I was healing. Okay, we're out here. Right, Lucy was
unironically saving my ass, though. Other reflins, I can't get you out there. I promise I was
healing you. Oh my god, the reflins off of Reinhardt. He really said your kills were that shit, bitch.
Oh my god, they're doing the turret, but this is my message.
I do have a nano, but I need to break that shield. Maybe that, we need to do the Torbjorn
turret strat, sorry, but if we get up, oh my god, I literally cannot keep up.
Right, back up, back up, everyone. I mean, if you want to attack them, I'm done for it.
Right, I'm getting the turret, the turret. There we go. He's doing what I always want to do with
the turret. Am I nanoing? I don't know, fuck it. Someone got nanoed. Enjoy it. It's not my problem.
It's not my problem. It's your problem. Look, I'm enabling you to do your crazy thing. I'm just
doing it from back here. That's all. Oh, she doesn't. I'm healing. I'm healing. I'm at the Fidget
Spinner, don't worry. This is called the Fidget Spinner. Back in my day on Overwatch, this map
is called... I'm somehow able to heal you. I'm throwing a nade. I'm not sure if it's going to
hit you, but I'm healing. Oh, the ping. Oh, I just put the equipment to sleep. I repeat,
I just put the mechanical equipment to sleep. I deserved it. Okay, okay, okay. Oh, that's so...
Don't even need me. Don't even need me.
Gorgeous. Oh, team kill. Gorgeous. Gorgeous. I'm fucking healing. I'm fucking healing.
Call me a custard because I'm absolutely creaming, okay? I hear lots of footsteps.
Okay, I'm going to try and break Reinhardt's shield whenever he puts it up.
Fuck you, Arissa. I'm throwing a nade. I'm helping. Oh, that was far too high. You want to lower that
a bit, darling? Hold on. Reloading. Reloading. Oh, I'm recharging so hard right now.
Hey, Arissa, stop it. I'm trying to heal from afar for a reason. Don't give me that look.
Don't give me that look.
Hold on, I'm healing. I'm healing so hard right now. Oh my god, five player kill streak. Hold on,
a hydration trick. We flexing on the mid game. Are they changing? No, they're sticking to their
guns. Yeah, they've probably got a few ults coming in. Someone's asleep. Someone's asleep. She
sticks away from attack dogs. Bro, I made that joke as well. I was like, oh, five kill streak.
I'm getting a care pack in. Yeah, fuck it. Go. I'm trying to heal. I'm healing so fast.
I'm half getting burnt, half not. Are we winning? I don't know if we're winning this fight or not.
Uh, back up. Back up. Okay, go. It's fine. Just going.
Oh my god, that looks so weak. Caracal. Yes. Yes, yes, yes. Okay. Okay, we can do this. We can do
this. We can do this, Starland. Come on. You've got it. I believe in you so hard right now,
Reflins. I believe in you so hard. We so have this. We are, oh, oh, oh, oh, cheeky, cheeky. We are
so javelin right in my heart. Oh my god. No, I actually believe in you so much. You can so do
this. I believe in, I'm coming. I'm coming around. I'm coming around the corner when I come. I'm dead,
so you only have one heal, but I promise you, you've got it. Lucio, Lucio red, right through
the wall. Lucio through the wall. Get right. Let me be handle. Oh, let me be handle.
I never have an original thought. It's okay. Neither do I honestly. I might as well just be
right. Deva is de-mecked. Warning. Deva is de-mecked. Okay, I'm throwing an aid. Hopefully it's not too
high. No. No, this cannot be. Oh no, no, no. I'm reloading. I think someone's coming for me,
but not in the good way. No, no, no, no, baby. No. Oh, it's the ping. I'm blaming the ping. I'm
blaming them. I'm off. I'm off. I'm away at the park. I'm away for a wee ride. I'm away for a
ride. I'm taking the time off my ride. Sombra, bro. Sombra, you're in so much trouble. Please be
careful. Be careful. I need the tanks coming. I need to be back. I need to be back. I must,
I must play safe. I'm helping, I'm helping the team so much though. Right, I'm breaking the
rain shield, breaking the ranch shield. I'm breaking the ranch shield.
Fuck it. Go in. Someone do something. Oh my god. Sombra, you're, right, someone, all right, fuck it.
Okay, and then Tarbjorn. Tarbjorn. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. That's right. Make him regret being born,
baby. All right, who can I hit? I feel a warm, me after the reef. Bro, there's too many. It's too
easy. It's too easy. Hey there. Hey, is that your stream sniper cone? Sin and sister. Did
you make a fucking side account? No way. Right, Sin's getting in. Oh my god. Streamer has a bias.
Damn right. Streamer has a bias. Make him regret being born. Make him regret being born. There's
no tanks. There's no tanks. Don't let him, don't, don't give him an inch. Don't give him an inch.
Give me five instead. You know what I'm saying? How did that miss the heal and the three enemies
in the jet? Oh, hold on. I can't, I can't heal you. I can't see it. You need to go for that healing
pack. I can't see it. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Get that, get that Torbjorn. That's right. Stagger him. When
you delay a kill on purpose, it's called a stagger. Not to be confused with swagger,
jagger. The hit sung by Sherloid, sung by Sherloid. Which one are you? Did uh, oh my god. Sorry,
I missed everything. Erchar! Erchar! Get him! Okay, thank you. I'm safe now.
I love life. I'm safe. Nothing can hurt me. Hold on. Okay, a few things can hurt. A few things can
hurt. Uh, why is this a rip? No, sorry, Kereco. You're getting all it says. You're not going down.
I refuse. Kereco's staying up. Is that? No. See this Torbjorn? More like, more like,
sorry, I really get it. I love this game. I've not brainwrote it in for long. And now I get to
force you to brainwrote on with me. Okay. Okay, let's go. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, 30 seconds.
30 seconds. The comeback is real. The comeback is real. Now you're not allowed in the group.
You have to wait to be invited. You have to wait. You must have patience. Patience. Patience. I'm a
world of Warcraft Panda. Patience. Okay. Get him. Oh my god. Get the Torbjorn! Torbjorn! Focus on Torbjorn!
Brainheart! Brainheart! I'm getting out of the way of the stun.
Bonk. Get out. Get out. Get the Rusa! Get the Rusa! Melee! Fister! Fister horse!
Oh my gosh. Call me Mr. Hansy. I'm fisting that horse.
You ever wonder why your subconscious does those things to you?
Bleh. Bleh. Forbidden Lord.
Right. Don't spam Invite me, please. I don't want to do it like that.
Oh my god. Is this one of us? It is! It's a rifling! Hit him with a bomb!
Hit him with a... Right. Your dunsel.
Um... Oh no, I didn't mean to do that. Hold on. Continue cause... Thank you. Oh got
Hanzo! Right. I'm Hanzo next game. Hold on. Don't spam Invite. That's not how you do it.
Thank you so much. Arigatou gozaimasu. And then boom. And then boom. And a bat boom being
we need... Did you play? No. You need to let me Invite you, darlings. I need to be fair to
everyone. We're Sin. And me. I need to be fair to everyone. Also me. Sin getting this fucking game
right now. Right. Sin... Did I even write your name down? Right. Who? We did T and W.
Did we do Ws? I've got a Zed. I'm not done a Zed in the film. Purely on the basis that your name
begins with Z. Then we'll go back to the start. D and D. I've not had you.
Fox robot? Have I had you? No. No I have not. Wait what? Did someone come in that? I didn't...
Rev, you need a wait or you're gonna get blocked? I'm not being funny. You need a wait or you're
gonna get blocked. I'm no... I'm no doing it like that. Okay. Fox robot. D and D roles. We both have
new account. So we're going to... Never get to watch how good Sin is in 4K. In literal 4K.
And then Sin. And then together we're going to be called Sin's imps. Tee hee imp pits. Ta-da!
Team Sin's imps. Right play. Go. Oh! We can do roll queue? Right. I'm hands... 18 fucking minutes!
Fuck. No. Bro. 18 minutes if I pick DPS. I thought this game wasn't dead. I thought they just released
Juno! Sin is grand master. Yeah grand master at debating. Thank you. I'll be here all week.
Okay well. Dead game. Literally 18 minutes. 18 minutes! Grand master shagging your nan.
That was good. That was good. I'll give you that one.
Quickly has a hidden MMR. So that's why it would take so long to match you up to someone with the same skill.
Why would it already give an estimate that's the other side of the team which is already full?
Really? I require a video right now. Damn. It's two minutes for me. Does it? Well it's actually...
Hold on a minute. Hold on. My fellow Americans. It's only saying that because I'm in Australia.
But you guys aren't in Australia. I'm playing Hanzo. Get wrecked. I don't know what Sin wants to play.
I'll find out in a second. Sin is gonna go tank or healer. Come on. Make your choice,
Fox robot. Make your choice. Sin 100% Adiva main. Doesn't she have a Adiva chair?
Ah yes, Hanzo. Master of bull job. Whoa! Hold on a minute there. I have to go tank or heal.
You two little DPS all walk. Wait. Should I stop D&D role? D&D, your account better not actually
be new. We're about to judge your profile. You locked in D8...
You locked in... Are you? What?
Why have you done? How do you do it? What? Wait, what does my profile look like then?
Oh my god, I look like an e-girl. Oh my god! I'm so very clearly a freaking e-girl. Look at the
line-up. Get my head, my head. I mean, not to brag about 42 minutes in Unranked.
What in Sim? Level one on a hero. What? I'm gonna unlock Perks on them? Yeah, I don't think so.
Nah, I want you on Hanzo. Oh my god, I said the port.
You are Zarya. Maybe they're trying to find a full party to fight you. Do you want Sin and
voice chat? Oh, I could just straight up Discord call you. Do you want to be in a Discord call?
Do you want to be in a Discord call? Oh, no, not a good time. It may not be a good time. Hold on a minute.
Whoopsies! I have tons of DMs out of my face.
Let's see if I make collabs. All right, hold on. Where is she?
Where the fuck is- There you are. I'm typing to- I don't know if you're appearing offline on Discord.
Why are you always hiding? Wow, something.
Oh, you made the end face. You made the- Oh.
Oh, you made the end face. Okay, okay, let's see if we can hear Sin. And don't fucking-
Don't- Wait, I can't- Hello?
Oh, you're quiet. Wait, hold on. Let me bust you. Test.
I have my shite. I literally sound like I'm playing CSGO with this fucking microphone right now. Holy
shit. I sound like I'm playing-
This is like a CSGO mic. Oh my god, it's ready. This microphone was fucking 10 quid.
Do you have- Do you have skin, bro? Bro, do you have skin? Bro, give me skin.
What about the echo on your make-up tone? Geeky and all.
Um, don't act like you don't want more of me.
Bro, of course I'm-
Don't act like you don't hear me twice in your ear, too.
Oh my god.
Wait, sorry. Oh my god.
No, no, don't- No, no, no, it's because I'm reading DMs. I've missed out all the DMs from the girls because I never looked at this-
I nearly left a call out of embarrassment.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Uh, sorry. It's fucking- I didn't look at anyone's DMs because I was so excited to play Overwatch this morning.
Uh, and it's just all the girls are-
Is this Discord kitten?
Yeah, I can fucking hear my echo like mental.
Zarian, thank you for the five. Oh my god, is that Sin's sister Discord kitten? Love you.
Are you at Discord? Wait, they call you Discord?
Bro, I'm gonna go Mercy now and I'm gonna just fuck at you the whole time.
Stop!
I'll go like, oh, missed a shot, missed a shot.
Oh, oh, oh my god, but you can play the heal slag game.
Bro, we were- right, not to leak any member's content.
Apparently, there's an entire, like, GitHub thing that, like, goes with a above sense wink-wink.
And literally, as you heal, you get rewarded and if you resurrect, it goes like 100% on Mercy and shit like that.
I was fucking hee-ho and I was like, bro, we're doing that right now. So, actually-
I'm up right now.
Yeah, the truth is me- the truth is me and Sin genuinely have it right now. Hold on.
I wanna hear that.
Oh my god.
It's literally down my throat.
It's fucking- I'm fucking neon blue. They changed the damage.
I'm deep-throating this bad boy.
Well, well, well, how do you got crumbs in it?
Oh my god, not to-
It's kind of like a cheeky little cheeto when I'm gaming.
A cheeto? Not cheese and onion baked walkers, Chris.
Mmm, you know what I mean? I smokey bacon breath, mm-mm.
Smoky bacon is actually right. If you've not got the opportunity to try crisps from the fucking UK-
Do you know what is- bro, I can't hit in the air. Are you joking?
And my ping is 200. I don't know what your ping is.
She missed the shot.
Literally. Every time I miss a shot, I have to spank myself.
Oof, I'm not gonna survive by the end of this.
I wish that- I wish I was that mic.
Oh my god, they won you a deep throat, yeah.
Johnny, you seem like you're frazzled.
You seem like you're frazzled, gal.
Yumi, I assure you it's just frazzled.
Banged! Oh my god, she's in the ground!
What the fuck?!
What are you?!
Bro, is that a refling stream sniping? Why are you all over the house?
Are you dead?
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm getting pr-
I'm getting pr- oh my god, I'm coming!
I mean-
Every time you miss a shot, I have to fucking pray!
I'm- I've been there a breath already!
Oh my god, I'm actually getting kills though, a wee bit.
Like, they're walking into my arrows.
This is actually going really well, sorry.
They keep walking into my- they keep walking into my arrow!
I'm walking on sunshine.
Oh my god, it's after- it's after me again.
It's after me again.
What is it?!
Where did it go?!
Carrying me harder!
It keeps coming back!
She got it! She got it!
What the fuck is it?!
Right, get out of here. Sorry, I don't know what that round ball is.
Sorry, I'm saving my res for scrawny.
I- oh.
No, no, res.
Did Eva just try and eat my late dragon?
Oh, oh, I'm getting whacked.
No, get off that petal.
Get off that platform.
I'm- I'm de-platforming you.
You're getting cancelled, literally. I'm de-platforming you.
What is this ultimate?!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god, I'm like- I'm picking up-
I'm picking up another e-girl.
I'm your e-girl! I'm your kitten, yo!
Did you ever see-
Mommy, daddy!
Did you ever see those TikToks?
That were like-
bark for mommy if you want to heal
then overwatch.
And then it's a guy going like-
You know what?
Why am I-
No, I need to change up now.
Can you fly to me?
You're not going to get the heals, sweetie.
Until you learn how to hit one shot.
Until you deserve it.
You have to show me.
This opportunity-
I'm missing all my shots.
I'm hiding, sorry. I'm hiding.
I don't know who's with me.
We're dead, Astro, I'm so sorry.
We're so dead.
I'm not good enough for this.
Oh my god, we survived.
Wait, I survived, you died.
It was a sacrifice I was willing to make.
I'm sorry, it had to be this way, but-
Right, D.Va.
Orph! Orph! Orph! Orph!
Oh my god, I'm meowing.
Meow, meow!
Why did I go ear?
Cats don't go ear, I assure you.
Meow, meow.
Ornian!
Did you know in Japanese frogs say
Kero Kero?
Bro, I'm actually getting-
I'm actually getting fucking kills though.
What's going on?
Right, I'm not getting kills anymore. I got a bit too excited.
Alright, I got another one.
Look at that shot!
Bro, get the freaking
mole wrap.
VTuber.
Confirmed for Gen 4 by the way.
Are we winning?
Is this approaching final destination?
Wasn't that a hit movie?
Someone is stuck in front of that.
Oh, I'm hiding behind a corner.
Sauce, I'm hiding behind a corner.
Bro, what's going on?
Wait, did they nerf? Did they boost hands?
All my shots are hitting, but I'm not actually-
Oh my god, she's coming for me.
She's raging at me, Sauce, but you're going down hen.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Hold on, I'm coming!
I'm coming, I'm de-platforming!
Right, close enough, I'll take it.
Right, I'm using dragon!
Imagine dragons!
RIDI AWAKEN!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
Fuck you!
Let me just type in
fucking-
That was so fucking good.
Oh, I got clean again!
Let's go!
Let me endorse some sin.
I'm literally on blue.
Oh, look at that aimbot.
Look at that aimbot.
Are you ready? One more for good luck!
Boom!
Only took me 10 shots per kill.
Oh my god!
Wait, I'm not-
Stop the count!
Right, are you coming for another one?
Are you satisfied?
Okay, one more for the roads.
I'm sorry, friends, we're taking a spot.
Okay, come on!
I'm playing for hours, it's fine.
I'll try to get me back in then.
Right.
Right, where are you?
Where are you?
Then, right, one more.
And then, who have I not looked at?
I've not looked at Ss, so actually...
Squishy, are you getting in?
Have I had a T in? I've not had a T.
Submissive!
Right, will we just do a full S gang?
Hold on.
I'm looking to see if I've got any more Ss.
Then you come.
Sniper?
I can look at your stream just to see how that makes sounds.
Oh my god.
I can hear myself in the background.
Yeah, that's right.
We're gonna be called S gang.
PG.
Paid actors, are you joking?
Sorry, but we're actually rolling and smoking.
I don't care what I'm doing.
We're doing so good.
And considering I've not played the game in literal years yet,
but I'm humping the screen.
I've got an embarrassing confession to make that I still play Overwatch in 2024.
Wait, casually, how often?
I still play every night!
Oh!
Do you actually?
I'll be your heel slut this time, how about that?
Oh my god!
I'll be your heel slut.
I'll be your heel slut. Hold on, let me add these.
Right, I'm walking in DPS.
No.
Everyone's...
No pressure.
And then I'll boot root and then I'll be in all fucking pre-recorded.
We're getting paid to die for her.
Literally died for me and the enemy team.
I have like 10 Overwatch accounts.
This one's dead. If you check my account, this one's dead.
Dead.
I mean, not like to brag, but if you're going competitive,
I'll be in season 5.
Look at my support rank.
I'm not good.
I'm Overwatch League.
I'm Lichu Overwatch League.
Oh my god, that makes sense.
It's awful in that frame.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Oh my god, she's doing work.
I'm Lichu, I'm fucking...
I did not realise how many DMs I had
until I opened it up to get you in a call.
I was like, ooh, the girls have been waiting on me.
Tee hee.
Tee hee, not my problem soon.
T-9 is like what, two weeks?
Tee hee.
And then I'm getting a manager.
Uh...
No, no.
Alpha Foxy.
I only won it.
Bro, one of the editors
got back about AC's scripts.
The fucking scriptmaster.
I shit you not, the scriptmaster.
Oh wait, what?
Oh, AC took it
out of contact.
Huh.
This is why you can't even stream and
fucking do the same thing.
Why they all get patched.
They'll get ding-dong ditched.
Tee hee.
This is just way more important,
you know, like you can wait in the queue
no longer.
Right, okay, I'm back.
Re-mail and stream.
Mail and stream is the fucking editor.
That's why there's man in manager hen.
Got noticed by noon.
Oh, you can't be saying that.
That's an inside thought, that'll get you cancelled soon.
That'll get you cancelled.
Oh no, what am I gonna do about Natalie?
No, that would be pure bogging.
You know how we
collabed on Dead by Daylight, like a wee bit ago?
Yes. How long ago was that?
Hold on, I'm analising.
Um, well,
let's just clock me last had Shark Week and then...
You know why I ask?
I'm a fucking ketchup packet right now.
Oh fuck!
Right.
I was so fucking embarrassed but now that you've said it,
I'm like, you know what,
I'm in pain. I'm on painkillers right now.
I'm sore.
You're right, kitten.
You're right.
Who are you? You're Ash?
You're Ash, okay.
Oh my god, they've changed this game so much.
Hi, Reefland.
Hi, S Gang. See, I'm Stronny.
We're all S's.
Snapeham, Scuttlefish,
Submissive, Sinning, Sister,
Squashy, like, come on!
Right, where are you?
The Monthly Collab,
brah.
Am I allowed to ruin what happened in Blake in 2 weeks' time?
I may or may not be doing that collab with
them and two other YouTubers.
There's something going on in the water.
You just comfort me so much, okay?
You just... I've never played this
freaking map. I am literally
heal-bought so hard. I'm just going to fly.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Hold on, any heal, Reefland? Keep her up.
Where are you?
Wrong one.
Okay.
Oh!
Who are you?
Sorry, right.
I'm making Scottish references
that are hilarious.
So there's, like,
random... I don't know.
It's, like, chance. It must be food.
Whoa! There's a freaking trampoline!
Oh my god, Sos.
I'm actually... excuse me.
Oh yeah, trampoline!
Trampoline!
Enemy over there.
Why is that not pinging?
There's a Pharah over there.
Oh my god, speaking of pockets...
Look at all Pharah, bitch.
Sorry. Literally, there's two hit scans.
There's two hit scans and they're sitting on Pharah.
Trampoline!
Trampoline! Please don't get headshot.
I'll cry. Oh no, I have res. It's fine. Get headshot. Go crazy.
Just give up.
Give up.
Oh! Oh!
I'm not getting caught out, though.
I'm not getting caught out.
Oh, Echo! Echo's going to make a difference!
Wait, they went...
Bro.
The Echo's in this distance.
Chat off, Mamek.
Oh my god.
You're so fucking way!
Fuck's sake, I wish I had your brain, honestly.
I'm just all in, Sos. I'm all in.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I got an achievement. I got an achievement.
Well...
Oh, I'm resin. I'm resin in front of the hands though.
What a cheeky sod I am.
No, I said I'm going for the hands off, right. Got it.
Got me, sticker.
Thank you, the Bailor.
Oh, you tingling over.
Oh my god, please.
Go ahead.
Bro.
Oh! Moira! Moira, I'm coming.
I'm coming. I'm coming.
In one. In one.
I'm doing it. I'm doing it in a bit.
I just found my one.
It's fucking easy.
Bro.
Sos, but there's nothing...
They can't even do nothing about this heel slag, okay?
They get nervous.
They start quaking in the lobby when they say mercy on
Scuttlefish, okay?
They say mercy. They say default pose.
Hit them with the default level 3.
Yeah. Look at those heels.
2.8
K heels.
Took me a second there.
That was 2.7.
I'm still the better mercy though.
I'm still better, okay?
It's not a pinky thing, but it both happened and died, you know?
Have I actually not?
Bro, I kept you up so much that we didn't die.
That's that new character.
I'm creeping around.
I can smell you.
That's right.
Bark for heels.
You're just slugging.
You're just turning into a fucking Chihuahua.
Where are you?
Oh, right. I found you. Sorry.
I'm staring at you.
I had no idea what was going on.
I was just having a good time.
Amora will come to me for healing
and we'll be normal in the enemy team.
Thank you.
That venture does not gear rats ours.
She said not my problem.
Hold on.
No way.
Oh no!
It's all coming down.
I need to heal.
I need to heal as much as I love being a healer.
Oh my God.
Teleporter.
Symmetra teleporter.
True.
I'm Jennifer Coolidge.
I'm getting pissed on by Moira.
I'm going to get in peace.
I'm going to damage again.
Adventure damage time.
But not to be confused with the hit TV show Adventure Time.
Because I booted up my PC
to play Overwatch
when my reef lands.
Adventure Time.
Sorry, that's the best I got.
Where is my little Ash?
I'm having him.
I don't trust that.
I feel like someone's about to ult.
I'm preemptively ulting in exchange of someone ulting.
Oh my God.
Okay.
That was cheeky.
Oh my God!
Literally team kill.
I feel like we're trolling so much
and it's going really well.
Oh my God.
You can't sit.
That's so toxic.
Since sister cancelled.
I'm literally so tired.
It's so easy.
Easy clap.
Oh my God! They're coming behind!
I can't.
I'm fucking somewhere!
Right, I've got the hands though.
I've got the turrets.
Okay.
They were no match.
I got an achievement for that as well.
They were genuinely
no match.
Wait, what did we do to them?
Oh my God.
I feel so bad.
I want to type like,
have good luck in your next games or whatever
but I'm not even got comms yet.
Wait, like me! She's British!
Let's go.
Excuse me?
Oh!
Oh yeah!
We got the sticker.
We got the sticker as well.
Oh my God, 5 minutes on mercy bro.
I'm actually sorry. I'm so good at this game.
Oh my God, I'm level 3.
Reward is a premium.
Yeah, I'm not paying for a fucking reward. Jesus.
Oh God! Junkrat!
Right, I'm doing DPS now.
Okay, thank you so so much.
Oh my God, she's leaving.
Right, I'm going to leave her boys.
I'm leaving.
Oh, that was it.
She's already left the call.
That was it.
That was the...
I mean, that was fucking fun. I enjoyed it.
Me and Senna are a fucking broke.
Maybe we should start fucking being...
Yeah, damn, buddy.
Overwatch professionals.
Why were we getting so lucky?
We ate the mic for a goodbye.
Right, who...
Who the fuck has not been in?
I maybe should have done this alphabet.
But then I wouldn't be able to name your teams very well.
I feel like
there's a lot of years that I've been waiting
and I'm so worried that I'm going to time out
because
you guys don't have time to like
wait to play.
Because it's not a weekend, is it? It's a weekday.
I wanted to give...
Oh, it's technically the weekend for me.
And smoked.
I wish there was...
Bastion logo, really?
It's Friday.
Wait, has everyone finished work in the world yet?
I don't need to be...
I don't need to be pan, okay?
Right, Chuggy.
Right, one from page one.
One from page two.
Caraca.
You respect it and that's why I'm getting confused with you.
One from this page.
Piano man, you've
definitely not written your name down.
And then...
Do you want to try again, Van der Leyen?
Because we couldn't get you in.
Right, who...
Alright, okay.
We've got Van der Leyen.
I think maybe that's how I should do it.
I should just do one from each page.
And then that's the best way I can do it.
I don't know what country that is, but...
Oh!
No, you can't come in. I don't know why.
That was Funko long three, I was sub.
Yeah?
Neko voodoo.
Thank you for the
super chat. Did you enjoy it?
Did you enjoy it?
It popped off.
Capital...
Right, okay. Who is...
the K page? Right, you could get...
Kalker, you've not had a shot.
And who...
Reserved someone on page four?
No, Van der Leyen was page four.
Who's page three?
Piano man, so page one, who didn't come in?
Who didn't come in?
Did I pick someone from page one?
A14N.
I don't think I recognize you, darling.
Okay.
A14N.
And together, we make the screamers.
Screamers, and then in brackets, while we ink.
I'm sorry for being so loud this stream.
I'm just really happy.
I apologize.
If it...
I apologize if this type of stream ain't your thing.
I'm just really happy.
Right, I'm playing Junkrat.
So...
You guys can bicker between yourselves.
What rules do you want to play, but I'm playing Junkrat.
You having fun and being loud is the best.
I'm almost tempted to hop on in the soft.
Oh my, thank you for the 10 gifted memberships.
Thank you.
Congrats to those who caught it with their face.
Wait a minute, hold on a minute.
I just had a vision.
I can't.
I'm pretty sure I was like one membership off of getting...
Wait, is it gonna...
Oh, it's probably not gonna register right away.
I'm pretty sure I was like one gifted
membership off in your moat.
Wait.
No.
What?
Oh, so it's unlocked the next one,
but it's not letting me add it.
Hey, up Mars, up Mars.
Okay, we're doing it.
You're and Mummy so happy.
Devices have...
Yeah, literally, you need to turn down the volume in this room.
Cause once I start popping off, it's bloody ogre.
It's bloody ogre.
Your energy is incredible.
It's just brain raw.
It's just overwatch brain raw.
I'm glad that you enjoyed them.
Too many moats in two and a half.
As I said, I'm happy to keep fucking going.
I am really...
I'm a happy being right now.
I don't think...
I plan on stopping anytime soon.
Um...
I'm just...
fucking checking the comments.
Of course the Scott uses a potato
as an example of a hardy vegetable.
Um...
Actually...
Ireland.
Um...
Makes for a solid background noise.
I am screaming my head off,
but I'm glad I can help you focus on something.
Uh...
Wow, thanks so much.
You'd think the company would pay for that kind of thing,
but they say the members pay walls
to filter people like me.
Hullary.
People are gonna fucking believe the shit you start spouting.
Got to play so I can
go to the vet appointment.
Happy?
Getting hydration checked.
Yeah, I'm chugging that cola.
I'm on rat do junk because I just unlocked them.
I'm Aussie.
Plenty of bombs to go around.
Would you still love me if I
sounded like this?
Fucking hell, can't get A's.
Fly, my good friend.
Thank you, crazy jet.
Thank you, crazy Jesse
for the super jets.
No, you were not like...
Ha!
Hobby door.
Oh my god.
Oh, hitting with it.
Oh, that was vivid.
VV fucking VTuber.
VV collaboration with Diablo.
VV, VTuber.
You know what I mean.
You guys saw the outfit.
You did. You know exactly what I mean.
We're spamming.
Right, if anyone decides to go in there,
they're getting caught.
Aussie is my favourite English accent.
Oh!
Someone's on the point, not to...
Right, I'll deal with it.
Fuck!
Fuck, this is what I fucking hate about
tracers, they're so weed.
I still tickle their balls more than like...
I'm just trying to get her with my mines.
Oh!
Oh, that's true. Oh!
Oh my god, the hansels are fighting back.
The hansels are fighting back.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry, I fucked up that one.
That was on me.
Mummy dabong!
Vividly ASMR. Yes!
She did a collaboration with El Diablo
and it looks like that Moira skin,
but I'm sure it's based after like an actual character in the series.
Right, oh my god, look at the damage I'm doing.
Oh!
Oh, that's right. That's right. You need to suck up my bombs.
Oh, I got one hit.
That's the best I got.
Okay, hansel's going to try and snipe me again.
Honestly, fair, valid.
I'm spamming. I'm spamming.
I got a kill. I got a kill.
Don't mind me, darlings.
Don't mind me.
That's right. I'm going to pop that right there.
Shh! Don't sell anyone.
Their tracer shacks are cousin on the weekend.
Oh, you're getting a bit...
Getting a bit of regen.
That's all right. You don't like to be regen.
Oh, diva bomb? Question mark. Diva bomb soon.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, I'm alive.
I'm dead. Oh, I'm alive again.
I'm watching TV.
We're doing it. We're doing it.
We're doing it.
I can hear footsteps.
I knew it. I knew it.
I knew it, you slag.
That's right. You better recall.
Diva bomb! Diva bomb!
I knew it. I knew it.
You better recall. Diva bomb! Diva bomb!
Possibly! Possibly!
He's coming up the stairs.
Okay. Okay.
Uh-huh. Tell him how you really feel.
Tell him how you really feel! Right. I'm dead. It's fine.
It's fine. It's fine. It's fine.
I did really bad. That was really poor movement.
If I was...
You red! How?
If...
If I do, like, peeky stuff like that...
Right, I'm out of here.
Up! Up! Get me in the air so Mercy can get up in the air as well.
If I do peeky stuff like that,
I... Trigger!
Trigger!
Oh my god. I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry. I'm... I promise I'm...
I'm helping. I'm getting out of here.
I'm getting out of here. I'm getting out of here.
I'm spamming. I'm spamming.
If you can't tell,
Junkrat really isn't my main source, but I didn't play him.
I don't know... Another of these particularly bad
or anything of that nature
didn't really go for it.
I just kind of... I just kind of suck, you know?
I just kind of suck, you know?
Sometimes you swallow on a hero
and sometimes you suck on a hero.
I'm afraid I ain't eating this time.
Oh, Mercy! Careful!
Jumping off the map!
She's not down there, is she? No.
Right, okay. Right, we can now go in there, spawn and fuck him up.
Oh, come on. I got one hit.
I'm doing terrible with the aim.
What is my... 90%
25 I throw, I get one hit.
Present for ya!
And no one's doing a back cap.
Although...
Oh, shit!
Look, I got the kill.
I got the kill.
That's the main thing.
That's the thing.
Get in there, Moira. Get in there.
Oh my god, I have my ultimate. Holy shit, we're down. Holy shit, we might lose this.
Holy... Holy cycle.
Better to pee in the sink than sink in the pee.
Unless... I heard that.
You need to get a rest, Eva.
Get a rest!
Get a fucking rest, Arlen.
Get a rest! Get a rest. No, you're actually upsetting me.
Fuck you, bitch.
No, get a rest. Oh!
I bet you were going to be on this side of the map now!
Get off my payloads!
Stop being so obvious!
Get off my payload, you wimp.
You wimp, fart!
Get off my payload!
I am the tank. I am the tank.
The only tank.
Right, I am very worried about a back cap.
So we're going to put a trap right there.
That was a little too close to the wall.
Fucking predicted!
Actual predicted, sauce.
But you want to try again, Tracer?
Look, I'll put it here this time.
So you can see it this time.
Yeah, you want to try and do a back cap?
Again, nice try.
Nice try. Right, I'm going to spam over the castle
and pray I get a hit or a kill.
Maybe, I don't know.
Rough.
I don't have any voice lanes to spam yet.
What is it? See?
Tick tock.
Me after stream from my brain rot.
Tick tock, tick tock, tick tock.
Come at me!
Oh!
Oh, behind again!
No, no, no. I saw you, you wee slag.
No, no, no, no, no. Come here.
Come here, you wee slag.
If you want a piece of this.
Oh, she's in the trap.
No, she made it out of the trap.
I can't believe it.
Sometimes...
No, we're not doing this.
I don't care if I have 200 ping.
You're getting abs.
You're getting wrecked! I don't care!
Get trap mined.
Get bombed in the air.
Don't care.
I'm Junkrat.
I'm having a good time.
MLG pro.
Hit him with a 360 and the stamp.
That's right.
That's right. That's my Luke sensitivity.
Hit him with that.
Okay.
The payload just destroyed my...
thingy mobile bar.
That's my rude.
I'm just doing that preemptively in case
an enemy comes around the corner.
Because I ain't tolerating that.
Okay, I may get headshot by...
Head behind! Behind!
They're coming up the stairs!
Yeah, you're not the only one...
Right. Sorry, I really don't like...
Chase them!
Because they can redo their health thingy, which I hate.
Oh, you want it again?
You want this again, journal?
Ah, fuck you up.
You may come from Mars, but you ain't got a clue
how gravity works on air.
Motherfucker!
Soz.
But you ain't touching me.
You are not touching me.
I still think we can win.
No, no. I know we can win, Junkrat.
Hold it together.
Hear me, baby. Hold it together.
Oh my god, all the Overwatch brainroads coming back.
All the voice lines.
That was a Torbjorn voice line.
Shh.
Behind you!
Right, stop down to that tracer.
I'm gonna cry.
Stop down to the tracer. I'm greeting.
Just in case.
We gotta give her a few on the stairs.
Right, I'm gonna... Unfortunately, I've got 30.
I'm gonna need a few cheeky hits.
I have to admit, I'm gonna need a few cheeky hits.
Oh, oh, we got a cheeky on Mars.
We've got a cheeky on Mars.
I can't believe the healers are down.
That's all we need.
Mars is gonna try and go for the rest, but we're gonna get her sweat.
Oh fuck.
I was gonna say, but we're gonna...
Oh no, our mercy goes down.
Due to my foolishness, just like that,
I take my own team down.
Due to my overcockiness, my foolishness,
my ambitions, I must lay them to rest
like Morgan Elden Ring.
I must lay my foolish ambitions to rest.
I'm in trouble! Piss! Piss!
Piss! I do have ultimate, but I can't touch.
I can't touch. You're gonna have to stall on point.
You're gonna have to touch the pill!
Right, okay, we still have a full section.
Don't worry. Let's regroup.
Don't panic, get it. Get it. Why are you panicking?
Reflins.
Reflins, don't panic.
We can still win this.
They have two minutes to push the full payload.
We just need to group up and be a hashtag team.
And now, if I get wig snaked by Hansel,
because I went around this corner,
that's on me, okay, darlings?
But it's not over.
It's not over until the tank comes in.
I'm about to ult their fucking assholes so hard.
Okay, well, speaking of ults...
Okay, that's all we needed.
That's all we needed. We're using a lot of ults,
but that's okay. We're allowed to be overze...
We're allowed to...
Yes!
Okay, and now this is the best bit about Junkrat.
You can literally spam from here.
You can spam from here.
Oh, you can spam.
And then you'll get a few cheeky hits.
See, look, 14% ult charge.
Thank you, crazy Jessie,
for the super charge. Everyone panic.
They better panic, because I'm on the enemy team.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, do you want to come through this whole tracer?
No, get right. Get out of here.
I don't want to see you.
I don't want to see you in your tight, gorgeous little pants.
I don't want to see that.
No, no, tracer. Leave my mercy alone.
I don't want to see that, darling.
We have been here before.
Oh, my God, that mercy is floating in the air.
I'm missing everything.
200 p...
Am I there? No!
I did not really need to die.
I believe in you.
Okay, we do have a race.
Mercy's down!
Okay, oh no.
Okay, we need a regroup.
Stop fucking wasting.
I need to put my heart rate monitor on,
just to prove to you that I'm not doing this on purpose.
This is actually my heartbeat,
and how excited I am right now.
I need to be careful. I don't want to peek too much.
Okay, we've got EMP down.
No, yes! Mercy down. One healer down.
The second DPS.
He can't approach. It's too much.
It's too much. I didn't win again.
The ink!
Victory once again.
Cannot handle a cheeky endorsement here and there.
Don't mind if we do.
They can't handle us.
We twiddler mustaches.
That's not one of us.
No, it's not. Get out of here.
You're not one of us!
Go away. I don't want to see your play of the game.
I don't know you. You're not a wiefling.
Unless you're a wiefling that's stream sniping somehow,
then that's different.
Don't make your heart explode, honestly.
It's me!
And Junkrat.
I didn't unlock a new character, so I guess...
It's tank time!
GG!
Thank you for the GG.
Right, okay.
At the fortnight.
Metal pass.
I can't show you where my house is.
And I believe I might be sure.
Cause I need you there.
Cause I'd like to watch you mate.
Metal pass.
Okay.
Right, one person per page.
Is Captain Crusher been in?
Captain, have you been in here before?
I don't see no Captain Crusher.
God, we have five pages.
Hand kill.
Hearthstone.
You got taken off the roster, didn't you?
You did.
And you come.
Uh...
Next page.
A paying...
Hello?
Have I had pain killer?
I don't think so.
I don't think I've had you.
Okay, you guys are just sitting on buzzers.
So that's actually unironically helpful.
Uh, bettable.
I don't think I've had you either, Darwin.
I'm checking my list.
I'm trying to see which reef win has been laid.
But I don't think anyone...
If...
I would like to respectfully ask all reeflings.
If I invite you when you've already had a chance.
Please don't accept or please leave respectfully.
Just because...
If you're having fun playing with me.
I want to extend that fun to all reeflings.
And I want to make sure everyone gets a chance.
So we're going to call this team fun and fair.
Because we're the fun and fair team.
Aw, yes.
I'm checking my list.
Right, I unlocked Roadhog so it's my turn for tank.
And I get 100 exp to the battle pet.
They have a battle.
Is that a premium?
Right, so they're free for everyone.
Then there's rewards, challenges,
and then upgrade to premium with a winky...
They really said, you know you want to...
You want to give us more money.
Even though I paid the base fee of Overwatch.
That's right, give them.
I'm all mine. Hi, reeflings.
Kolker, thank you for the 10 gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught them with your...
Face.
Thank you, Kolker.
And my for the 10 gifted.
Very kind, very kind. Please enjoy the emotes.
Activates my super dodge.
Right, continue.
Show tutorial?
Sure, show me the tutorial on how to look at the battle pass.
Knock and go.
Welcome to the Overwatch Battle Pass.
The Overwatch Battle Pass rewards you for playing...
Play games to get more.
Okay, thank you for your tutorial.
Don't care.
Can I please leave?
Oh my god, sorry, that cut the queue.
Sorry, I didn't realize me mucking about on that would cut the queue.
Sorry, right, pick a rules, pick a rules.
Choose a rule, any rule, any rule is yours, really.
Cause I'm gon' play...
Roothog.
Of course it kicks out the game when you...
At the prospect of you spending some money on them.
They're like, oh, hold on a minute, you're not loud enough.
You ain't not loud enough in there.
They said, wait.
Hold on a minute.
Is it pause?
Just as a check, I believe my Shibidi Weepidees...
No, not that word.
Maybe live right now with a shooter.
Shibidi is live in four hours with an ASMR collab.
Okay, Amy might be up next.
I'm not sure.
My purr embers isn't feeling very well at the moment.
She might be up today.
No, she's not.
And then Azura is off.
And then Mercy...
Mercy Mooties.
Is on a...
Oh, I have the floor today.
Well, don't mind if I fucking do it.
Don't mind if I fucking do it.
You mean I can play Overwatch all day long,
without steamrolling over my gen mates
and being hyper shit?
I mean, I don't know.
To me, it sounds like a treat day.
I don't know, but maybe a cheeky Macca's breakfast?
I don't know.
I've got a cola.
I've got painkillers in my system.
I have the floor, so I don't feel mildly bad
for streaming for longer times.
Just read AC later.
My stream is actually getting changed tomorrow.
I can't do the exercise stream because...
So I have to change it to a smaller stream.
I think we might play the demo for Card Shop TGM.
It's literally the exact same as Supermarket Simulator.
It's my favourite kind of thing.
So tomorrow's Ring Fit stream will be delayed until next week because...
And I'll also delay Cult of the Lamb
because that's a longer one as well.
And, you know, some people, like myself,
suffer for 48 hours and then you feel fine.
So I just need to, you know, anyway, any spawn camp.
Instead of playing a game together,
how about I play with you?
I'm pretty sure I got your buttons all mapped out
in which ones to push at the right moment.
Oh my god, wait, what's that T-shirt?
T-shirt, gamer, play with me, like buttons, PNG, please.
I'm gonna stick that on my VTuber model so fast.
I found it, but is that a PNG?
It's not.
Okay, hear me out.
I know that...
It's not a PNG, but I might...
I know it's not a PNG.
I know, but come on.
Should I just leave it on?
I'll just sit in the corner here like this.
I know it's not a PNG.
I know, I'm sorry.
Yeah, do you want this?
Okay, Roadhog time, Roadhog time.
It's perfect. Yeah, you like that.
Jubilee's easy.
Okay, where am I?
Ah, I need to put something on my head that's from an overwatch character.
It's so hard to think PNG.
What, who has something in their hair?
What character has something in their hair that's easy to stick on my head?
Why can't you do Ring Fit, Yuntemaut season?
All I'm saying is that when Sin shows up,
the world starts to...
The Bluetooth device is connected when Sin shows up.
Okay, are we ready?
Now, unfortunately, the likelihood of us losing goes up quite exponentially when I'm sitting on the tank.
I'm not even kidding.
Okay.
That must be her portal, that Juno portal thing.
More like Sink sister.
That's perfect, perfect.
Okay, right, Roadhog.
I have... Oh, wait, you said he has a trap now.
I knew he was an offend, boys.
Okay.
What the fuck are you doing?
Hold on, can you leave?
Oh, I missed.
I've never gone against him before, and I'm scared.
Okay, thank God you guys are clutching up for me,
because, certainly, no me that's clutching up.
I did not know what was going for me.
I have 750 health, I've changed it.
Hmm.
I'm afraid tanks might no longer...
I'm good at... I'm fine with Zarya.
I'm not gonna lie, I hate Roadhog.
Wait, where's my right click?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Did I not have a right click anymore?
Did I not have a right click?
Is it gone?
Did they take it?
Never forget what they stole from you.
What? Or is my controls messed up?
His right click is gone?
Wait, so I just... I just spam like this the entire time?
What the...
Frick, Frick, Diddly-Duck, Tic-Tac, Paddy-Wack.
So, did I have like a longer shoot then?
Was it longer?
Sorry, I just left the engine on.
And I missed! That's embarrassing.
I'm so sorry, I just let you die.
I'm dumb. It's not because I hate you.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Wait, how do I heal?
Oh, this one. Why the Frick would it be that one?
Who? Where?
I can't get you, you weebam.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so sorry, I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
No, I'm not, I'm going in, I'm going in.
Reflin's going in, boss deep, so am I.
Right, I missed, I missed, sorry. Roadhog is not the character for me.
I can't either, I'm shy, sir.
No, no, no, I needed to reload.
Unlucky, unlucky.
I still don't know what Juno's ult is.
Oh, she's one HP in a dream.
No, no, no, no, no, what's going on here?
If you want to fight, fight me.
Shit, I'm in trouble.
I don't know what to do!
Where's the Mercy? Fuck you, Peach!
But if it's me, that's the Mercy.
Please be nice to me, I'm just an innocent little Mercy.
Hold to heal, literally, um, this is very...
That's what your hook is for.
I do make a good hooker, don't I?
Oh, right, no I don't, because I keep missing them.
Oh, get her, get her!
Oh, she got greedy, she got greedy!
She said I wanted that right, oh!
We cheeky enemy, we cheeky enemy to the left.
Oh, we cheeky enemy, we widow, we widow.
No, I said I'm going for her, fuck you.
Okay, I'm gonna just push the payload.
Unfortunately, right.
So the reason why, uh, who come when I do that?
What the fuck, I healed like my, oh my...
No, I'm trying to stun him from doing anything.
Right, and then Mercy, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy!
She popped out, oh!
Oh my god, he's gonna all, I don't know what it's all is, I'm scared.
I hate that kid!
Right, I'm not playing Roadhog ever again, sorry.
I can't, I can't do it, I can't do that, I'm too shy, so...
I'm too sheba.
Don't call me a sheba, you know?
Because that's a random deal.
What was that being?
Right, I don't know how to play, but...
Almost deathless, almost.
It's because the reflins do pay extra attention to me, though.
Like, there's no doubt about it.
Okay, we can kind of cut across this section.
Who goes there?
I don't know what is fire.
I'm gonna just spray to distract.
No, I miss.
I miss.
Beat up the tank, get rid of the tank.
As soon as you get done with the tank, you're fine.
Mercy!
Yes.
I'm sombra.
Oh, I'm still in gear, are we cheeky headshot?
Aye, that's what you get.
That's what you get, you fandom.
Oh!
Well, I gotta wee hint though.
I gotta wee...
I gotta wee lickin', so I gotta wee assist.
I forgot you don't really...
Yeah, literally, I'm like, I'm...
I'm gonna have my own soon, surely.
Where's my health?
Oh no, that's a friendly.
That's a friendly.
Hold on, wait, the echo...
No!
Why am I so bad at hooking?
So, I used to be really good at Roadhog.
Not to be biased or anything,
but I actually used to be really good at Roadhog,
and I feel like I don't know the length of his hook or anything.
I sucky sucky, I do sucky sucky,
and I do sucky sucky.
Right, fuck it, go and just...
Fuck outta here!
Right, Mercy, you're next to me, bam.
You wanna be in the front line so bad,
get the fuck out of my face.
Get up!
Right, okay, hold on a minute, hold on a minute.
I'm afraid the reef ones,
I'm gonna have to ask yous to clutch up.
Very, I know it's selfish.
I can't do it, I can't do Roadhog, I can't do it.
It's a dilithium, crystals can't,
and they just can't do it.
Well, there's two alive, but...
Oh, Genji's all in, he's getting heals off the break.
He gets one, he gets two,
a healer and a DPS is down, he does perish.
Oh, sorry, fuck, I forgot it,
I don't have a long range hit anymore.
Go and stop it, go and knock it off, honestly.
Right, yes, yes, yes, we get it.
Oh no, I'm trapped, what will I ever do?
Heals, heals, heals, heals, heals.
Okay, right, Juno time, Juno time,
I don't know what Juno does, I'm just maling, I'm maling.
We don't make her in the back, we don't make her in the back.
Okay, Bob got me, that's fine.
Oh, this is a hard one.
I'm gonna say it,
we're actually having a fight for this victory.
I don't know the length of his hook,
I feel like it's a lot shorter than I thought it was.
I wouldn't be surprised if they shortened,
you know, they gave me a little cheeky circumcision, you know.
Look, we were all thinking of it.
Okay, we're all thinking of it.
Right, stop, right, I'm literally,
my middle finger is hovering off of my right mouse button
because I keep thinking it's a long range when it's not.
He's off.
Okay, one DPS down, Juno in the air, Juno in the air,
Juno in the air, Juno getting hit, Juno got hooked,
reloading on Juno.
I'm doing absolutely terrible against Juno, absolutely terrible.
I somehow got her, going on Ash, going on Ash,
reloading on Ash's face.
Pushing, I think we've won this, right?
We've won this, sorry.
I think, footsteps, footsteps above.
I feel really bad about that.
Wait, stop pushing, yes, yes!
Oh, we did it!
It continues, it continues.
We're actually so energy, so I'm not playing Roadhog again.
That was terrible, I did not enjoy that.
Catalyst, more like, loserless.
Because even though you tried your best, it was not enough.
Reloading on Ash's face.
Oh yeah, more like.
Well, you already know the joke, I'm not gonna say it.
Oh my god, that's me when I pheromone max.
Oh, I stink so good.
Right, continue, close, change roles, cancel.
Right, I did not mock a new hero.
Thank you very much.
One more thumb group.
Yeah, dang, that's a lot of friends.
Right, who?
I'm now on the other page now, I'm opening up the page like a book.
Who has been waiting a while?
I'm trying to see who has been waiting a while.
I feel like you've all been waiting a while.
I feel like you've all been waiting a while and I feel really bad, I'm so sorry.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Right, hold on, let me just consult the list.
Well, I still do one from each page.
I'll still do one from each page, okay?
Chuggy cheese?
I definitely have not had you.
Greta T, you've not been in either.
No tails and blah blah blah, I've not had you because I can't even say your name.
Jess have had you, two moons have had you.
Technical ninja?
No, I've not had you.
Again, if I have had you, please be super respectful and leave in case I make it whoopsie whoopsie.
A bit of matcha, a bit of green tea.
Okay, we're going to be called the Zen team because we're so relaxed, we're so well behaved.
I just realised I'm not ever posting the pictures of all the scribbles when I write down all your names.
I should maybe do that and just be like, that's me.
Right, this is called the Zen team because I'm going to be relaxed and I'm not going to shout in excitement.
I'm going to be calm.
I'm going to be wise.
I am also going to play either healer or DPS.
I don't want to touch tank or a 10 foot pole, it scares me, okay?
This is, we are peace.
This is about going to be the craziest game so far.
How?
No, we're in our peace.
Awe.
Right, I'm going to take the shirt off.
That came off really quickly.
I did not expect it to come off that quickly.
Right, hold on.
You.
This.
One.
Okay, we did it.
I'm looking forward to the game.
No.
I am peaceful.
I'm chaotic.
I think I would like
to do that.
I think, sorry, sorry.
Just, just fucking looking around.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
What else is, so let me look up other words for peace.
Other words for peace.
We are tranquil.
We are calm.
We are restfulness.
What the fuck is restfulness?
We are peace and quiet.
Quiet. This is what Google's telling me by the way. We are, we are quieted. What the fuck is quieted?
Quieted.
Melancholy!
Quieted. I've never heard that. A state of silliness, calmness, and quiet in a, wait, what?
Oh, sorry. A state of stillness, calmness. I don't know why I said that, but I did.
We are silent. We are soundlessness. We are harsh. We are noiseless.
We're also illiterate. We absolutely are.
Thank you the beauty lord for the super chat as well. Like I said, he, we're in a state of silliness. We are in a state of silliness.
Okay, we're searching, we're searching. Hold on, I'm trying it.
My microphone seems to be getting looser and looser and it makes me so nervous.
Oh, you're gonna hear his plunk and everyone's gonna be like, she has a butt plug in.
And it's like, no. Literally the Christopher Walken scene. No. I don't wanna. I don't have one.
Melon stream. Beat em up. Recess box, recess box. Beat em up, beat em up, beat em up, beat em up.
Beat em up, beat em up, beat em up, beat em up, beat em up.
Are you squidding me right now? I don't know, are you squidding me, Brian?
Oh, I know that's what I'm saying. I feel bad if yous are waiting, but like, I'm no, right, I'm gonna be controversial.
I'm gonna say something controversial. Yes, we're all hating on me when I was like, I wanna play Overwatch, right?
But then when I put up Overwatch, all of a sudden I've got 63 pals.
Now, hold on a minute. You cannae make fun of me for picking Overwatch if I've got 63 pals sitting.
So, I don't know, one of us is telling Fiborino's and I ain't me.
One of us is telling Fiborino, you're making fun of me for my Overwatch choice?
You tell him Fiborino's.
Look at my boobs and tell me if I picked a bad game or not.
Hmm? Look? Did I pick a bad game, be honest?
Look at my...
And tell me I picked a bad game.
Almost.
Oh god, it kinda looks like I have a penis.
Cause you know how guys have a V? If you don't show the whole picture.
Okay, let me go see mine again.
No giant test time, that comes later.
So yeah, then he'd be coming at me.
Hmm, it's funny, Overwatch 2 is such a bad stream snipe game.
I'll stream snipe your prostate, how about that?
That's what I'll stream snipe.
Sorry mama, you couldn't pay me enough to play Overwatch.
F Blizzard.
They got acquired though.
Doesn't that redeem them if they got acquired?
They got acquired by Microsoft.
Personally me, I'm mega hard, but over there they're Microsoft.
Thank you for the super chat, but they got acquired.
My bad, Overwatch is the best game ever.
Thank you, thank you for admitting it.
Sorry, but I can only get hypnotized by the eyes.
Wait, hold on, hold on, I got it.
No, that's not my hypnosis eyes at all.
Stop, that's not my hypnosis eyes.
Okay, sorry.
You want to play Overwatch with me?
Stop, I was like, that's not my hypnosis.
I still have all the sound effects from that other stream.
Hold on.
Damn boy, were you just frying chicken in there?
Chicken in there?
I want she be to dub that meme, I'm not even kidding.
I want her to dub it.
You know what, I'm fucking DMing her right now.
I'm literally not, I'm gonna give no context.
Haha, you piss loud as fuck, copypasta.
That's it, that's all I'm sending her.
She will have no other context, for she does not know my name.
Okay, we, oh I'm DPS.
Alright, time to be French.
Oh wait, that was Elvis Presley.
That was not a French laughter.
I'm sorry, Elvis Presley.
Let me retry that game.
Salut, a va, messieurs?
Je jouais, je jouais 8 mecs.
Hello?
Une balle, une meur.
Mmm, discord.
It's a piggy!
Oh my god, pig girl confirmed for Gentoo because it's so cute.
Chicken, oh it's the hololive chicken girl from Austria.
She always has her boobs out.
That's the only time I see artwork of her is her Austrian flag on her chest and her tits around.
I said what I said.
That's the only time, man.
No, that's a perfect shot!
How did you fucking arsehole?
Sorry if anyone's...
Give me the opportunity to snipe!
Oh yeah, oh yeah piss, oh yeah piss.
There's a ball and spawn.
Someone's missing a testicle, there's a fucking ball and spawn!
Right, hold on.
Hold on, let me get the shot.
I missed.
Hammond!
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god, I want to play Widowmaker for one game.
Please.
Where are they?
I hear them.
Oh my god, I got a half shot, I'll take it.
I missed.
I took a shot and I missed again.
Okay, hold on, let me get on this platform.
I missed again.
Fucking hell, red!
Get me off it, sorry, I need to rotate, I'm getting off Hammond.
I'm getting off Widowmaker, I'm not French, I'm sorry I lied to you like this.
Everyone is a terrible pick for me other than, what's his name?
Right, I've not played Reaper, I've not played Reaper.
Widowmaker's just for the cake.
You're not gonna, oh my ping's 250!
Oh my god yes, I'll blame the ping!
Oh the ping, it's totally not my absolute kaka aim.
My duty kaka aim.
Oh the ping.
It's just so frustrating, you know?
Oh shucks, it's not my aim whatsoever.
Okay, okay, hit him with the Hammond, hit him with the, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Okay.
Ooh, I already got on fire.
Only been on him for five seconds, already on fire.
Oh yeah, you're jumping off the map?
Are you scared?
Right, I'm off, sorry.
I'm off for a cheeky heal, bye.
Okay, we did it, we did it.
We're winning, so as we're winning now, I'm on someone that kind of know how to play.
Come back, come back, come back baby, come back.
Wait, hold on, I'm out.
Ooh, ooh!
Oh there's a soldier above!
Oh yeah, bleed it.
No, that's it, I'm coming for you.
I'm coming for your soul!
That's right, you're no killing my Moira
and thinking I'm gonna tolerate that behaviour.
I'm taking big chunks, alright.
Ooh, ooh, turn around.
Right, no, no, I'm coming for you.
I'm coming for you!
Alright, she's won.
You can do the rest, you can do the rest.
I did what I had to do, I did what I had to do.
Put me in, oh sorry, I need to be zen.
I forgot, I'm on the camp team.
Death, death heals me.
Death is a nice cold coffin where my body can rest.
For I am calm, I am collected.
I love what I'm able to do.
Piss!
Piss, no!
I mean, oh how unfortunate.
Sometimes fate has other things on my mind.
Experience tranquility.
Why I'm calm, collected.
I have my ultimate.
Wait, come, don't go in!
Don't go in, you silly Billy.
We're supposed to go in together.
You have no got heals, darling.
What you doing?
Then he start, then he start making me get raging at the refunds.
Then I think I want to start raging at you.
Then he be silly Billy.
Right, look at that.
Do you see that HP damage I'm doing from across the map?
I hear someone.
Right, I'm going to ult on the payloads.
I'm in boys.
No, fuck you.
Fuck, fuck, I'm out of range.
I mean, oh my god, no.
How did I do it?
Right, I said I'm going hands-on.
I'm just so MLG.
No, no, I'm going Tarbjorn.
No, I'm going tracer because I'm fast.
I'm fast as fuck boys.
I'm coming on point.
Tranquil, peace.
I love Zinnia.
I love Nepal.
I love the lore that monks are robot.
I hear footsteps.
Oh, I missed the staircase.
That was a wee bit embarrassing.
I'm British.
Hi, I love tracer.
Tracer here.
No, he went and got heals to be bobagged.
No, I didn't hear Ken who he's shooting at because it's not me.
Oh, he's shooting at you, sauce.
I just don't want to let him have an ult from above.
I'm in.
I'm stuck.
I'm still reachable.
No, sauce, I'm going in.
I'm going in.
I finally got him.
Did we win?
I'm just letting you guys carry me.
I've been carried.
I literally didn't do anything.
Mommy, you're getting too Zinnia.
You're going in the opposite direction.
I mean, bro, I'm getting carried hard.
Oh my God.
Let me just sip my matcha.
My green tea.
Oh my God, I can sing.
Ready?
No, no, no, no, no.
Tracer's here.
This is my song.
Oh, yeah.
Tracer here.
I'm ready to suck and fuck.
I'm too hyper playing this game with you.
I need to stop.
Oh, wait, this is a Torbjorn map.
Are you ready?
This is a Torbjorn.
No, hold on.
Let me change my hero.
This is a Torbjorn map.
Trust this is Torbjorn map.
Bro, if you've not seen the artworks of Tracer,
I don't know what to tell you.
The Monkey Paw Curls, MonkaS.
Oh, yeah.
It's a Symmetra, but she's not Symmetra.
I'm being a bit.
My turret's up, though.
That's the main thing.
As long as my turret's up, I'm helping my teammate.
It does not matter that I died.
It does not smath her.
No, nata ma.
I can't speak French.
I keep pretending I can, but I can't.
Everyone has seen Tracer's artworks, bro.
There's some animations of her.
There was one where she was getting plapped by Roadhog,
and Roadhog was like fucking massive with his belly,
and I used to like,
religiously go on it all the time.
I don't know if I could find it again.
I just really like what I saw, you know what I'm saying?
Right, hold on.
Let me get rid of that.
No, Zinnia.
Don't try and destroy my turret.
I'm going to be mad.
Okay, so they are getting no Symmetra!
Bleed it!
Her wee pissy pissy.
Wait, my turret doesn't recognize her turret?
Are turrets ignoring each other?
Roadhog kind of base.
Look, I'm in a fat bastard.
I don't care.
I'm going to see who it is.
He had a big round tummy,
and it was Tracer on top,
and she was like lowering herself, I think.
I don't know if I can find it, but...
I pick on someone your own size.
I'm tiny.
No!
I'm doing so bad.
Holy moly moly.
Right, my ultimate is going to clear this off a bit.
A wee bit.
Are you fucking serious?
See these wee hamsters?
Extermination on site.
Oh my god, I died.
Right, I have my ultimate.
It's okay, I have my ultimate.
We can bring it back.
Group up.
Right, do I need to shout at them and group up?
That's like getting fucking...
Can I talk to them in game?
Hold on, can I talk?
Am I allowed to talk to them?
They're not even in the...
My microphone has been completely new player experience.
I still can't talk to them.
I want to shit them up.
I want to start screaming at them in game.
I said what I said.
I want to scare them.
Why?
I want to be like,
BOOM!
Right, I need the team to come together.
I need the tank.
What?
Hammond the Bam.
Hammond?
Yeah, it is Hammond, right?
He's a wee hamster.
Hammond the Hamster.
He's trying to knock us off the mag Brigitte.
We must be careful.
I may have used my ult a bit preemptively.
Look, I'm stalling, okay?
It's called stalling.
I'm actually not...
I'm totally wasting my ult.
I know.
I got two.
I don't know if Lucio can touch.
I think if they...
Hold on.
I think if they can touch, we've got it.
No, Myra.
No.
I can't believe it.
I can't talk completely.
Right, I'm putting it here.
Oh, no.
I almost got the freaking...
What's her name?
Oh, right.
We lost this one, but that's okay.
That's okay.
We're team Zen, okay?
Zen also means to balance, okay?
And we will balance the ying and yang.
We will win one and we will lose one, okay?
And just because...
Because of you.
Is it okay if I post on you?
Yeah, I'm literally a streamer.
To focus on fat bastard.
Stop.
I don't know.
Hold on.
Let me check my marshmallows in case
one of you's have found it already.
We will watch it live.
I don't care.
It was so good because it has a big belly in it.
Love me a big belly.
T-shirt.
Oh, you made me a fail for the t-shirt.
A wreathling made me a t-shirt?
I have to say, I swear if I look at your bobby,
when I open up this link, you're so done.
Oh my god, I messed it up.
Sorry, low IQ.
I messed it up, right?
Let me get...
Put me back in, coach.
Put me back in.
Yes.
Check your quest.
Welcome to Overwatch.
Okay.
So, I'm going to show you where you're to put your turret.
Oh, piss!
Hammond is ruining it.
If you put your turret here,
they have to like get put in the way.
They're destroying my turret already.
They better not be.
But like, see how if they cross over,
they get hit by my turret?
Uh...
No.
I'm going to leave it up.
See how it's bothering them?
They're not focusing on damaging my teammates
because of this turret being up.
Hey, oh, my turret almost got someone.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh shit, we're losing though.
So, I can hide behind...
See, I can hide behind the drum
and we can take the point until...
Right, so Zen's just hiding by the stash.
We're in the best position right now.
Literally, turret set up.
Naifos, name us.
I can hear a Symmetra turret though.
I don't know where it is.
Please be super safe and alive.
Torbjorn is there.
Torbjorn's come down.
Torbjorn's fucked up her moira.
Okay, this could have gone better.
Okay, we do have one kill.
I'll take it.
If I can get the Sim,
I should be okay.
If I can get her to cross into my fucking turret...
I hate when they have brain cells.
I mean, no.
It is good to have challenges in life.
You will prosper as a person through hardship.
Do you play Team Fortress 2?
I've never played it before.
We can play it for the first time together, if you like.
Right, and now we're going to do...
Oh, no, he put the turret where I was going to put it next.
No, that's stinky.
That's the victory.
Oh shit.
I'm cut.
Probably...
There we go.
See?
See how we almost, like,
debated her into coming into my turret.
Okay.
Sorry, I just hammered the air.
I got rid...
I'm getting excited.
Spank.
Right, I'm spanking the refland.
One spank.
Where's another refland?
I need to spank a Rissa.
Right, spanking Rissa.
Boom.
Take that.
Take this reaper.
Okay, reapers try hard,
so maybe we won't spank them right now.
Hold on, Ana, you need to spank.
Spank.
Right, we're backing off.
We're backing off because enemies are respawning.
Enemies are respawning!
Don't panic.
Oh, no.
What happens if my turret destroyed the balls
and rendered your all...
Oh, no, Ana died.
Oh, my God, I'm being pinned against the wall by a Hammond.
Oh, yeah.
Fucking hell, when did the Hamsters get so strong?
Right, Moira's getting mass occurred.
Uh, I can't even keep you up.
I'm out.
I don't know where...
300 ping, by the way, wink, wink.
If you round it up, it's 300 ping.
Like, come on.
Give me the benefit of the doubt.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Hit him with a...
Hit him with a clear in the area.
That's right.
We're going for the Zen.
He's exposed.
He's vulnerable!
Unless he hits me, he's not vulnerable.
See?
Okay, fuck it.
Come on.
So he...
So the Zen now can't...
Yeah?
Yeah, you're gonna ult?
Yeah.
You're gonna ult and waste it
so you can't utilize it for your team when you need it most?
That's right.
Oh, you thought going on top of the drum was gonna work?
Sorry.
I've played this game before.
I hate to break it to you.
I'm sorry.
It...
It pained...
It hurt me to put that...
That previous gamer knowledge.
Ana...
Ana on her own, Mohammed.
Fuck it!
Come in!
Come in everywhere!
I'm splurging!
I can't take it anymore.
It's just too much.
Damn right, I'm powered up.
Uh...
Right, I'm getting everyone.
Okay, so they expect...
I guess where they expect my turret to be, not in the shrine.
So the turret is now going in the shrine.
Turret in the shrine!
No, fuck!
Myra, are you serious, young lady?
Well, anyway.
That's right, team Zen.
Oh, peace and tranquility all over your face.
Oh, peace and tranquility is everywhere.
Gee, motherfucking...
Gee...
Achievement unlocked.
Oh, yeah.
Blackjack.
What does it mean?
I don't know, but I'm just glad it's having a good time.
Ooh!
A little cheeky, all off the map, and Byra mental kill.
Not bad at all.
Good, good feel be.
Mm-mm.
Right, we're gonna check what I need to do in order to...
Um...
How do I see?
Unavailable...
Wait, what?
So can I talk in group now?
Hello?
I think...
I think I can talk in group now.
I think I can start screaming at the refunds.
Like, not to get political, but I think I can start screaming at yous in game.
Am I gonna be scaring yous?
I mean, I kid.
Right.
Becks, you're literally in a competitive game.
I'm not gonna throw you out of that.
Broly, have you had a chance?
I'm opening up my map, my agendination.
Broly not had a chance.
Oh wait, I wrote your name before you could have accepted.
Because you may not accept.
Oh my gosh, may not accept.
I see.
Um...
Mm-mm.
And the next page...
Um...
Is there...
Easy...
Isn't...
I'm gonna say...
That's a name, isn't it?
Ziko.
That's a name.
Oh yeah!
Excuse me.
Did I give you permission to speak?
Do you think I'm gonna scare them?
I don't wanna scare the refunds.
Are they gonna be scared to talk to me?
They might be.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
Right, who's not had a chance?
Sprung Cobra?
I don't think you were a part of the F team, were you?
Mm-mm.
No, you weren't.
Sprung Cobra.
I'm from...
Sip it, ret hot and go,
Yahoo!
Beah, beah, reeah.
And then...
Page four...
You've got an X in your name.
I've not had you in.
And together, we will make
the microphone blowers.
Cos do you remember in dead lobbies,
if you got annoyed at the enemy team,
you're just blowing your mic,
so we're called the blik...
the MIC blowers.
Mm-mm.
I'm running out of air cos I'm talking so much,
cos I'm so excited!
Right, wait, can I scare them?
Boo.
Okay.
But don't talk.
Because mail on stream.
Wait, no, you can put, but don't talk.
You're not allowed to talk.
Right, I've not unlocked any new heroes yet, but I'm allowed to talk, okay?
I'm blowing the mic, but I'm blowing it right now.
You're not allowed to talk.
But I'm allowed to talk to you and make demands, okay?
They will get a fear-boner.
Are you scared?
Oh, that's embarrassing.
I just whistled when I said that.
Do we mail on stream each other?
I whistled.
I know they heard that whistle because I fucking heard it.
It was piercing.
It was ear-piercingly loud.
I'm scaring you.
I'm giving them the heebie-jeebie.
I should start interviewing and be like, so when did you become a reflin?
Prove you're a reflin right now.
What is my favorite type of meat?
There's actually two answers to that.
Come on.
Are they going to be too scared to say anything?
They're not saying anything.
I think I've terrified them.
Are they just sweet shit in themselves?
Chicken.
Yeah, but you're not talking.
I don't know.
Do you?
Two types of meat.
Chicken and a reflin, exactly.
I was going to say calamari because your tentacle counts as well.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
The reflin sent me a PNG.
Fuck!
Oh, my God.
I'm getting links to the Roadhog thing as well.
Wait.
Where's the P...
I need the PNG.
Oh, my God.
Are we in Australia?
Real, I'm sure.
I'm going to have good ping for once.
Please.
Oh, you did PNG it for me.
Hold on.
Fucking fire.
I'm not giving fire a try.
Hold on.
How do I do this fast?
All right.
Test me.
He put on.
Hold on.
Put on the shirt.
Oh, no.
Don't make me bigger.
Make the shirt.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm a real gamer now.
Okay, we did it.
What is this?
Prepare to attack.
Oh, no.
This is the new game mode I'm not really familiar with.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's so not put on me correctly.
It rotates off of me so much.
Right.
I'll fix it after this game.
A little more man on stream.
Well, you better win.
No pressure.
Okay.
Right.
Farah looks the exact same.
I don't seem to not recognize anything from Farah.
Okay.
I'm linking Farah.
What's this?
Oh, wow.
I have mobility.
I have a mobility shot for the air.
Now hold on a minute.
Let's go.
Bruh.
I'm so sorry.
Me.
Oh, my God.
Me just got me.
Right.
Oh, my God.
Farah has like a wee mobility thing now.
I need to try and get him in the crossfire.
I don't want him to reflect and hit me, but I'm trying to get...
Jeez.
You guys are aggressive.
Get him.
The reflings are no calling it.
I'm just going to aim down.
I worked.
I'm beating him up.
Beat him up.
Recess pass.
I don't have to be tranquil anymore.
Okay.
I'm allowed to be excited.
I'm so excited.
I just can't hate it.
I know.
Something.
Oh, I'm going to have ultimate soon.
Right.
Enemies are going to have ultimate soon as well.
Just to warn you, it's my darlings.
I'm backing off.
Back off if you can.
Back off.
I'm scaring them.
I'm getting just back up a little bit.
I'm going to give them fucking...
What is it called when you get scared of someone?
But like, you want to keep into...
Is it...
No.
What's the...
It's just...
But like, you want to keep into...
Is it...
No.
What's the...
It's the stockman syndrome.
I'm going to give them stockman syndrome.
My poor babies.
They don't deserve this.
Moira, can I...
You know what?
Am I allowed to scream at the healers?
Do you think they'd like it?
Oh!
I wonder why I didn't get a heal.
Moira's fucking gobbling them off and spawning.
I'm coming for you, Reflin.
I'm just kidding.
You don't discipline me.
Please understand if I ever insult you, it's for funsies.
Wait!
You have a boost coming out of spawn now?
Uh, hold on a minute.
That's kinda hashtag smart.
I'm coming in!
I'm...
I'm helping!
Stop healing them, Jesus.
Where's Allari?
Allari!
Right.
Me!
Me next!
Uh, pick the...
Ozzy!
Right, and then me!
Then me!
Maino heal!
Maino heal our wall!
Maino wall our heal our ice!
Okay, and then Ozzy!
I need to console...
I need us to be...
To share our one brain cell.
I need us to share the brain cell.
Where the fuck did he go?
Where the fuck...
Right.
Okay, we're in trouble.
I've not got it.
Sorry.
I fucked up.
I'm so sorry, darlings.
I'm trying.
I'm going...
Get the Junker Queen.
Okay.
Genji next.
Wherever the fuck he is.
Yes.
The brain cell!
We're sharing the brain cell!
We're doing it.
Okay.
Maino heal after she comes out so we can all throttle her.
Our wall doesn't count as a heal.
Okay.
Next point.
Uh, look on the map where it is.
Over here.
Okay.
We will now waddle our way to the next point.
Swarm intelligence, actually, though.
And before anyone says, oh my god, you're tryharding.
Uh, yeah.
I don't play video games to fucking lose, you moron.
Oh my god, that was so mean.
I didn't mean to say it like that.
That came out a lot meaner than I wanted.
I wanted it to be humorous, but that came out really mean.
I'm so sorry.
I just, like, winnin' in games.
Like, I don't wanna...
Oh, I was purple so you couldn't have healed me.
It's okay.
Like...
I hope that didn't come off meaner than I meant to say.
I didn't mean I didn't play video games to mean.
I'm done.
Like, I enjoy winning.
Don't get me wrong.
A good bot spanking, like, you know when it's close and you get your bot spanked and it's
like, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
I'm raging.
Ken, what do I mean?
Oh my god, leave my reclines alone.
No, sorry.
I'm laying down cover fire.
Get me in there.
Put me in, coach.
No, no, no.
If you wanna be out here, I'm gonna bump you about.
I'm farming heals.
I'm farming, not heals, all on her.
Oh!
Right.
I'm glad he killed me because I actually pressed Q there.
I'm not gonna lie.
Right.
We need our group hive mind to come together because it's not working.
My brain's not working.
And my brain needs to come together.
Be more mean.
It's hot.
I feel like it's scary.
I mean, shit, if you're asking for it.
Right.
I'm not going in.
So I'm not going in.
They can have that point.
No!
I never did that.
Thank you, chair and the bail.
I'm hiding.
Oh my god.
They heard me.
They heard my rocket propellers.
I'm hiding.
Yella is more.
It helps.
I feel like I'm gonna accidentally say the R word.
If I really get, you know, like, it's just gamer talk.
Okay.
New objective.
Wait.
I need to say something mean.
Open your eyes.
There's a new location.
I must sound absolutely chaotic for them on the other side because there's a stream delay
as well.
So they hear it twice.
I don't know how to be mean.
Oh, you fucking idiot.
Bonk.
War insult.
Give me insults to say to them.
R word season.
Oh god.
They're all coming from behind.
As opposed to coming from the front.
You'll need to type insults in chat.
Okay.
Come to me and I'll heal you.
I'm so sorry.
She literally pirouetted into my fucking hole.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't keep dying.
Weakling.
That's right.
Ooh.
Did you just come in here from World of Warcraft?
Oh my god.
Never played this game before, have you?
Ooh.
I'm hitting them where it hurts.
Okay.
Your life is as valuable as a summer ant.
Oh, that's a really...
That one's harsh.
Right.
Well, if we lose this fight, I'll say the ant lane.
I'm going for the healing.
Right.
So they don't have a heal from that.
I'm going...
I'm trying to get Elaria, but she cannot.
Elaria evade in me.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh my god.
Me, go away.
Not now, me.
Me, no.
I'm about to start screaming.
I can't stay alive this fucking game.
Caracall, you piece of fucking shit.
I need a set.
We all need a set.
Right.
Get me.
Me behind.
Me behind with Genji.
And she gets the heal.
I can't eat fucking data.
I'm getting redone.
No, so is...
I'm coming out.
And I'm going to let you know.
Your life is as valuable as a summer ant.
That's what you get!
You walk into my bullets and you think you're going to win?
Fucking...
Like...
Just...
Oh, right.
I need glasses for a blind man.
Fucking dozen buzhing zhoush.
Someone else!
Right, we're winning.
We're winning.
I refuse to lose this.
I actually refuse to lose against the fucking me when I'm a pharaoh.
Don't care.
Die.
Perish.
Genji, Genji, Genji, Genji.
Right, brain cell this.
Brain cell this.
I'm going to start screaming.
Typical nation.
I made it to the live stream house, Johnny.
Please lower your volume.
I'll need to put a big warning at the top of the screen.
Lower your volume now before it's too late.
Okay.
Instead of R, we'll just say any other word like refunded.
You fucking refling!
Right, Genji won.
I did what I had to do.
Right.
Alright, okay.
Yes!
Go in the attack!
Fuck!
Oh, I got to play the game.
Hem with the uh.
Hem with the pirouet.
Right, okay.
We did it.
I got to play the game for that.
I don't care.
I got to play the game.
We are not losing.
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
You're a real Overwatch player.
You have a Christmas skin.
Oh, God, they're coming.
Oh, wait.
I hear them.
Suck the Genji off wherever he is.
I don't care when he is.
Alright, they're all coming from there.
You hear them?
You've got directional sound.
Unless you're a death reaper and you have to use the AI to know what I'm saying.
I'm so sorry.
It's wrong, like, all the time.
I'm attacking from afar.
I need to use my distance to my advantage.
Fantastic.
Me.
Okay.
I'm starting to lose my voice, but that's okay.
That's not going to stop me.
Okay, new objective.
Okay, I wasn't paying attention.
New objective.
We're going to fucking find her.
I'm salivating, not from my mouth.
We're actually so fucking good at this game.
Oh, that's actually really good.
Bro, I need to take my clothes off.
I'm sweating.
I'm getting so excited playing this game.
I'll take my clothes off after this round.
Get too excited.
No!
Not freaking Sombra!
Are you joking?
Yes.
If you're happy and you know what, clap your hands.
I'm sad.
Oh, where are you?
There is more to learn.
What a voice line.
Hit the level.
Let's go.
We need to group up.
We need to group up like the groupies you are, reflings.
That's right.
You've got backstage passes and I'm dragging you.
Right, we need to group up.
We need to group up.
Don't fucking go in.
Group up!
You will pocket me.
Oh.
No, no.
Okay, we're ready.
I'm ready for a motion.
That's a SpongeBob reference.
Oh my God.
Open!
Get away!
He's gone.
He's gone and moistened his fucking knife.
Get him.
The UK government's going to get you.
You're not allowed a knife like that.
Right, we're actually going to...
No, we can let them win this one.
Okay, let them win.
Regroup.
I'm getting lightheaded from how much I'm screaming.
Okay, I'm going to get some water.
Actually...
Okay.
It's okay.
I know how to shoot.
Okay.
New objective.
I don't...
I'm really not even paying attention, to be honest.
I'm in the air.
Bye.
His all is not my problem.
I'm off.
I have flay.
I'm...
Doomfist!
Okay.
And then objective to the objective.
Huzzah!
We're walking to the objective.
We're fucking walking.
We're almost there.
We're going to kill that anyone.
And one by one they'll dissipate the enemy.
There's a somber behind us.
Huzzah!
Doomfist!
Get the tank off the fucking point!
Get that motherfucker!
Oh!
Oh, hold on.
Let me get the point.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Gorgeous.
I'm going to need to get some oxygen back in because I'm starting to get lightheaded.
The boot alert.
I'm so bad you couldn't hit the broad side of a barn from the inside of it.
I'm so dumb I could not tip water out of a boot if the instructions were written on the soles.
Hold on.
That was...
No!
Wrong sound effect!
It's supposed to be clapping because it was good.
You're intoxicity has inspired me.
I'm redamling.
Exactly.
Okay.
Oh!
It's going to ult right there.
Oh my God!
You cheeky fucking cow!
You absolute...
Oh!
What can I say to insult her?
What can I say to insult Sombra?
You...
You're...
You're so invisible.
Mmm.
That's right.
I sure showed you.
I showed you.
That's right.
Okay.
You're going to play Marvel Rivals?
I think we're going to play it together.
I don't know when it comes out but the beta got like really well done.
They used the old reliable.
Where's the point?
Oh!
It's here.
Oh my God!
I was not paying attention.
Tee hee!
Right.
Are you ready?
I'm going to jump scare them.
She perroed!
I knew that was coming!
Okay.
There's two of them.
They're kind of on point.
I'll weave it.
But she perroed into that.
That was funny.
Right.
Sorry Sombra.
You're going to first.
I actually hate you.
Yes!
Yeah.
I literally cannot stand you.
I cannot stand you!
HACK SOMEONE ELSE!
Because it's not me!
I have a firewall!
And I have a pie hole too which I highly recommend.
Oh!
So good.
Right.
Let me readjust the shirt.
Wait no.
I got play of the game.
Let's see it.
Give me play of the game.
I know.
Show me what I want to see.
Replay!
You took my fucking play of the game!
Also me.
Why is my voice so sore tomorrow?
I don't know why my voice is so sore.
You.
You only won our wording.
GG.
G.
We're actually so...
Oh my god.
I'm almost live.
Not to brag but I'm almost level 4.
Right.
Let me take off my clothes because I'm a swan.
If anyone would like to lick up my belly sweat you're more than welcome to.
It's also in my inner thighs pretty badly.
There's much more comfortable to do than that.
That's much more like it.
Headset back on.
Let's get our team together ladies and gentlemen.
Oh!
Time to be symmetrical.
All right.
I'm playing symmetrical next game.
And thank you for backing out everyone because it makes us go a lot faster.
Who goes there?
You must have wondered.
Right.
Hasn't had a shot next.
Chair have not sat on your face.
DC packed.
Did I?
Did I write your face?
You should play pro league baseball with how well you throw.
That's rude.
I know.
Are you squidding me right now?
You fucking bitch.
When is the good game playing in the start?
You fucking arsehole.
We've been rolling and smoking and on.
You little motherfucker.
You little bitch.
I'm doomed.
Has d-pack had a chance?
DC packed.
I don't remember writing that out.
I'm checking the notes.
I don't think you've had a chance.
No.
But you're in a game.
I can't invite you while you're in a game.
Has these notes played?
These notes.
I must have wondered where have them been.
Frosty feet.
You've not had a shot.
I'm going to kill myself.
Bye.
Real good game.
What the fuck?
Right.
One shot myself.
Didn't expect that.
We're going to be called team shot myself.
Because I did not expect the fucking voice comms.
Right.
Right next.
I'm playing Symmetra.
Because I just unlocked Symmetra.
So you guys can squabble between yourselves.
I was struggling so hard to pay on 300 ping.
Was that on my server?
No, that wasn't on my server.
Did somebody send board you?
No, that was a replay.
Oh, my shirt.
I need to fix my shirt.
Hold on.
No.
Oh, it's stuck.
Why is this?
Hold on.
I need to, like, re-add it.
Okay.
Hold on.
I have the PNG of the shirt.
No.
Wait, what?
What is it?
I just downloaded it.
Okay, there you are.
Right.
If I look straight.
Oh, ignore my funny.
If I look straight and then I pin it.
Like this.
I'm looking.
Well, my model's looking straight.
I'm going to pin it.
Right.
Okay.
I don't even need to pin it.
It's so perfect.
It's so, it's so good.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I just need to look dead ahead.
Okay.
I'm not tilting my head at all.
Broly legend.
Thank you for the super chat.
The booty lord.
Count quispy.
You couldn't hit water if it fell out of a bowl.
If it fell...
If you...
Oh!
I misread it.
Sorry.
Count quispy.
Let me try that again.
You couldn't hit water if you fell out of a bowl.
Because I'm hydrophobic.
Most fishes are actually.
I think that's how...
Because there's something about fishes.
They have like a swim bladder as well.
That like kills them if they go upside down or something.
I had to work for that one.
I'm so sorry.
For legal reasons.
Ronnie's wearing running shorts.
Like what marathon runners wear?
I never even thought about that.
Oh my God.
Marathon short runner cosplay when?
Right now?
Did you know that having a brain can cause...
Brain cancer?
Thank...
Thank God you guys are safe.
Oh my God.
I really like to even say that one.
I'm coming right now.
I'm a grade A trash talker.
I was raised on COD lobbies.
Yeah.
What do you know about MW21V1 on Rust?
Oh!
Everyone says that was such a good map.
But I don't remember much of it.
Maybe I can 1v1 these on Rust as well.
Because we're going to 1v1 on Ches later I think.
If I'm up for it later in the week.
I might have to delay it yet again.
Who did I...
Symmetra.
This is going to be the worst freaking map for her.
I can just tell.
We build anew.
Oh!
It's a Christmas fashion.
Right.
What are the fits?
Fit check.
What we got?
We've got a summer beach.
Right.
We've got default mercy too.
We've got Juno default.
She probably doesn't have enough skins out.
Right.
Oh!
She's got like a...
Really...
Oh my gosh.
I would like one Tuck Pokey.
I've never played this map before.
It's up to you guys to carry me.
I know it's just...
It's remade Hanamura.
But I don't know why they didn't just...
I'm sure.
And now I'm cold.
That I've taken my clothes off.
I can't believe it.
How does this work?
Oh!
I could have put a teleport down.
Sorry!
Alright.
I'm going to put one there.
And here.
Basically, I just want to catch them off if they go too far.
Because you want to make it annoying to turn around and hit you.
Like you want to be an annoyance.
So...
Oh!
You can't hold it for as long as you want.
Curious.
Oh!
That Ash was one HP in a dream.
So now that we have point,
I am going to push up with my turrets.
So if they dare to come around the corner,
they get creamed on by my turrets.
And then that way we...
Oh!
Sugar!
I wasn't tall enough to get the reins thing.
Right.
We'll do then.
And if you didn't know on Symmetra,
you...
What is this game mode?
Is this not capture the flag?
Objective D?
I hear it.
Have what?
No.
Oh, well, everyone's dead.
I'm out.
Bye.
I'll go for a cheeky kill, why not?
I'm so dead.
I'm like actually so dead.
But with a frying pan,
I am so dead.
Oh, this reins going to ram me.
Okay.
I don't know how I survived that.
Wait, so...
What?
They're getting Objective Delta?
I want to use my ult and...
I loved him.
He was like 9.
Fucking dealing with that.
Let's get this all leveled up.
Okay.
So, now that we've been captured the D,
what happens after that?
I don't...
I'm not...
I'm not sure what happens after this.
Ow!
Don't hurt me.
How...
You go to B?
I said it's to go to...
What is this?
Oh!
I got pinned.
Oh, dear.
Okay.
But that's okay.
It's okay.
My three turrets are up,
so hopefully they're helping my teammates.
Wink, wink.
The one turret that's just chilling out.
Uh...
Right.
So, we need to stop them from capturing Echo.
Hmm.
This is a rather curious game mode.
Does it come back to Delta?
I don't...
I don't know if it happened...
Okay, wait.
Oh!
How...
You...
Right.
Just so you hate me.
Just so you hate me,
because why am I getting singled out?
How curious.
You play to five points.
Wait, so this game could keep going back and forth for ages?
Because if we can't reach the end...
Whee!
Uh...
I don't know if happened.
Right.
Fuck it, I'm going up here.
Right, let's see what the deal is.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm a big scary Symmetra.
Ooh!
I'm so...
I can't stop dying!
Sorry!
I'm being a bit of a silly Billy.
Right.
They're not going to capture it.
They're not going to come on point.
So, we'll go to Echo now.
I'm at the height of my performance.
No!
Well, I'm glad I survived.
I'm glad I have you on my side.
So...
Right, I'm not going in if my tank's dead.
So, I said it.
I'm not going in if my tank's dead.
I'm going to use my ultimate to get us in.
Well, I'm going to need my tank before I can move in.
I ain't fucking moving in.
Sorry, I'm not expecting Hammond to dolphin dive on that point as well.
That seems a bit ridiculous.
So, we go back to fighting for this one.
Like...
Oh dear.
Ha ha!
Get right by my turrets.
I bet the turrets are annoying you.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Get lezered, get lezered.
Pop, pop, pop!
Get lezered, get lezered!
So, this is it.
This is the game for the next two hours.
We're stun-multed.
Right.
So, we can capture Delta again.
So, I don't want to use my ult on this point
because we seem to be taking...
Right, I take it back.
Sorry.
I take it back.
This Reign must be getting so annoyed.
He's like, I'm the only one that's destroying these fucking turrets.
I'm...
I don't want to friggin' nano Reign on my R-sheet.
Right, there.
What?!
How did Zyn do that?
That was so good.
That honestly saws, but that was well played by Zyn.
I'm not even mad.
Right?
Okay.
Literally my first death.
It wasn't, but I'm just gonna pretend it was my first death.
Right.
So, they're gonna capture that.
That's fine.
So, they now have to come through here
to get this next point, right?
That's fine.
I can handle that.
Right.
Let them come.
Literally.
Not like that!
Don't...
She's gonna blow up my friggin' things on the side.
Right.
Do that then.
Oh, they can still see that turret.
Right.
I'm gonna have to do it like this.
They won't let me set up on my point!
The best I can do is this.
Come on, come on, come on!
I don't want to know, Reaper.
I do not want to know.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
I'm doing so bad.
I was doing alright,
but I've certainly lost it.
I've lost Mimojo.
Right.
Let me...
Let me entertain you.
Sorry.
I should really...
Wait, we have to do this now?
Oh, no.
We're like the monkey
from Planet of the Apes.
Oh, no.
We're losing.
Okay.
Let them...
I've set up my two rails.
I've got my wee cheeky ultimate.
If they want to go for me, they can.
Because that's kind of the...
And then we just need...
Oh, my God.
We're gonna be in this game for hours.
I hope you're ready for the long haul.
Oh.
Oh, these are a friendly ham and thing.
Right.
I'm going for the rein.
I'm reloading.
I'm going for the ana.
No, I'm not.
I'm getting pinned.
Didn't ask for it.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm really letting the refunds down for this one.
Mmm.
I'm letting the refunds down.
To whoop your arm.
I'm so sorry, refunds.
No, no, no.
Just go back.
No.
I'm so...
I need to go someone else.
Sorry.
I can't win on them.
I can't let the refunds down.
Oh, no.
We're bent to...
Wait.
I just see the five tabs on the star.
No, no, no, no.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, forgive me.
I threw...
I thought we had it.
I'm going to blame it on the fact I need to pee.
I'm so sorry, refunds.
I'm so sorry.
I need to pee, so I'm going to go pee.
I'm going to blame it on my pee.
My bladder's so full.
Is that a refund?
The rain did not like me.
I think the rain knew that once I got set up
I was doing enough damage to mess them up.
Right.
Oh, my God, right.
Change role.
Oh, I really want to win on Sim though.
I'm tempted to play her next game.
Right, I'm going to go for a very quick PPE.
PPE and caca land.
No, not caca.
Just pee.
I promise, just pee-pee.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on.
Pee-pee time, pee-pee time.
I got pee-pee time.
Please enjoy Juno in the background.
My throat is like razor blades.
I've been screaming far too much recently.
Actually, can I make a cup of tea for my throat?
I have just realized how freaking sore it is.
I'm going to make a cup of tea.
I'll be a minute, like three minutes to boil the kettle.
Okay, and pee.
Everyone stretch, get up and pee, and then we'll go again.
Okay.
Are you squidding me right now?
I could go ask him to still be cute.
My voice box is sore.
I did not realize how much fun I was having.
So when I show up on stream tomorrow and I'm like, tee, I don't have a voice box.
It's your fault.
you're the culprit okay cuz you made it far too fun okay stop being so fun right
who oh have I looked at the who have I not had someone had your profile picture
that's why I think you've been in Mr. Savage you've not been in MoMolo again
if you have been in before and I can't read it off the sheet right away please
I plead with you to I'm so sorry I'm just running so many trains on me I'm
starting to be unable to differentiate between your names I don't think I've
had you in but as always please I plead with you I beg with oh my god my voice
is really good can you hear the strain I wonder if the microphone's covering up
when I first debuted my voice broke but the microphone covered it up first like
really well you could not hear my voice was really broken but it's getting
broken right now you don't hear it yeah I guess that makes cover now preparing the
honey tea right I mean I have the tea cup if you want to yeah now hmm okay this
team is going to be called team honey because I need some down my throat right
now call your in cunning because I need that oh even though I just got up 15
minutes ago I'll take full and thank you for the super shot the typical nation
and thank you
colker for the super chat momy momy momy MoMolo crazy Jesse Zarian the booty lord
I could go afk and still beat you oh right I'm playing Symmetra so you guys
can bicker between yourselves you guys can fight between yourselves I want to
win one game on Symmetra that is my only objective okay and it is team honey team
around I should not be fucking around with later voice characters right now
um she hates me wait why would I hate you specifically no I got ignored no you
didn't know I have to go through all of years the train needs to be ran okay it
needs to be ran in 40 wait you found it oh you found the roadhog
is it oh my god I think it is oh no way you found it hold on hold on oh you found it see
guys okay no we're not listening to the rest of it but yes that's it it's cuz you
know what you know what spoke to me on a spiritual level it's because Roadhog was
so large he had to lie on his back because of his belly and I was like oh
oh it spoke to me I don't call me what you want it was a good fucking
animation call me what you want give us the name I actually don't know what the
name I just close up hold on let me open it again oopsie where is it call me
anything you want under the Sun I will stand by that animation it was animated
by Guilty 3d so if you type in Tracer Roadhog Guilty 3d hold on let me just
say oh she's got her pierce like me well I only have one angel wing okay oh no
Tracer is taking HP damage oh no okay yeah that's definitely a controversial
but
brother saying no what are you talking about I'm just looking at overwatch
music video stuff anything we talking about I don't know what you talk about
beefling like I don't these accusations they're you're you're miss firing you're
miss firing I don't know
so I said someone said on my new ASMR video the battle one eh the battle front
campaign noise they eat them I am playing Star Wars Battlefront campaign I
think at the end of oh this month no the month we're about to enter and September
like long story short I've like planned streams all the way up until like halfway
through October I'm about to hit November where was straight for the stream
planning I like planning ahead because it means like if someone asked for a
collab or something happens or whatever like I've always got backups in that and
what so if we when we get to join via right I don't know I wish I was waiting I
could say something down the make right now to frighten them be like I'm the
only male in via word because I have a big winky get run over me please run over
me overwatch playing games the silent instrumentals really have on gap
fucking je ne sais quoi what why are we evil of France and oh my god back to
spawn Joker tone right oh defense right I'll I'll play Widowmaker we'll give
her another chance again cuz I balls that up what's that have 255 ping mm-hmm
mm-hmm 255 so you're seeing if I put a turret down it's gonna auto him for me
hmm should have worked should I put the reflands on the spot and make them
perform should I give them performance anxiety and make them do a Scottish
accent what the fuck was that I was a roof plane he's doing should I put them
on the spot mail on stream read looks like you're in any servers do a Scottish
accent right now I'm putting them on the spot oh fuck see he's ready for it
oh yeah that's Scottish Scottish why did he go Aussie what why do you think
what I was Australian in Scotland we're not even on the same freaking part of
the tectonic plate literally the opposite side of the map brah Danny do
geography stream like I'm not a smarts but I'll name the fucking 50 states of
America right now Wyoming that's that's the best I got Wyoming I'm sorry I had
to be this way yeah get right okay and then junkrat's one but I can he suck
him off sorry I can't even hear me baby hold it together can I tell you one of
the worst put parts of my overwatch brain rock so Torbjrn has a voice line
and it goes hear me baby hold it together and for some reason every time I
used to ink his that voice line would play in my head so I'd be inking and
then all I hear is hear me baby hold it together every time I inked and this
went on for months until it eventually went away and I was like the most brain
raw you like how do you bring what that badly and before you like is it because
you love Torbjrn or something no it was just completely random like it could
have been passing to the iris for all I knew and but oh no our mayor sees down
should have picked mayor see I cannot hit that soldier I'm so sorry I'm backing
up I'm backing up oh my god rain doesn't care there's no healer he's going
deep is your soldier here what's going on come back Reinhardt back up there's no
healer rain breath back up twerk look I'll be your shield don't worry I'll be
your shield I'm healing I'm healing I can't be you should be the tank now no
literally I did it I tank I'm such a good tank I'm the best tank you worry
me sometimes mommy and they say and they say and they say yeah I don't know why
so I mean I'm sure if you send me like voicelines of you I'll probably like I
could probably brain rot and make it happen every time I think I just think
of your voiceline what would it what would a refunds voiceline be mom I'm
coming right we can't touch we can't touch bring it back bring it back bring
it back now y'all crisscross everybody okay you know the song that would
it what would the refunds it please mom would you be pleading with me oh you
can't put down your turret where's a soldier he's such a wee bambos so look
there's a fire again surrender to my will I can't wait for them to release a
Scottish Overwatch character and she has the worst heavy put on accent you know
what blizzard I'll do it for free no royalties nail payment just let me be
right I'm about to cream if you don't leave my turret alone I'm about to
ram on this map what is your flavor tea flavor it is everyday breakfast tea or
also known as black tea and I put honey in it for my throat and also honey has
anti-bacterial properties so it's good for my health as well because I don't
I kind of hinted to it the other day when I was getting my soup ingredients I
actually get really nervous I'm gonna fall ill and for strummy strum time but
you know what I'm creaming oh my god what was that did you hear that that was
really weird did you hear that noise I think it must have been a glitch from
my game I don't know if it's like a pain voiceline like played over and over
something weird yes sorry bro but
it's you never oh save real and true it's universe and sings for my hello
strongy go get the junkrat I believe in you I'm off I'm off I'm off I've got
instructions instructions to come oh you piss right I'm a shit I'm a shit I'm
a shit assassin someone else did my contract alright we need to need to be
careful be careful I'm gonna put the turret here and then when they come
around the corner it's gonna be hitting them but I'm gonna stand up here with a
junkrat so they kind of have to look up at me as well no it does give our poor
healers a bit more of a tame when we're spread around like this but I think it
will be already they'll be already I don't want to stand I saw that I saw
that oh oh I'm not not I ain't going against her so she's too strong I wait
okay I don't I'm fucking saved hold it honey mother okay we're at 41% malls
coming in gonna heal my turret oh I spank the refunds hold on hold on spank
time spanked at Stancil Stancil one spank bunk two spank bunk third spank
bunk fourth spank where are you are you to are you pulling the game where's the
fucking spank I got it I got it everyone's been spanked this game oh no
don't destroy my two no no no no no no I put some of my ink down oh you raised
to me you naughty soft pan how did you get that off how did you do that I hear
lots of footsteps I tried I'm trying to distract so much fucking thing can get
a few no no no no not like this not like this okay I'm alive okay hold on hold on
no okay it's okay I don't know how I survived though I think you have to
because I should not have survived that nice old mummy what you didn't look I had
two tiddly winks in the chamber I've been inking all stream I've been inking
everywhere to wait stay on payloads stay on payloads stay on payloads I'm coming
stay on payload do not get off I fuck oh fuck no that couldn't have gone any
alright okay hold on my cup of tea so one we're fine I like junkrat's voice
and we're literally that's how I want you guys trembling right let's pop this
down so he can't get it easily wait they have a sword horn no not to be
confused with the hit overwatch character Torbjrn ready to oh hold on a
minute don't write me out yeah don't write me out yeah are you writing me out
ma'am coming this is this is a real come all yeah that's right this is a real
communal what's so join all again what does she do what is all what's so
all I can't remember oh yeah I almost got it I almost got it right okay cheeky
B group right regroup and let's start using our one brain cell regroup regroup
let's say that is if I'm not thrown every single time I play around with you
guys as if I'm not the problem in the team unironically so darn gets a quick
rail gun shot not the only railing that's being done tonight okay mercy if
you're just gonna stand still you're getting freaking I need tank on payload
I'm so sorry darling I need tank on payload I need it I need just tank on
payload and if you hold up your shield my freaking turret will do the rest
once I get turret again right someone better start being my heel slag okay
stay on payload stay on payload because there's they only have to move at four
inches and four inches is a lot I'll have you know four inches it's meters not
inches oh yeah piss it's bigger than the right I'm gonna have my turret back
here on the chair okay so then it's gonna annoy them every time that mercy
must be a reason didn't know Torb saying it's inking time with a real literally me
if I ever got skin oh yeah it's thinking time inks all over do not get caught
out I know do not get caught out no no no my fucking I don't know who's
all else else use all sues all sues all sues all sues all sues all sues all
so it's overtime use your fucking all I love you but why are we holding on to
all okay there we go there we go
inking oh what the fuck is up a lot of it oh yeah jean what do you mean what do
you mean the police are going to be no I like the rule I like the commitment to
the rule team honey right let me see if my tea is nice oh this is what real
oh and makes a hundred it's kind of like Zarya's bubble where the stronger she
is the stronger the show right okay jay come home thank you for the game thank
you for the game you said play Anna right right we can't I promise we're
gonna win I got me addicted drinking tea for a long time where I would have to
buy to help me relax to sleep I ended up buying different kinds like Earl Grey
wild berry country peach tea and Irish breakfast tea I've never had fruit teas
I get um thingy I've not had the opportunity right hold on it was
those were the M's so I've not taken out of the S's in a hot second the one
that sounds like a bad dragon toy and you come
who we not had senpai ghost during the game so I'm so sorry I'm sure you're
just I understand you guys are probably playing games to pass the time and not
understanding tomboy Sun top I don't think I've had you and I understand
you're probably in games to pass the time from when I can invite Sentinel you
did have a shot sure it can Sean I'm gonna say no I've not had you as always
please be super fair if you did get a chance to play with me please I think
we're whittling it down though like we've had quite a lot to go yeah page 5
Jess you did get a short thank I don't know how you're at the end of the list
when it begins with you wait has just had a shot oh no you did you were team
dark team dark I think we're getting there like I think we're getting close
I'm so sorry to anyone that did have to go offline like before we could wrap it
right I'm gonna play support and damage if I get some metro I don't know how to
unlock the other heroes though sorry I'm gonna cut thank you typical nation I
mean maybe I should get fruit tea like I drink honey tea the reason the sole
purpose of the honey tea is to soothe my throat
bro literally never played mercy ever I only played one hour of just Reaper
yeah but it's a good game I would say mercy is the easiest character to try
and learn what's going on is chaos it's absolute chaos I kid you not as chaos
and yeah just play soldier 76 yes 76 is a great DPS to start with and a great
tank to start with I'm not sure about a good tank I just wouldn't play tank right
we're gonna be team we're gonna be team painkiller I'm gonna need to redo some
of painkillers in a moment because I'm here speaking of painkillers you'll
never guess what happened so we'll be fine and by painkiller I mean kill the
enemy team of plane thank you move with that and thank you the beauty Lord for
as you are my witness that was water I'm drinking
that was water I have had half a bottle of water officially one can of cola one
tea and now a second tea come pie power see them all are I boot for fun I'm a
I boot for fun Andy I'm a I'm a fiend for the boot for fun it's my preferred
poison it's also anti-inflammatory apparently I rest are probably has a
simple it's kit I'm an anti-profen and it honestly right I didn't even take a
sip of my tea I hope it's not cold oh my god they sent us to Brazil and hey
plus all to lobby como estas see oh I said I was gonna be I want to win one on
Symmetra if we're on defense we might be able to do on Symmetra with this one I
just want to win once on her I just like her I like the laser beams I like that
not all the damage wait brazil mentioned time for Brazil okay I'm gonna try and
inhale my honey tea give me a second brazil mentioned real true true true true
Torbjorn skin is a Torbikini do you remember so I never played
Overwatch when it first came out someone just unfriendly I heard a bleep that
sounded like some of them friend in there right if you guys hold this line
here
a Juno is got the anxiety oh hold on I never did the tell for they're not gonna
know okay they're not gonna know why we keep returning back Hammond piss off
piece of course it's fine I got it you guys hold the line you hold the line
people famine oh that Brigitte is getting slowed down by my turret I'm holding
the line for the Hammond cuz I can beat them up okay this is how I can beat
them up okay I can't beat them up I'm on those piggy okay okay okay okay we're
okay we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it okay we're doing we already
have a Torbz swimsuit they gave him that I thought it was a meme they did not
give him a mankini though right copium
oh hey Sardarn yeah get out here you yep Canadian you the way you eat
poutine oh that really irks me the way that you manufacture your maple syrup and
then import it around the world as if it's got some special attributes in it
yeah oh oh how dare you how dare you you Canadian you maple leaf you a fucking
leaf I like how that's what the criticism about
canada is is that it has a leaf excuse me I was rubbing my nose some of us are
right hold on let me just spam up here oh my gosh they're getting that sauce oh
not to make anyone panic there is a sniper see this Hammond he's gonna put
his wee bombs done does mercy have a res for junky wonky any resurrections for
my reefing how am I supposed to survive if I'm not railing for reeflings at once
in a match like what's the point of existing I'm sorry but what is the
point of if they're moving up I'm about to right fuck you yeah yeah nice
luck down there have fun well I'm itching my face or when you mention
that some oh rain heart oh geez as I said he just keeps leveling me up I'm
not kidding he keeps leveling me up I don't know what they're oh well junk
crits don't worry my bowl my turrets are gonna help I might die but my turrets
are helping okay for the most part my turrets are helping right widow maker
can yeah I get fucked ah I hate when it's one centimeter in a dream so as I'm
hiding ah come on come on come on come on baby I did it though I got rid of the
tank and the tank is the main problem and the rest of the teammates are
trickling in so it's not a problem and junk rat is going for it junk rat said
I see you widow maker I can do it we can do it we can do it we can do it we
can do it I can win on symmetry no my plans get them down fuck you yeah yeah
up Mars no way I made him so angry he went on a freaking different character
no no I'm weak fuck I can maybe I'll from spawn to help the teammates I don't
know I don't know I don't know if the teammates can make it in time
Reinhardt olives I can I can all from spawn if it can tick up a bit faster
three no no no it crumbles I don't know is he going for it fuck it why not fuck
it feeling a bit cheeky feeling a bit cheeky feeling a bit cheeky arm okay
right fuck it I wasted it but it's okay we're gonna win on symmetry I can do it
I'm gonna I'm gonna inhale my teeth mummies frothing at the mouth right now I
hope I don't sound insane I just really enjoy this game and it just feels
really nice that I get to play it with you and like I think because obviously I
have old knowledge of the game so it's not like I'm confused playing it or I'm
like oh like I know I don't understand the new heroes that well or the maps but
like at the end of the day I got them a core mechanics you know that's the main
thing and like it's just nice to have familiarity and playing like it feels
extra sweet and and I'm thoroughly I'm thoroughly enjoying myself what's
going on why did mercy die I don't know what she died for I'm gonna feel really
bad Reinhardt Reinhardt if I get my wake snipe because you're 360 in oh my god
oh my god oh my god I'm good I'm laser beamin yeah that'll that'll teach you
you went for it I'm actually gonna do that for someone who would like to come
back hey oh my god it's cuz he's nanoed it's cuz he's nanoed it's it's not my
fault it's not my fault it's cuz he's nanoed are none of them destroying my
lasers I'm a fire in my laser beam cuz excuse me hi yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what fucking thought that's what fucking thought we've a lot of fucking front
right anyway enough about that yes that's what I thought you're gonna harass
my reflins less likely than you think you aren't harassing my refunds okay
they're on my cock they're under my watch this game might be called overwatch
but it is my watch I'm looking after my reflins got one here
rematch are behind that's right I remember your name I remember you not
in particularly but I'm gonna get the Brigitte up right that's all we needed
soon as you break soon as you break them 30 seconds right don't get cocky
don't get cocky 30 seconds put your put your penis away don't get cocky get back
here put it away put away I don't want to see anyone pair they're gonna all
they're gonna I'm warning you I'm more I'm backing up sauce I'm backing up look
they're coming I told you there's two behind Reaper above and Genji behind on
the floor I told you oh rematchers above oh yeah I knew it I knew it I knew it
mm-hmm okay I don't yeah that's what I was worried about mm-hmm okay yeah
are they gonna clutch up shit oh my god is mercy gonna survive okay no mercy's
fine she got she got someone she got someone oh no can Ryan make it I don't
know if Ryan can touch for a bird okay no it's fine it's but oh right okay okay
right get ready to move out okay at least okay no no no this is really good
for me in particular because I have a lot of twists that I can do this stuff
and like annoy them with oh my god rematch or just say you love me just
so you want to make out with me okay this is good it's good that we're in the
section of the map because once I lay down my turret it is very awkward to
kill them as I take a chug of tea harassing is a strong job exactly we
need to put the turrets in locations where they have to essentially do a u-turn
so if the payload gets pushed up not big deal I've always wanted to play this
game my body keeps telling me no the reason why I can't say yeah but I kept
telling him that it looks so fun to play so I don't know I might download it and
it is a free to play game oh my god I don't know how I forgot how his work
is all works
oh what's what the fucking London blitz what's going on wasn't his all his all
got changed what is the London blitz now thank you typical no it's a free to
play game you should try it don't let them see us thank you friend oh my god I
hate oh I need to be able to get my ultimate I'm trying to stall on the
payload just touch the payload just touch it
what you say hey what you say but don't worry I'm gonna get a double in
Symmetra it has to be symmetric I don't count them it doesn't count his old
all is just a regular ability an orbital strike but not like this it's a
motor okay okay let's try again let's try again oh new hero I'm playing Zen I'm a
healer I'm a little heel I'm gonna shove my balls up yes do you would you like my
balls they'll make you feel better I promise I promise my balls are gonna
make you feel better they're gonna make you feel so good I'm gonna I'm gonna get
all up in there I'm gonna get all up in there right go get I'm not had you
Brunt J I know how to do right let's see right let's get right into this right
who the monkey paw has not curled yet Brunt J go get her go get a sandwich
cuz sorry I sound like the fucking witch that's like
I'm good to find out these children and eat them peppermint I'm sorry that is not
what you wanted for your name I'm just I'm I'm so sorry Broly legend I'm
what's your shagging you you're getting absolutely wrecked in dick thank you for
the super chat I am my fellow Americans my fellow Americans shit I just started
it nobody we are going to be known as team team
brew go more pay and that's all the start of your names together
that's the best I got but I'm being the healer I'm being the healer look never
says cute times are two minutes I said 18 minutes like a couple hours ago oh I've
already been playing for four hours time flies when you get to be with the one
you declare your love for me right now I'm gonna see if any of them are gonna
talk are they too shy to say I love your moment oh we've got shilings on this
maybe the team I'm gonna put in brackets shilings clearly oh my god none of them
declare their love for me shilings and exclamation mark I've scared them the
I love you okay my tea is almost room temperature that's okay
a reefing says where you plugged no GGs mommy I haven't touched overwatch since
season one but had a blast playing with your honest lane small doses the game
isn't nearly as bad as people make it out to me oh no like please don't think
I'm gonna randomly turn into an overwatch streamer I just love games where
you can wonder free to play because I don't like the idea of you spending
money just to play with me it makes me feel bad it makes me feel bad because I
want it to be accessible to you and I want it to be a say it back I love you
too and wait what did I pick the wrong role oh I picked the wrong role can I
pull out can I come out with you's okay right we're all coming together come
with me support is everyone is my witness that says a plus sign next to me
for I am the field medic I assure you I will not touch you and a way you do not
desire you pick both to get whoopsie why do mods hate me mama I don't know you
I'll I'll see one thing you're coming out with a lot of ink stuff I think it
might be that I think everything's an ink reference oh no you're not wait hold
on I'm no wait I'm analyzing what you've been saying you play tank because you
need the health I play tanks I take punishment for my team we're not same
okay my darling refling mods I kindly request from you ease up a little that's
all I know I know I know I know I think I know what you're doing it wait that's
bill or not wait what there's terminate I said everyone's getting renamed to a
singular we fling sorry
broly legend wait are your messages getting deleted I thought the booty
lords messages were getting deleted yeah wait broly legend or your talks
getting deleted like your chat what are you saying I actually could not hear you
in game earlier testing to clear your fucking wait is it my headset Mike test
is this is this my headset Mike wait what's my input hold on wait hold on let
me test hold on testicles testicles escape options social default microphone
streamer mode what does that do oh no sorry you can see my name would be such
a shame if you added you know what for anyone that has played with me does it
sound like this microphone that I'm talking to you right now my make isn't
working in day my love you mama oh no don't give me money for that it was a
tease and meme thank you for this super chat don't don't give me money like
though okay voice setting should be certain but you can hear me and don't
super chat that you can hear me in game this sounds like the stream microphone
right or am I really low in game
oh the monkey paw curled monk eyes right it's time for some balls but anyone
like my balls oh my follow me oh can you hear me yeah I can hear you okay now
declare your love for me wait you guys don't talk in game in general you guys
don't talk in game in general it's just like a new concept and none of you talk
I regret putting on headphones the voice lines are so loud Jackson Shaw thank you
for the extended membership Johnny I love you reapling I love you do you guys
not talk in game wait I talk in game all the time I'm like a I'm like one of
those people that are like oh and oh you're doing so well and like oh that's
great oh my great you know you're not used to talking are you not gonna lose
your ability to talk if you like don't talk in general where to make her on
stairs I didn't even get a chance to heal that reflin I feel so bad right now
oh my god I'm gonna blame the ping oh my god 300 billion ping even though it's
200 which means it's actually pretty decent thing I've a discord or bone
widow maker top right oh no we don't make again I'm the only healer I'm the
healer I'm trying oh my god the balls the balls aren't cooperating oh my gosh
it's not this is not one how I like it I can't go on oh my gosh they're having a
tank off I can't heal bro I can't sorry then it's so hard then it's so hard I'm
not even funny see that window maker oh my god see you widow maker I'm coming
for your wake no no no you're no the only one I stay oh it won't have a nice
day I'm like oh no don't leave the game ah oh my god please don't die did they
nerve sends balls I feel like they're so useless I don't even have all yet I
heard spending money also there isn't a point to talk in game anymore there's an
appointed talking to me wait what I heard spend money Alan stop it you're
getting spanked why is it not going on I think my sentence needed just that it's
like not going on the player I want it to go on and I think it's maybe like
super sensitive thank you for the super chat don't get me fucking random oh my
god we've got the tank down that's good cuz they'll struggle to ping ping ping
fuck that no let's see what she saw no lies that's not what I saw yeah you want
you may turn in a fucking dog I'll do this stream cuz I'm getting rabbit
again oh my god I'm going for her ankle I dare you to peak me a little French
barbecue stop it no no no when you're healed when you're damaged hold on oh my
god I hate her spend money I got you must stop it really listen Lucy oh no I
can't heal you I can't put my balls on you can I put my balls on your jaw can
you put my balls on your jaw I mean I could all I would be a bit dramatic though
oh my god see you you eat bar that's what you get oh I'm all in sauce this is my
payload my payload I don't care oh bastion you cheeky sod you're lucky
you're lucky I'm a five-head you're lucky I'm observing everything on the map
all at once all all four reflands health bars are materialized into my brain
tissue I have all of you on the roster not one of you will die under my watch
there may have been few mistakes before but mistakes are mistakes you will not
die under my watch and there isn't a point to talk in game anymore oh you mean
in general I thought you meant like to me while we're in gameplay and I was like
I don't mind if you say hi right I'm backing up backing up because they're
gonna have all and I don't have good heels Lucio I'm gonna need your help to
fucking heal and Lucio's gone they have nerfed her ball I kid you not my
freaking balls are useless they are hardly healing I'm a DPS I'm starting to
think I'm DPS I'll I'm what is my heel per second on the ball I'm a
core mechanic they've changed on him I'm so confused I only have one ball I can
put on a refland at one time why is the heel so slow why am I being punished
okay perfect gorgeous stunning lovely discord discord the brahmata brahmata
I'm all in I don't care I'm all in my payload now get off get away I repel you
with my all get off here gorgeous 10 out of 10 gameplay fantastic team shilings
more like team stomped on him then yeah is hybrid damage healing oh my god oh
my god look at that oh that's right look at that aimbot and then watch this
rematch our discord orb and pop on him go for a very late melee but that's
because I have lag that that's not me he wasn't dead on my screen yeah okay G
motherfucking G's G motherfucking G's that was good one that was a rolling and
smoking right change your old stop cancel castle but don't cancel me the
monkey paw has been uncurled oh yeah right who have I not had
hmm
Ched gay have I had Ched gay I'm analising my list I'm checking it twice I'm
trying to find the refling has inked once or is being nice I don't think I've
had you I'm a I'm assume you guys are gonna respectfully have I had crazy
have I had crazy Jesse I'm looking at a list now DC packed it I have you am I
gonna mental that I have you or did you not accept a friend and invite now you
need a reject if you've had a shot with me I'm gonna fart on your eyelash because
I want all refunds to have a shot and but as a reminder I and then dog have I
just straight-up will up dog
don't but a dog flame arrow did you know the chance did you open make I heard
that I'm coming for you flame arrow you're gonna I think these are gonna have
to start rejecting if I'm adding years and you've had a shot I'm looking about
I don't see I but to show you I'll show it I'll take a picture to show you how
scribbly my stream state notes are they just like descend into like utter
madness Evangelion ain't that an enemy big Evangelion I don't think I've had you
I'm gonna say I've not had you wait hold on don't accept don't accept I have too
many reflings right I don't think this is variable confirmation none of you have
played with me today right I have not played today
scouts on her scouts on her reflings on her oh my god sorry this is a scouts
honor gang that was so cute scouts on her sick yeah oh oh and then that was
so cute and then I'll put Kawaii name brackets kit where I if you did a
digitalist you could do control left this evening I said I didn't so because
you're all funny Tee hee ha ha right I'm gonna win on Symmetra I want to win
once on Symmetra okay refling's honor that's so cute the beauty lord thank you
for the super chat yeah I deserve to get muted I'm a Luddling a Luddling
refling each word on the game calm a Luddling a refling hungry call me call
him a feeder enabling wait no I'm the feeder what were you wait what's the name
of you if you're the prey when it comes to feeding the gainer yeah again laying
there we go I got there in the end reefland hungry but I'm feeding call
him a gainling game gain a laying geez I'm really struggling that's squids on her
ma'am not spreadsheet you look at recent players I think recent players might
actually factually show the enemy team as well
no challenges when three games no on all keep I I can't even play thank I don't
know how to unlock the other characters like I've still not unlocked them
progression what's this sub the badges play games any hero and to represent
badges professional let prestige player icon names I'll okay I'm a level 2
Torbjorn shit you caught me I love a good tour where I don't have to aim when
my pings a billion how do I today's top fat insta capture three highlights
expires every patch today's top five oh I remember this used to be a thing so
that's not new that used to be a thing I think and then you could like save them
up wait how do I figure out how when I'm gonna lock a new hero in the battle path
no clearly not where career I think it's missions or quest missions
challengers event lifetime hero right uh-huh complete 50 games a win is double
progress right so who's gonna unlock next it's just a fucking chance unlock
echo can be found in hero echo unlock okay nice one very polished you have to
do 150 games like I'm gonna be honest I don't think I got 150 games I mean I
don't know how many games we've done so far but I'm not sure I'm 150 minutes I'm
actually ran out I'm gonna have to get a new piece of paper cuz on the other side
of the stream sniping I think is for tonight it is I've got team name check
mo fumblings prime gods the reckoning of the radical reeflings and scissors
a Peter the game dairy is here I can't do it and get his that must be for tonight
and then on the other side is over watch right we're on a tax a metro come on
give me give me a show Genji you better freaking carry so hard I'm no even
being funny right hydration check hydration check did you go pee by the
way did you go pee I hope you pee I hope you pee I hope you pee and I hope it
won't do anything we can he see you and no we're coming for you so no you're not
jumping us we jump in you we jumped we're gonna jump your ass right in the
crack that's right I'm gonna jump welcome to the rock of Gibraltar did you know
Joe brought us like a part of the UK randomly well maybe not random okay
Farah is probably needing a pair whoa why am I getting attacked here I don't
know no she's one oh my god you did it oh my god you did it you did it right
they're gonna get distracted trying to destroy my we to the L right divas
at the Mac Farah's respond get that get that horror on wings I've seen what
those I've seen what those animations are I know what you are far oh I didn't
even oh yeah what's going on here but we got her does it count as a straggler I
think she I think they changed the response if I think about it they
changed the response so now when the thing mama every part of the world was a
part of the UK at some point do you wait do you actually mean that because I
believe it I know there was the British Empire but we were Scotland so you know
we weren't forced to learn too much about it I know I was begging that oh I
messed up so badly sorry oh my god him with it him with a 360 and then give
him a little wave just in case that's play of the game just in case the bailout
thank you for the geography no it's history it's geographical historical
geography yeah that's much more sense put it the other round if it doesn't
sound right in English just swap it around you'll do fine okay that was a
fast push maybe the sim attack sim real is the way to go
unfortunately unfortunately unfortunately although again she's hunting
down that mercy he said now I'm not taking that oh that's so scary the way
she's in the ground oh you have a skin you're a real overwatch player I mean if
you pay money in the game for the skin I feel like you must enjoy the game oh I
don't think so nice try though
what was that thing I don't really want to go against the Sombra I'm gonna be
honest
I don't have my ultimate yeah I'm came to hoping for what's going on what's going
on I don't I don't know where's my tank I'm getting nervous I don't see my tank
I'm gonna sneeze where's my tank did they die I'm so sorry I never paid it I
don't realize your pop your clothes no way oh gorgeous gorgeous reflin gorgeous
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous why is that not a door I don't know when is the door
not a door when it's a jar hold on thank you thank you oh my god gee we won
and fun too we won on some her name's a little sombra symmetrical they alone oh
my god I'm oh and it's a refund let's see it let's analyze he goes in for the
swipe gets the kill he's shaking he's quaking are you perp
I was it you're you're shaking do you have high sensitivity I mean you are a
reflin so by default you have high sensitivity
that's not even a joke I'm now that's nice right cancel we we smoked that oh
my god that was like bruh we smoked that right who next we flins coming to
turn okay Bing boom bop boom bing boom bing bum boom bing hmm can't invite you
but I don't think you've had a show I don't think you've had a show I know you
guys are probably doing an evangelical you never got chance Fox robot
gaming cutscene hidden squid and legend sold that did I get you or were you're
gonna be a better than I had to get you please do the honor system I'm looking
so that I don't think let me consult my beloved sheet of paper I'm looking for
the letter L but I don't see it so I don't actually think you've been in I
think what it is is I think I'm about to get you in and then I'm like oops wait
hidden squid are you going for a job a I see I see you wait for a shine you may
for a shine a fucking job right even to even the bells of overwatches ring
and hidden squiddle you're tamed out again right legend sold out I don't even
let you in and then level I don't think I've had you in either
bunk level five would and together we're gonna be team world of warcraft but in
particular we're gonna be team wargin team wargin yeah what was that mean my
brain just oh no hold on hold on you didn't you didn't come in hold on two
okay stop wanking on the job but the fuck try again get in here there's no
head of shop the struggle being on page through the whole time I'm so sorry I'm
actually looking and we're getting close to the point where everyone is just like
look everyone we that we're on this page now and it already turns to s here I'm
I'm so sorry for the later names but look on page three it's already like I've had
a shot with the zealots two moons had a shot tomboy had a shot you've not had a
shot did you have a shot we you weren't part of the S team now you weren't you've
not had a shot you've been waiting tigers like you did get one a sculpting yeah right
what's going on do the one after level five what for no particular reason wink
wink we're still playing new reeflings yeah I've still not ran a train long
enough right unfortunately wood elf is dying up there mommy I'm cooking you're
cooking all right you're cooking right now sorry sorry sorry sorry okay I'll take
your name out take your name out meme mazer welcome to team Morgan World of
Warcraft and together with our team we are going to oh no we won on Zinnia
didn't we but then who don't eat a plate I'll do both damage and support but I
feel like we're winning like a decent amount of games what's my win how do you
win quickly right but how do I go in two hours played well the stream zone was
five hours long so one of us is telling feathers one of us is telling
feathers and it's not me where's the wins games 1 13 I feel like we'd be in
and out I'd be I'd be in and out you so quick I feel like I miss trains one so
it's not only all games played 16 damn that's a high win loss I'm sure outcome
tumbling down once it gives me a hidden MMR but so I think I would get a new
hero at 20 then let me find it let me find it heroes I should I want a
Brigitte I've not had oh wait did I play as Anna I did did I win on Anna I
don't know I might play Anna for my shit do you know what are you I don't
even know how to more challenges cannot be complete and cuss oh no I'm not
cussing in a lifelover what are you can be found in hero unlock unlock yeah I'm
on it oh 150 wait so you know how the whole point of the stream was to let me
play general all I'm saying if yous are sick of overwatch I'll just do a
membership overwatch stream because the whole point of this stream was to let me
on general what are you like fucking hell jump scare oh my god
refunds dying we need to take him to the hospital time to get my gloves on hold
on I actually have my latex once your MMR gets adjusted that win
she was gonna tank oh I know right who who what are we attack
uh-huh Hanzo Hanzo actually Hanzo mean so I mean is currently in Japan right
now and I sent her a message I was like take lots of photos and have so much fun
are you saying you kiss it what is the secret wait if I start coughing it's
your fault the overwatch gone wrong almost died real okay I'm Hanzo me I'm
Hanzo me and I don't have any him I don't have any someone dying on stream
would be great clickbait ah as much as I love a good bit of publicity I'm
probably just gonna do what I see did and do like a tango milestone you know I
think for 25k I'll do the tango ASMR but it has to be after the 19 because that's
when my wee warning expires okay I am a okay get out my face if someone be no
it's Juno's gun right I'm not used to Juno's gun yet okay not bad not bad not
bad and Sean Sean Tato aim or calling me potato aim wasn't enough you had to
really you had to characterize it to me you know what don't you bend over that's
the only punishment I can justify oh my god no it's the elemental P1 oh okay I
missed everything but I am a Hanzo mean I promise
I'm scared okay hold on McCree to the right who are you I need to figure out
what Juno's kit is I still don't you know didn't comprehend oh I hurt someone
there by accident that's what I'm saying then whatever I play hands though the
enemies seem to walk into my my bullets and I'm like well they're in my knee
you don't I can hear that J that Mao is getting closer though oh my god I need to
all but this game you're gonna freakin wallop my boss act yeah we oh no the
objectives there oh my god he's one HP now I got him I'm so proud of myself so
he I think we're doing it sorry I don't know it's a tag
you might be one of few players that play better I'm doing fit so is so is I've
got too much of an ego on this game I'm literally creaming my crackers I'm so
good at this game I'm snorting G fuel the G fuel snort made the difference see
that Genji more like pathetic wedgie no what it breath it has a shield for his
teammate you can use it as a freaking oh my god the Anna is so weak behind and
the Genji's weak as well I'm so sorry I'm missing everything
oh that Anna's weak oh my god if you could if I knew how to put my heart
rate monitor on screen right now it'd be over I get so lightheaded because I
forget to breathe I genuinely forget to breathe playing this game okay it's fine
I can hear Genji go away I am ah you know feel well I had that kill you eat
give me I can't get him I'm sorry I can't when he is that a more nimble we're
gonna have to go for him I'm not even kidding I can't eat it I'm just letting
you down unironically I'm letting you down hold on right can we focus our
brain power Genji Genji left Genji what happened can't you see this Genji see
I'm darting about the screen like a little flea bouncing left right he's on
the wall she's on the floor he's upside down get him I'm getting trolled by this
but he will not best me my brother get I just I remember the lore now hands on
Genji your brothers we both have dragon pets or something like that I don't know
oh my god I helped by capturing oh Juno is so cute what the heck I want her in
gen 2 I like that design of being fully covered up but shapely does that make
sense yeah yeah yeah go time oh no friendly go time I thought it was enemy
go time I was like yeah yeah go time ah I had one
fucking I reflected whatever Juno I am not panicking
oh come on no this cannot be this cannot be I'm trying so hard for the
refunds I don't want to let them down be like let's all just press Q brah yeah
exactly oh my god they wasted it they threw they threw they threw because they
used all their alchemists I see as we are missing three alchemists on their team
what who said that that wasn't me that was a man analysis of the gameplay okay
see this Genji deflecting but I'm actually so bad I never hit him once
that's embarrassing on his face okay they're coming oh my god Genji's
coming after me oh my god oh my god it's a McCree McCree's like on the
balcony at the point to the left nine o'clock I don't know oh my god we're
getting dismayed oh my gosh I can't let my teammates down
I need to snort some more gamerships I need to snort more gamerships cuz it's
not working please do not snort okay I helped I helped I got a kill okay yeah
right I got a wee bit I got a whiff on McCree you know a wee cheeky headshot you
know me I do love a wee bit we bet cheekiness you know oh come on that
was a headshot I can't fucking see my wee brother he's actually a wee rat I'm
pretty sure I'm older than him I'm like 99% sure I'm older than Genji I feel
like he's the wee brother and yeah cuz Hansel wanted to kill him take over the
family business or some question I was like damn I'm sure about that I'm about
to get annihilated I'm point right what does she do she seems to have oh she
has all that's right that's right she has an all lock thing and that's what the
bubble sound effect is okay right
oh that one well oh my god right that's what that BBB is okay I'm learning I'm
learning I'm getting edge imitated
mada mada mada why does she sound like a Scottish person mada mada hurry hurry
hi you cool hi you cool I missed I missed again oh my god my creep please
just perish I really can't be dealing with you right now I need to like kill
their healer oh my god Juno's one I love wasting my ability it's actually
everyone use all use also when you get them this is the last fight I never got
one shot on him I never got one shot on him I said what oh I got him you're
welcome I actually clutched I'm welcome I'm I do come well sometimes
I'm gonna respawn I'm gonna respawn and I'm gonna send dragons I'm gonna
respawn I'm gonna send dragons I'm chasing dragons I'm chasing oh my god
I'm chasing everyone's fucking dead oh my god watch this are you ready for this
move oh shit okay okay okay him with a tracer and this is by a ball here did
we win oh so close we cook chat so close that wasn't even that bad oh my god
that wasn't even that bad I'm not mad that was so close you did so well
reflens you did so so well oh my gosh go on then shows that MLG my free
gameplay oh my god me just absolutely perishing he didn't even he didn't even
see me the crosshair was gone the crosshair was gone okay we're doing it
fasting time I hope you're ready for that me by the way thank you for the
playing okay right invitation dude boy I don't think you've had a chance so that
I'll give you another chance you you better be finished cooking boss I don't
think I had Boston as I said please do the honor system I'm gonna cry I'm gonna
cry if the honor system isn't followed I'll I'll be
would be nice momo would be nice dude boy dude perfect dude boy level 5l me hi I'm
just gonna call you boss I'm gonna just call you boss I'm gonna be honest with
you chief I'm just calling you boss okay and together we will be team man that's
that's her name team I almost killed the tank but you whiffed off the knee worry
about it I'm having a good time I serious I am thoroughly enjoying myself I'm
playing Bastion your problem not mine I'm playing Bastion hydration check my
way to we friend mmm thank you for the game got to bring my inner healer you
little hill slot you mm you should heal slack from me thank you the beauty lord
for the super chat again even though it's an entire my gameplay is not now I mean
maybe it's a little bit and yes as I said tomorrow the celebration for 20 case
getting changed and then I think the celebration for 25k is gonna be a
banger bus is coming ASMR stream and when when my warning gets taken off which
is in two weeks time roughly I've I played this map hello I'm right I'm I'm
about people no I'm a people oh yeah oh yeah who's that I heard that I was a
reason oh yeah looking in the shadows I think I've almost I think we've almost
officially done it I think I've almost officially ran a train through it only
took me five hours to run a train like come on right what is this map oh it's
really pretty oh my god it kind of reminds me of like futuristic bio labs
though I hate being old Ellari doesn't like it here where are we I picked up
the game just for you knew oh my gosh I would be up for playing this in the
future yes I'll give it a big break though because I cannot be this excited
all the time oh this map is gorgeous look at the plants everywhere I don't know
have it please but this is cute
kawaii ne right shoot shoot it looks like I have a main though back in the
mind take your pickaxe from side to side oh I get it now my all is literally
this get the reaper oh dear oh dear I didn't like that mmm I didn't like that
dear I say it's a gallon it's a ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch you know very curious
oh the diva the diva diva diva diva diva yes yes yes perfect perfect perfect
oh sorry sorry the reaper you need to get the reaper off of her Winston there
you go there you go gorgeous stunning we're sharing that brain cell oh they're
doing it soldier soldier soldier if you can oh oh oh no wait I did play this map
I played it with sin didn't I play this map with sin I didn't even pay attention
right diva coming back just get some alt charge on her that's right I'm a real
overwatch coach that's not the only thing I can coach you on lower your pan
oh reaper behind reaper behind yeah that's what I thought nice try me nice
try me okay diva out of mech again I'm gonna try not give her it but I don't
know how effective my need is it seems like it what's real see what I'm looking
at I don't know if I got anyone oh wow I did a surprise let's get rid of that
that's how a lari heals from a lamp post okay a lari can do a pirouette no no
no not like these no no no right if he's gonna go away unfortunately I'm gonna
get rolled from behind because of this there's a reaper back oh dear oh dear
surprise I got you bitch about the reaper so there's no one behind us anymore
Winston Holland ass yeah that oh no I'm no pushing so as I'm on my own I'm no
pushing the only thing I'm pushing is boundaries of the enemy team because I
shouldn't be in their spawn tee he right you want to back up I'd love to play
again yeah like I said like once I finish doing the like everyone gets a
chance if you want I can pitch us against each other like we can go against
each other if you want and 5v5 custom lobby if not we can just keep doing
public games and then I can work focus on trying to unlock more characters all
right I need to go oh yeah I'm gripping up sorry I'm getting out sorry I'm
backing up back and back and up back and up back and up cuz my daddy taught me
good I'm backing the hell out of there and I'm like oh my god oh my god congrats
to the one person that gets my reference right we're gripping up our tank is
coming we're taking our sweet time now they have to come around this corner
anyway so are you serious are you serious right now right her defense
matrix is completely uh no no no no Brigitte's Brigitte's fucked up Brigitte's
fucked up yep okay lovely we love to see it
repart yep we love to see it diva diva next even X even I oh no she's full
health again oh my god our brains our brains are sinking you're all having a
chicken breast brain smooth no lumps and bumps but it's working we are sinking
okay what are you thinking about that's another meme reference you might know and
it's like what I was thinking about and it was like haha play on accent okay okay
we're going in again I do have my ultimate you know what fuck I'm doing
it right now let's see what we're looking at bam bam bam bam yeah I knew you were
coming oh no everyone died everyone died I'm sorry I couldn't hold it together I
just heard it's a moon behind me and I was like it's over I don't know how I
didn't die I got 350 health as a DPS wow they've definitely mucked around with
the health the law is everyone like tankier no no no no no no no get out what
oh he has replenish health when he shoots he has replenish okay okay one big
up right get that we need to we need to hone in on our lovely brains right we're
gonna respawn at the same time so it may be a blessing in disguise that we all
perished at the same time Winston's already in the heat of it into
Winston I love the confidence oh come on oh that was a freaking pixel I'm backing up
you may be able to get out soldier and put a heal down for yourself oh no I don't
have health anymore oh my god that's the ability they took away from Bastion he
can't self heal oh my god I just I just took all of that damage like a good
I was in the down yes he's in nine increase everyone's health all right all
right all right all right okay let's no no no no let's stop I'm getting I'm
getting hurt I'm getting help help help help help oh god it's also one be one
who's got wait something else get me oh I didn't even see them agree well they're
down to defend an attacker so oh dear oh dear that I did not even see on ballroom
blitz I really wish you could listen to like your music while we play games
together that would be really sweet you guys can take the music and we can all
hang out and just game away game the day away Reaper behind Reaper half behind
just be aware be advised we first behind don't go looking for a fight where
you don't need to but I'm a crease in this we think oh there's a jump there's so
many noises going on I hear them okay okay okay okay okay okay okay don't hurt
him right okay I am definitely a big target for Diva I need to not be as
aggressive I'm a very large and easy formable target for Diva I'm all the way
back here I get a little speed this like that other you did it oh they didn't
even need me there unironically the reeflings didn't even need me you won
GG why are you on a bicycle where's the spurs or this the sporkle thing email
Bulbers you're not refund I don't care about the cake oh no you're gonna see me
show me look I'm getting harassed by the Reaper and then I'm like no I'm in I
was so late back home I help I help a little bit you know okay and then thank
you for the game and then I open up social and then I did invitation and be
and above and a bag and a big bag and then next team I'm having to write it
smaller and smaller because I'm running out of paper and I don't I don't I actually
don't know right analyze becks you've no being in I know for a fact you've no
being in because I don't recognize you okay becks is in you played you played
you played you you you you you you just played didn't you played you played
earlier hidden squid we're gonna try you again you played you played you played
you played no oh we did you were my very first team you were in team noobie
boobie a Primal Primal I've got you in team Nuka Cola I believe programmer your
team Nuka Cola as well Senpai ghost Senpai ghost did you have a shot
analizing analizing I think I tried to get you in and it never worked out so in
come shin as well
I don't think I've had you no and then Sigma
uh no I don't think I do either okay we're gonna be called team Sigma
okay team Sigma not and then sick and then on our system you guys haven't played
I'm analizing the book and then so we're already at the S's so whoever's past the
S's tells zero Scotland cycle on you look like my next team and you look like
did I unlock anyone no I won on Bastion okay let's the healer again healer or
DPS I'll take either I'm on what that's like mom all it took was getting on the
page to I'm sorry for making your ways along is I thoroughly enjoy stream
sniping games I understand though if you're sitting wait I mean fuck we're
at the five-hour mark if you were here at the start waiting to play goddamn do
you have some patience for me fucking had to smack in a cryo pod run to because
that took a while can we analyze your moment I don't know do you think you
can handle the cake is there like a PNG of Mercy staff Mercy staff PNG from
I want to stick it on me I need it like up you down the way though
how would I how would I rotate you hmm these aren't PNG's why are you pretending
I want like a little forget it I'm gonna fart forget it I'll just find it okay
um defend who are not played oh right okay do you want to see how bad I am at
Genji I do not touch Genji where 10-foot pole
Kerika didn't play did you know did I try and get you in and I think you played
I don't realize we phones waiting for first game right now I'm so sorry this is
I don't I don't play Genji I don't do anything with them I never touch them
because I don't have the frame rate in built in my hardware to register what's
going on fast enough I don't have it I don't know how to do it I'm just here
for a good time Ohio that's the best for getting pro Genji strats bro I'm
following that I don't know oh already took them down half health because of
those cheeky headshots I'm backing off I'm backing off oh no it's my job to get
the widow maker no I don't want to but I don't want to get the widow maker I'm
scared wait hold on I can climb on stuff oh I mean I could oh oh oh yeah
believe it oh yeah believe it how'd I get out of here well I've made my bread
a bed and I'm gonna rock oh no I needed to reload sorry about timing oh my god
is this how I'm supposed to do it I feel like I don't know I feel like my job is
to be a nuisance like that's what my job is to be as Genji like I'm supposed to
just jump around that's I'm double jumping can't touch this me me me me me
me can't touch this just just like the bad guys on lethal weapons to I have
diplomatic immunity so hammer MC hammer you can't sue I don't know the rest I'm
sorry I love reflecting and then it's like ha ha
this is a what's that word it's a it's a big word for Elmo oh I'm climbing bye
Mersey do you want to fly off of me oh Mersey McCree's on point McCree's on
point oh I don't ever reflect I don't oh I did it though so I did it though you're
welcome I'm actually I do come well thank you oh oh my god I'm doing it maybe
maybe all I needed was the refunds in order to play whoever I want like I'm
not being funny but I don't play Genji at all oh god there's a widow maker
didn't get your wife's night didn't get your wife's night oh I say that as if
I'm no getting my feet snipe oh oh oh she's trying to go for me saws you can't
handle this oh oh you can't handle this I'm away oh they're here I don't like to
that and then I'm sorry dimfist I don't I don't play this oh no dimfist don't do
that
is this what I'm supposed to do I don't I don't know what I'm doing I'm going I
don't know I'm going I'm going out over I think I did okay normally when I see a
play of the game from a Genji he's doing a lot more like dashing in the air
maybe that's what I was supposed to do in that instance that could have gone
worse but it didn't that's what's to focus on that could have gone terribly
wrong what's your name bob so they calling you Bob stop playing you know that
I'm known for the Bob okay I'm gonna just let my team do everything your dash
resets when you get killed ah that makes sense why they're always like jumping
about the map jump up jump up and get down I hear footsteps and they ain't
friends oh I'm scared I'm scared oh no wait why would you get Winston I'm not
good no I can't tell the Winston he's gonna kill my mercy you thought I can't
oh my god did they increase Winston's attack that feels so quick oh no he
damaged me from the job I don't know I'm trying to get there fast enough but
I'm too slow and double jumping we have no ults either right okay we'll take the
L on this one but but we'll be okay there is a Winnie Winnie the poo
oh that was an accident well it wasn't an accident I tried oh that's another
overwatch thing you know that voiceline you just heard he where he goes the
advantage is mine because of his accent I had no idea what he's saying and I
thought he says the adabanteum is mine and I was like I don't know what adabanteum
is it must be the currency inside the overwatch or something because yeah I
was too daft to even have a clue what it meant it was him saying the word
advantage and I'm I'm rather slow and the reason why I didn't know what he was
saying is because they didn't have subtitles for eons they did not have
subtitles and overwatch and they added it and then I could finally read what
they were saying I don't know what it's called when you can like never
understand what's being oh god oh that Winston bubble just saved her I don't
have a reflect if that McCree's about to all I'm so sorry I don't know I'm
helping sometimes I that widow must be having a field day like this Genji
doesn't know what he's doing okay I did it Christmas miracle I'm out sorry I'm
having to use my dash to get out I'm out I'm away don't look at me I'm not I'm
not good at games like that okay I'm hiding inside the building I'm just
letting them I'm just gonna pretend it's all lag okay it's all lag oh he's got
spanked we got to be spanking I was to me hi I'm so sorry no this is really
embarrassing for me I'm so sorry can you just die this is really embarrassing
please just die I'm not being funny please oh my god I'm in their spawn I'm
in their spawn fuck please this is embarrassing I'm so embarrassed right now
stop I don't want to be in your spawn right sorry as I said I just
distracted their tank my teammate should not be struggling to defend that
payload I just had their whole team on me one enemy they should not be you
should not be having issues defending up I cannot help you Anna I'm so sorry no
I don't come back for more no this is embarrassing Winston this is embarrassing
stop it look I've never played Genji before leave me alone you we fart let me
just be bad at Genji okay let me just be bad again to I mean I'm doing art I
am doing all right it was a little I'm just spraying where I think they're
gonna show up and a stop as soon as the organ the main thing is I didn't panic
I didn't panic I don't know I did not panic as if he just all of that as if oh
my god take that me take that me six little sludge oh my god I'm the real
Genji right okay okay I'm analyzing my gameplay okay first thing I did wrong is
didn't click anyone's head okay okay tank okay tank some payload just need to
I'm just sure can around the payload no oh my god I'm getting her I'm helping
I'm helping why is Moira there oh my god maze one maze one ish kind of I'm gonna
just spray down the middle how about that there we go I'm helping I'm not I'm
just free you ink I'll spray deal you ink I'll spring spring spring I am getting
my I do have my ultimate for the last baby my fellow reflex there's me that's
right I'm doing call outs you know what fuck it oh shit I never did my dash
how do they do it there must be some science to I'm sorry oh I'm letting my
teammates die sorry I need to go Torbjorn I'm not letting them die because I'm a
fucking idiot I'm not disappointing the reflands because I wanted to be a hero
and use my all when it was silly to I just threw I just threw why did you do
that I'm so sorry we friends I just threw so badly I am so sorry we friends
I'm so sorry this is why I don't play what's his name Genji okay I don't play
Genji I don't touch him my 10-foot pole he stinks I don't like him carry headshots
so 120 damage your dash and then you all when you all you get your dash back
oh that means so much oh you got sneak around you got taken by surprise here's
me like hello I would like to kill you please don't shoot me okay change rolls
change rolls are you sure you didn't get oh if someone called Kanaka you're
called Kerika why the odds your name versus someone over zero you've not had
a chance I'm just no you're in a game so I can't I do zero vocal that should be
the squad right Kerika over zero and then another zero I should just call
00's shaken not stirred vocal fuck it we're just going to call 007 there's so many years
in the squadron oh no 005 because there's five of us yeah 005 team 005 okay I'm not playing
Genji again though I'm gonna be a hero I'm no sorry I'm gonna be healer I want to be a little
he'll shoot okay my brain's starting to shot down just a wee bit but please don't think I'm not
gonna compete 5v5 I'm gonna put us in a custom game once everyone's had a shot okay you'll get
them next time a body better everyone is gonna get a shot for me to ride them like a damn train
and then I'm gonna pitch us against each other and I'm gonna be in one of the teams so obviously
you have a chance to destroy me in game you're welcome don't worry we'll win I'm lying
oh so thanks to our tank that range you really held the lane for us
what as Genji are you trolling I didn't I did not do good as Genji Genji's very squishy but
faster than agile yeah I'm more of a dwarf build myself mummy's feeding like we say winning
we can listen to music without well playing games together it takes some setup
um
if I make a twitch again and add a bubble bolt we can listen to music together apparently when
we game oh and you guys can add what you want to hear oh my god yeah because it would be set for
hmm
I see I see
that that wouldn't go in there
I think that would work out yeah we definitely try that we're on a roll we couldn't try that
watch together maybe watch together would be a bit easier and then I'll get you guys to submit
your songs and then I'll make sure my audio is separate but obviously I'm gonna do karaoke I mean
there's me all you're gonna hear is
utilizing utilizing
hmm
okay I think I think we manage it I feel bad about beating you if I was in the other team
I welcome it are you joking me beat the fucking shit out of me oh my dad sent me a photo what did
he send me if I fucks like he sent me the most boomer mean ever the meme goes where are you
question mark and then the other person says Jim and then the person says really send me a picture
and it's a picture of mcdonald's sign with the G in the wine front of it dad I love you but oh my god
I'm gonna need to teach you some real humor oh my god
I mean if I stalk your Overwatch profile um I mean I'm only gonna touch it when we play together
you can literally jump on it like look I'm a Torbjorn main and some hit your main apparently
just try to get one on them these are all the characters I've yet to unlock and I I want
goon well excuse me goon peak boomer humor honestly that's peak
you're only gonna touch it when we play together oh wait that's what she said thank you thank you
I'll be streaming all day what else have I got I got microwave sound let's just listen to
microwave ambience together yeah I'm gonna the next reflin that fucks up my game I'm gonna wrap
you up in tin foil put you in the microwave and blow you up to fuck
that's terrible that's terrible okay oh wait I've not wrote someone's name down
I've not played blue seal have I not put me on the road skates I'm off on one
we go to brazil put grapes in the microwave night oh they explode in the microwave I don't know that
not the sound of the radiation I suddenly got scared just running
now by another figure no wait wrong stream anyway have to wake up in three hours good night mama
oh my god go to sleep oh a mormolo thank you for the 100 tip go the fuck to sleep
oh my gosh please rest well go to sleep
the radiation is too much of radiations like now
uh go buy another figure yeah that's the wrong stream we're not I don't know what that
reflin's on about buying figurines I've never heard of it okay I'm gonna just stay on heels like
a good little heel salute that I am oh I'm healing oh my leg whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
right get sigma oh my god he's glowing oh sorry I let the me die
when strone's tell you you aren't getting enough sleep that's what we're going too far
actually I got four hours I think but so what's happening now is my sleep is going in two segments
I was looking it up if you really need like a full eight hours in a row and I was awesome I don't
know I don't know so I saw some reports that were like no you can actually just split up your sleep
it's not that big of a deal because obviously the eight hour sleep is in um oh my god I'm going on
the walls sorry I'm creeping around I'm on the walls I'm just spraying oh my god this tracer
is getting a bit of a bother get off the map oh my gosh this Juno I keep wanting to say Juno
because I collabed with her yesterday no Juno uh is not on me okay I do have my ultimate so we
do have a counter sorry mercy this is the way it has to be it's the way it has to be darlin
why am I not getting any headshot oh my ping's actually 180 this is the lowest I think I've seen it
wait until I get an old server games oh I was too late I was too late I heard the raise I was
I'm waiting for someone to all so I can all in my counter all I need a counter all
okay no
you what are you you rock eating more rap
fucking thing that crawls around in the ground are you serious you brought my all I wasted it
bro
well I'm glad that's over there I know you're I'm sorry Lucio
oh my god she's gonna get fucking hell she has some aoe on that
like that aoe is real you know what get off the map yeah focus focus your mom or whatever
wait get off the map I'm I died for that but get off the map okay kindly get off the
map nice try and try and resurrect it get off that map no the servers melded together
all the servers are the same now it's like the same server that you can't pick
like if you wanted to be on one or the other the longer you see the longer rim cycle than
that's probably important for you as a creative well I just and so I nap after stream now like
I'll take a moment to myself just to like chill out and uh let's get love let's get love
yeah you're not doing it this time bitch I'm on the walls I'm creeping around on the walls
what are you gonna do about it oh would you want off the map again okay close enough please don't
hit me I'm getting chased down they're getting off the stairs
ah I'm going for the mercy okay mercy's down Juno is afk for nope nope she's back oh
cock and ball torture bro we had it it was so close god vent oh okay oh she kind of has like a
swordjorn you know
uh we're so close we're so close are we going for it the refunds are already going in
oh okay we got one oh my god that oh I'm hiding behind this sauce I'm out of the window then you
look at me oh I'm stuck help step tracer I'm stuck oh I was literally in her face
my mouth was wide open and I'm trying to get Simmons I don't know
I'm just gonna oh do you remember that guy is it Ricardo oh my god I'm getting I'm getting
zoned off oh please I have ultimate soon don't do it I know you tempted I know what you are come on
I'm throwing I could be wall raiding but instead I'm throwing on the floor
what is that she does for for the lower thrust okay I I comprehend how damaging that is
I can comprehend I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming please
right I'm on the walls oh my gosh I can't keep up this I'm so sorry beeflin I can't keep you up I
don't have enough heels I don't know it just feels like my heels aren't healing anymore
oh sugar oh I don't know I need to look up the patch nose oh I'm lucky I'm lucky I'm lucky I'm lucky
I feel like I'm never healing did I do any heels I did 6k but I felt so useless Ricardo
Melos I that happened to me today on Reinhardt I lost my shatter with you
broken
nationwide questioning tradition oh my god thank you again momo hope you're passed out in
fucking three hours until you go get up like I'm very lucky that I can just be like even though
I get fewer sleep before stream it's not work um that's all I'm saying oh I should have knocked
them off the mat um like it's just no work and oh that oh I can't stay alive I think I'm being a
bot I think I'm just being a bot that sits on the floor or something yeah um um I'm just being a
bot it's me I'm the problem oh my god I can't believe it the first woman in history to take
accountability uh whoa hold on a minute now is that because I'm playing a multi player game
I'm coming out with stuff like that you can't be seeing that shit that was a joke okay that was a
joke at my own expense okay at my own expense I am a woman uh my fellow americans that was a joke
about you she only plays games for male attention I actually am like the only reason I'm playing
a roge right now we're gonna get booked off oh no we're not who or where I didn't even know she
could do that well I'm not the tank but I'm happy to that heal myself anymore is that what the
no listen must heal himself there's no way get on the floor you wait back
what is getting me I had 200
is it Juno oh my god the lag saved my all I still have my all
I still have my all I love like I still have my all even though you clearly heard it yes some
it must be Juno I'm I'm I'm not making fuck piss
I right get that default honestly make a regret being born oh we're getting a
freaking stuffy all right all right all right all right all right oh get her off the point
I'm healing myself it just feels so slow
I hear him I'm getting nervous Brigitte is gonna boop him off the map I'm gonna boop him off the
far is gonna boop him off the map we're all booping them off the map we're booppers
hashtag any booppers we need okay right our divas back in our tank that's the most important
thing I kid you not right can I oh my god my boop is like 11 second cooldown
okay stop it you're so get that moira oh I killed my Brigitte
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay I'm focusing up I'm I'm healing I mean I'm not
them but obviously I'm staying on hills I'm not giving my teammates any agility
oh right diva seems to be doing a lot more damage than I I know get the diva yeah so we
don't waste up oh that's good and then
that that was me that wasted that all I'm gonna be honest chief I wasted that Lucio defense
just Brigitte right Brigitte is about to have her ult so we we do have we do have some defensive
capabilities but I have to admit I should not have ulted there no they're not they're too scared to
come to the edge what are you doing young lady come back to the ultimate I need everyone on
point everyone on point and use ults when you get them don't don't hesitate they're gonna try and
they're gonna do buck
okay tracer no recall
oh goodness me
oh goodness me they oh baby refince oh goodness me oh goodness me oh goodness me
oh goodness me oh goodness me
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
I don't I don't know I don't know I don't know and I missed everything that could
have bounced my fucking arse cheeks off I'm throwing I'm so sorry we flins I'm
so sorry it's just no happening I'm absolutely oh my god they're oh my
poor babies are getting fucking massacred I'm I'm so sorry I couldn't do I was
throwing team 005 I'm sorry more like 004 because I did not help as a team
like out oh she's got a piercing in her eyebrow so gg's nice try nice right you
didn't sassus for having a tough time you know good what is that okay
it's a new hero I don't know what her name is is it venture adventure time yes
it is venture time right I think we're like literally getting down to that
right Astro snow you've no had a shot mmm I think we're faster have I had you
my brains melt in a bit together faster right I think I had you are my
mixing you with someone else I had a phone in I failed mommy no you didn't
no not yet okay I was on that shout out to the roof I'm very hard to carry
please don't please don't think it's your fault if we don't win I am very hard
to carry I'm looking at my list my eyes are darting over the screen
supremacy call right over zero you're my last game thank you
who's supremacy you're not a refund all right I don't know you are have you been
in before how did you even get after you sneaking and bitch we 200 case you
hard to carry in his supremacy I'm so sorry there is a lot of names now like
scribbled down and obviously cuz I don't write very neatly it's very hard to tell
I don't think you've played I'm gonna say you've not I really hope you're
honoring the reason I don't think you have right and then Scotland I seem to
think you're next Scotland invite you in or did I have a shot of you did I
read your tentacle yet no you've accepted and I trust my reasoning is not
take advantage of my mistakes
together we will be team patient because it's been quite a while I think
next no I didn't expect so and oh my god that tea person's been waiting for ages
as well oh my god I'm so sorry tilled I'm like in cyclone oh my god you've been
waiting forever I promise you're getting a next tilled in cyclone don't I'm
writing your names down right now hold on tilled in cyclone so I don't forget
yeah I'm starting to get vocal fry my breath my breath is getting tired my
voice walks is getting tired I think you're the only I'm gonna check my
friends list again I'm just gonna write thing thing thing you've been you were
ready to start yeah you are your team where you've been number two hidden
squid you're now in a competitive game I can't pull you out
look Lord you were in Tiananmen I had you because I remember your name and I was
like your name sprunk over I did get you submissive you're in the ace team yeah
cyclone and tilled tilt it does tell to the tilt maybe yeah you definite cyclone
tilts you're coming in coming in I have so many people to remove right I guess
after the next one I must start pitching you together if he's wanting to fight so
I'll play this one I'll go for a quick pee cuz I've got a lot of liquid in me
right now and then cyclone tilt and then it goes back to any reflin and you did
have me mummy and piano man that's my impression of a piano you're welcome
treat around with strongy like dinner everybody gets a meal before you get
second oh that's a really nice way to put it I think that's an incredibly fair
way to be fair where we're going to be show fair range of couch range of couch
and oh hey strongy hi reflin I never admit that overwatch is kind of fun but
only playing with you I've still got brain damage from playing at those you
need give me some aftercare did you lose some brain cells yeah oh my god rum
it's been just been a regular sked about yeah right I've not been a heel
slag for a reflin yet have a right I'm gonna be a heel slag this round for a
reflin because I've not played mercy heel slag because I did it for sin but I'm
not done it for sorry I forgot to un-add ain't you the one that's supposed to be
asleep right now go to sleep go to sleep if you need to rest reflins please
don't stay up you're about to do a twill and all day or right what we looking at
for the roster we've got Anna oh my god I wish Anna said good dog yeah I'd be
fucking feral for that voiceline well I'd rather a reflin said it you know what
I'm saying but reflins are shy like come on say I'm a good pup right now see
they're all too shy none of them are gonna do it navels straight back if you
didn't literally all they can do is emote see set proof proof is in the
pudding oh why do you always treat reflin so submissive they get put on the
spot okay they're they get so scared the balls will straight back up into their
fucking stomachs I love them for it though all right let's rock oh shit
mild balls detected oh shit oh my god they're actually going for me in the
air oh get out of here enemy tracer you're so mean we're getting backlined
by a British girl I knew there was a problem with it English honestly actually
that's the real reason why there's not an English girl injured oh I'm dead I'm
dead I'm down oh my god I couldn't have played that any worse I could not have
played that any worse I could not have played that any more right maybe I
shouldn't be on mersey maybe I should be on listen to your mommy oh that's such
a voiceline for me reef lines listen to your mom over there
and I boosted up my PC I can't outheal that oh my god he wants me not to raise
them but what ah ha ha you love that fucking I saw him he was like no you're
no resurrecting that reef line and I was like em actually factually get your
back right like I literally said I'm rewriting history hmm did you see my
little fake fly as well did you see him ram into me I did my little fake like
I'm going forward and I'm gonna fly into you but then I didn't 100 IQ that's
right praise me say I'm smart say I'm a smart girl that figures out oh fuck
girl the lead is ours who's got their all okay Genji's about to have his all
hmm okay we've got a minefield down okay we're healing to make sure no one gets
caught in that I think we're okay a roadhog did get caught in a trap Anna is
pushing which is really good news for me unless that I'm not picking up oh that
roadhog really wants your birthday right I'm just gonna heal up I'm gonna make
sure we win this next push okay I think we're okay I'm gonna keep pushing out so
we've won that fight now tracer let's try something else careful Anna you're on
your own careful careful careful right we've got a Genji all we've got nano
Genji nano Genji shortly when they come in Genji if you dash in the air that'll
be the sign for annative nano yeah no no pressure you are such a smart dreamer
and such a dumb puffy girl strong a smart room with such a dump oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah I'm healing I'm healing okay missiles with that shit junk
crack you come closer to the table if you group together for me I don't know
how you are alive right now put the trap down oh I do prefer being in the air
oh we're almost done it oh no no no no not like this not like this not like
this not like this they're coming out back up back up they're coming out I
don't I don't oh my god Anna oh that was oh that was just oh that was just
okay that was all ultimate retaliation that's what that was okay no no no it's
okay we got it we got it we got it we got it it's in the bag it's in the back
I'm sprained I'm praying I'm getting that ultimate for the next fight cry key cry key I'm English
restart recall okay we're healing we're healing we're healing we're all
things we're all things I'm not losing this fight I'm not losing this fight I'm
not losing a roofland yeah I can maybe he took me out of that animation but I'm
still up I don't know I don't know I'm trying okay okay get the mercy next make
the make the tracer yep aha okay bring it back bring it back now y'all crisscross
everybody use your all okay break the shield we've got a wind in now we've got
wind in okay tracer's gonna see me she's gonna see how juicy I was looking what
tracer and a Winston rather diving that quite the diving oh I'm gonna stay I'm
gonna stay but I can't go with the tank at this moment in time because of this
tracer she's gonna tracer might try and dash over to me to get the kill on me
it's very plausible yeah she's really I'm in a rather difficult position I need
to get out of this position that's what she said I'm needing I'm needing to be
with a reefland I can yeah yeah not she's coming I need to fucking be
preemptive oh that's so unfortunate I'm sorry I'm sorry that was my
positioning that was my positioning oh what happens is I kept dragging the
tracer with me in the Winston at one point was also trying to get on me I
kept dragging them like so when my teammate scatter when the reefland
scatter it actually helps out immensely because yeah because it means I
can I can ping about the map I can jump yop yop yop yop but the problem is I
just can't eat whoopsie who is that who is that not I know you're gonna be putting
up unique situation I mean we just need to win a fight and not push it any
further and we'll win do you know what I mean oh my god I just floated over that
bomb maybe if we can kill them wait wait don't push the robot any further don't
push it any further if you can avoid it yeah yeah she's right she's right don't
push just leave it although there is gonna be another fight after this I'm
gonna try not touch the box I can hear him stop it he so he does have a good
alien okay lovely that was perfect from Anna absolutely perfect oh no I have
reds I have reds it's okay oh unless Anna gets me okay don't okay oh my god
oh we're fucking wild with this energy it's so good we're on strike whoa I don't
have words I don't have words I don't have words I don't have words you don't
understand I don't have words it's just so good I thought you were Scottish call us
the earlings carry cuz we bodied them wait what did you take wait come back
what did you take what did you take what did you take call us the the fuck
I'm up a wings oh the fucking carry links okay sorry sorry I thought it's
carry links I saw innings and I was like I must be okay that was well done right I
summon tids and the thing my bobber syndrome no not syndrome that's the
enemy from that hit movie thingy you and you and I'm literally grabbing you like
the mat the mat the rat meme I'm just gonna check right cycle on your end good
oh my god that's Dallas team oh my god the refund talks he has balls I give him
that I'm just gonna check the list I know I saw that new friend request I'm
just checking the list I'm joking at worst I'm trying to see which refund has
been naughty or nice I think everyone has had a chance right I'm gonna do where
was where did you go redacted okay you're only where's the the other one it wasn't
robot it was the other one that had this profile picture but he never got a chance
to get in I don't know he really said I don't want to join and I'm like right how
many numbers one two three four five so there's 15 on each page 15 plus 15 plus
three no 15 not 150 it's 33 okay pick a random number between 30 1 and 33 number
nine come on down one two three four five six seven eight nine well you're not
just in the game you lucky shit you lucky shit right after this we're gonna go
against each other you're gonna have to either you're gonna be trash talked by
mommy or mommy's gonna be screaming in your ear are you giving a refill in a
shot I don't know
mommy at the top left you can see your friends that are playing over watch I
know you again oh your time's up okay generated another random number 20 15
that would be 30 9 8 20 yeah that's how it works okay tiger say you're coming
and then after this we're fucking annihilating each other I'm pitying
us against each other right I don't want to be I've not locked in your hero
either I'm a do healer or tank a healer or DPS the win win number nine
download complete please crush me moment have a good night woman thank you
for letting us lay over watch oh no thank you for playing with me bro I was
so nervous when I said it cuz I was getting memed on and I genuinely thought
and I genuinely thought it two hours until an Emmy stream always any I thought
Amy wasn't am I going mental well if Amy is gonna I thought Amy wasn't
screaming today she's not is it a member stream is that what it is no are you
trolling me thank you for the revised did I heal you in game I was gonna say I
thought I was the only one that had a story to do but yeah I was worried
cuz when I said I wanted to play overwatch because then you're always
like oh no I'm gonna show up and play I've been proven wrong but I got plopped
with love pop pop pop pop pop I've been plopped so hard
that's right overwatch is fun you better the minute you better confess that you
judged the game too harshly games I think that's probably one of the major
factors if you find yourself tired of multiplayer games in particular I think
it is now you're not to blame or anything for this factor but if you have
someone you can connect with on that game that makes the world of difference
for the multiplayer experience like I was fucking screaming and I mean I think
I'm still partly screaming through my games I just I'm so excited I'm so much
fun playing with you like it makes the world of difference to play the game
that's multiplayer experience you know when we lose the game I'm not like oh my
effing god I'm raging I don't want to play anymore I want to you know uninstall
that no I'm like oh my god we were so close we did so well like we tried so
hard like you know and like I think I hope I hope I am able to give you the
seed of a you know love when we play together type thing maybe maybe it's
wishful thinking thank you cartoffel of them for the chip as well you're such a
smart streamer and such a dump right hey strongy sense none of the
things would say it I will you know what when we when we beat each other up in
game when we beat each other up in the next round if I fall lose wait no that
would be a reward wait what's the punishment for me if I lose oh no I have
to stream another hour oh no my life is oh yeah hi dream hold on I miss I missed
again I hit I miss again okay I have 200 ping give me give me some
okay now there's I'm a try but there's no way anyone's getting a headshot like I
refuse to believe I'm gonna headshot one person with us look not that I'm aiming
that well either but you know oh don't mind me just one for their healer my
fellow Americans okay I was trying to go for the healer but I didn't do it I need
swap I think I'm away are you going for it you can he be oh fucking pylon right
no I'm sure I need swap I need swap let's go give me here let me I'm here I need
swap I need you can't play widowmaker I'm blaming the ping I don't care I don't
care if it makes me bad no actually it doesn't make me a bad gamer if I blame
the ping it makes me a real gamer who should I play like all I'm saying is
Torbjorn smart accurate hey this is how I see the world okay I literally can't
you see bump over the bumpers of hummers you know there's like American cars are
ridiculously big yeah we're gonna put a weed turret there so they are gonna have
to do so they are gonna have to get wallets of it by my turret if they come
a little I think come out I'm coming lowish hold on wait it's there I'm
supposed to play good ooh save by Lucille corgi captain thank you for
becoming a member bean oh bro excuse me I'm trying to talk to the reason Sombra
then if you do why am I getting hurt something's hurting me but I'm not being
directly damaged it's crazy how long you've been streaming you really need
I I will rest when oh but when I have a hook it's two inches long no that oh oh
drunkrat was right there oh I'm no being funny but make a quick wargola
either take my eat well or if you're dutch a smack like the moon and then then
you go thank you well so the way I do Torbjorn on push maps is I constantly
update my turret like behind the payload so when we enter the next fight it's
gonna be in the vicinity of like what we need to shoot at in general and it you
know also gets covered up a little bit which is really he destroyed my churrell
raise my turret right now how is that getting there oh my god can you get
out of there Reinhardt can you come to me come to me Reinhardt oh my god yeah I
need to get my other okay that's good I'll take that I'll take that right
just let the turret give them a little I do have ink I do have ink I'm gonna move
in with my ink I may have been a bit overconfident over confidence is a
flimsy she it is actually I'm just putting my okay I need her gone and I
need that gone any junkrat gone someone's getting walloped by my turret
it's Sombra she's getting in trouble by it heals on Reinhardt I don't think we
have a healer I don't I can't get him I can't get him I'm weak bruv bruv my
turret's gonna have to get him I'm not even kidding I hear footsteps I don't
like it he's still there oh my god that Reinhardt just slammed his death you violent
boy oh oh oh Reinhardt behind by a he'll a target okay I'm backing up I'm backing up
almost oh I don't know where it is I'm spraying I'm spraying I'm spraying oh my
god he's coming for me oh my god oh right okay get right right focus up we're
doing it right as I said we're just gonna I'll have my ink soon ish I'm gonna
ink we'll move up with the ink and then we'll get rid of that freaking Alari
heal beam if you're happy and you know we'll clap your hands okay I need to stop
throwing I'm throwing again I'm I am you know what the common denomination is
every time I see defeat across the screen it's me I said what I said it's me
and the problem and I accept that and I understand right get rid of the healing
beam that can go up my arse oh no our tank just went down as well I'm not
sure I can get us in there I cannot I'm doing pathetic I'm getting damaged but
I'm no getting like the kills I'm not getting the finalization on the tail
but that's cuz I'm not like aiming I'm just playing Torb is well the way you
can play Torb
this is the best I can do all things considered I don't know maybe he should
go with the turret we got one I'm getting a few hits on the turret as well that
somber has been rather we the somber is around the somber is around I'm
getting nervous I don't know where she is she's she's hacked my somber was on the
roof to eat it oh she's got me oh yeah oh yeah they be lamp post right we're
gonna put a turret back here on purpose so it's like annoying to deal with it
like the it gets hidden by the load oh unless they do that oh okay I'm spraying
so you're saying there's a chance I don't know all my teammates the views than
all though the view if I could get that junk around make them pay um um no we
can do it we can do it I believe in us I have ink in a minute we need to read
group I have ink in a minute I have ink I have ink so badly I'm making
everywhere yeah waiting to regroup we can do it with the through the power
over one brain cell I'm coming I'm inking I'm inking I've inked everywhere
get rid of that get rid of that my turret is down is it even there no it's not
my turret isn't there did I not put it down oh I've thrown I've thrown I'm so
sorry I've freaking thrown GG my problem right okay now it's time now it's
time for us to fight each other now it's time to annihilate each other on say I
never named us strong are you actually good it was the turret I'll take the
credit thank you like I got 11,000 because of the turret feels good not see
that's why torments the best especially when you got like really bad pink right
now to beat each other up right how do I make us fight each other I need to make
us fight if you're throwing I'd rather you throw it back
hey how do I custom game one dad versus 11 kids what what the fuck is this based
on mystery death mark army 11 players huh tinder match reborn what the fuck is
tinder match based on all tinder match a lover watch you can change what is this
all join are you guys wait can we join the same thing what is this create in the
top right corner right what we're gonna do one dad versus 11 kids I'll be the
daddy for one right let me be the daddy and then how did I get you in friends
only right how am I am I'm marking down the custom games when we do this wait I
think there was a refund that sent a friend request hold on wait wait wait
before I launch social yeah infiltrator and you guys to come in
can I you in wait what was it infiltrator and you're not even in game no
you must be wait why is it like this I don't know who's online I can't guess
who's online are you serious I think you guys are gonna have to just bomb it yeah
I think you guys are whoa you have level 5 endorsement you must talk in game I can't
join your group and you have to go like any team sorry I've never done this I'm
sorry it's my first time because what the fuck am I doing what am I doing sorry I
don't I think you just have to come in I think we'll just do honor system can you
like come over can I like to rag you over no I can't I can see that you guys
are here but there's two open slots to go on the enemy team what did you call
I don't know why you can infiltrator needs in because he's not had a chance and
really the chance that he's got time and how do I get you I'm invited group and
that does that put you in here it doesn't how do I put you in there I'm like
why is it not a drag and drop system swap to the red team wait if I invite
infiltrator to the red team wait hold on wait infiltrator I need to I think I
need to remove you from my group and then okay that did not work infiltrator
you're getting shagged and through you're getting shag nice right infiltrate
it and fit a little traitor and was there one it's filming so then what
happens is that is that all I had to do I mean I'm just gonna start it and we'll
see what happens cuz I'm not I'm not is this like an actual match or if I fuck
this up oh I can play Juno not enough players I assure you there's enough
players wait is no one loading in no they are right I'm gonna play Juno
cuz I never got a chance to play her nice t-shirt by the way yeah you like it
that's real I'm actually wearing it right now I promise I'm wearing clothes
well this room oh shebe's live with her is more clever if you want to see it yeah
shebe's live right now with a cool I'm like 90% sure shebe's live right now
whoa okay what do you do
cancel he makes me faster he seems to be some sort of grab wait I'm pretty sure
is it not f1 watch that I bet you I'm gonna get teabagged in the kill cams
cuz reeflands are gonna want a cheeky shag I bet yeah yous are gonna be I'm
getting teabagged absolutely out the wazoo they're all gonna be jumping me okay
right hold on that was not what I wanted to do oh my god they're so aggressive
oh my god reefland stop it you're making me nervous I'm sorry I'm going wait
why did that cancel come back I didn't mean it I'm sorry oh my god I'm flying
oh I can't fly forever okay the reeflands like absolutely massacre in
each other me how to fly okay shift up right second just hang out and then I
click it once and then a fire and if no one's there no one's gonna get hit oh okay
I'm gonna get rid of the bastion thingy my barber so then how do I heal I don't
I'm not even healing I'm just being a vdps right now sorry actual um Danny shoot
you I want to be teabagged what you may kill yous and teabag you I don't I'm
flying I'm aiming I'm shooting how much damage it doesn't seem to oh my god oh okay
it's over it's over hmm I'm not sure how I feel about you know I'm gonna see
what at least see where all of it is oh yeah yeah you get me in there I'm down
I'm down right okay I'm gonna get to her ultimate and then I'll find out I'll find
out how it works and then I guess we'll play venture because I've not played her
and I've not played my
Morg Morg
over reasons are how is it my pain is so low when I'm the one who's hosting the
lobby I'm healing question mark I like how it gets stuck into her
munitions whoa whoa I'm down I need to float I need to float oh my god I need
to float down oh I'm just what do you mean when I play a hero for the first
time I don't instantly comprehend their assets and their abilities and their
playability I'm flying I must don't think like that my fellow Americans I'm so
nervous playing this game be careful you know you might kind of sounds like
Mickey Mouse hit f1 so I'm gonna let you all fight in the background we'll
orbital ray call down a ray that travels forward healing allies increasing
their damage oh it goes for haha I'm jumping not again not again okay my
healing is my show and jeez that's very strange
or but say fucking go okay all I'm saying is you're lucky
reflands on the enemy team that I'm playing a character I've never played
before oh she got me shoes I like the shape I like the show oh god no you're
targeting me roots right that's it that's it that's it what the fuck are you
I mean I've played what are you spend every moment growing into who you truly are oh
my god wow what is this
can I like a don't mind me guys there you go hell power what does that do I can
grab people and stuff am I helping I don't know if I'm healing I don't think
I'm helping I'm just gonna pretend I'm off you go I I think I'm I think I'm
doing it I think it's working I'm a flower flower power shapes and colors what
did you expect mommy not to be mowed down for the reeflings to let me learn a
new character with dignity okay but kind of deserved because you hurt me and
killed me in that last time I spawned in who would be a good player to spectate
to learn not me anyway it seems like the refunds on within I just like the
pretty flower in my hand okay it's gorgeous is stunning apparently I have
to reload the flower I've got eleven out of sixteen units of ammo oh that's how
I feel I hear again why is the number going up oh it's past oh I see it's
ogre it's ogre it's ogre oh right now get me off like get me on someone I can
they're getting sucked today I'm sorry I'm not make put me wait hold on can I
speak to the refunds of my team put me in chief or anyone I'm in voice chat I
need to apologize to them I need to apologize personally for fucking
fucking up this team I'm on my run and we're sucking them up fucking souls out
of them we winning we winning the dubs start here the dubs start here okay it's
over it's over I know how to piss I assure you I know how to pass and I
know how to position these balls give them a little little pinch and roll
giving a little pinch and roll so we're gonna bounce that ball against the wall
I may be a detriment to the team I may be a detriment that's all I'm saying okay
that was a warm-up now I'm gonna ask for the honor system if you had a chance to
get in do not come I'm sorry I was such a detriment a life grab oh my god I
life grabbed you in the middle of your all I am so sorry I could not have been
any more of a nuisance do not come wait it's just gonna keep no no no don't keep
putting me in right leave game but I can't come with you I don't know if the
game just ends because I've left right let me right social I'm a for the people
who haven't played a regular schmagular game with me I don't know how do we do
that again completely fun right hold on play custom create we're not doing I
can vote sure we'll play bullies adware how the fuck did you snake no way hold
on hold on to people infiltrator and really have to get in right reason
infiltrator has to get in infiltrator needs to be in because that he's not
had a chance to play okay there you go everyone else go now if you've played
the last game I am begging you please for the honor system I cannot track
everyone who comes into the custom game if you played last time please and please
go out because we're gonna keep playing custom for a little bit longer okay I
can't do invite only because there's no way I can track custom games I just don't
infiltrator and rule haven't had a chance to play with me and there's someone
who's on my team want to let routine and then they can go in the enemy team I need
to be on if I go in rose team infiltrator can come over with me right
click join group I see it I see where join group is
join group I need to be on infiltrator and rules team
why else we've not played together move me oh oh my god oh my god right so who
didn't play I assume those suspect he didn't play is this correct is everyone
not played last round I really need to pee can I go pee really quickly I played
so move me how do I write so what move you into a spectator
mother mental move you to here like this so everyone here hasn't played a custom
with me I hope right I'm gonna very quickly go for a pee and console players
can't join they have to be invited special if you're the makes a high at least
one-time game but my mic was made oh yeah the curse yeah right I'm gonna very
quickly go for a tinkle in the toilets right there I'm gonna get another amount
of tea war and cola you can't make this up I have literally nail liquids to my
name Mary I'll be right back
you
okay I think we're ready you I'm not kidding once a zero does appeal or
allegation audio I think I need to like make sure I drink two cups of tea a
bottle of water and a cola that went on forever not to be dramatic but I just
passed anonymous thank you for the tip unironically to hit f1 I knew there was a
freaking code you don't have to pay me money to tell me what to do in game okay
you can you can do it without giving me money you don't have to give money and
anonymous for that want to be teabag by you I will drag my gorgeous Mahina
against your face any day so I know you can just hit go to lobby when the match
in okay right time for please add west sorry this I swear my microphone is gonna
come off flying and it's gonna be so loud right who's the other one I've no
played why is this history let's make history right I'm venture
what is endorsement level it's when wait no there's not a match check could you
imagine us all shit talking each other mortified there's not a match chat no is
that a certain please I would love to fucking I would love to do callouts live
whilst we're all talking over each other no that's so frustrating there must be a
certain let's make history oh there is a man wait I can put it on oh you'll need
to tell me tell me how to put it on please please please refund please tell me
please I'm begging I know this is nothing to do with me but I decide what to
eat should I eat pizza or fried chicken fried chicken it's the best husky we
can do a match chat so we can shit talk the enemy reefland but we can't do it
in this one because I need to set it up but we could fuckable we're going to be
at no one's allowed to say the gamer word and all that jazz you know the rules
gotcha ten four okay they're they're behaving right what are you if one no
sorry that's not it one explore resolve drill dash dash forward or borrow okay
borrow looks like a left oh Danny you snipe me don't think I won't go and
widow maker and snipe you back I don't care if I have why can't I hit why is
nothing hidden I don't have a hit why are they picking on me oh no I just drilled
forward didn't want to do that this widow maker getting me I'm leveling up that
Zario is June is Juno's we shield thing a shield drop me oh my god that
refunds literally going for my wake I'm sorry do you just like my hair that much
I know it looks like a warm-up why is nothing hitting stop drilling forward
sorry I seem to think she's gonna have like some long
I'm fucking creeping around I'm I can smell you I'm creeping around
I'm coming to sniff your toe I can smell your pheromones refund I'm getting
sensory overload from both stream and game I'm so far away you don't do
anything that far away I something tells me Ventress play style isn't for me I'm
gonna pop off on Torbjorn I hear you widow maker now I'm creeping around now
I'm coming for you refund sorry you thought no don't hate no go away I'm
not that good at the game to do that right I'm not hitting anything so is she
a short distance character just put me at my misery put me at my misery I'm not
playing this character right ash sin picked ash so sin picked ash right okay
I'm ash I have a golden gun oh it must be your default I was gonna say I was like
how can I have a golden one no I'm going this way then fine where are you I saw
I can smell you oh wet saucepan right I'm getting an aisle I think I'm gonna
have to go Torbjorn I'm so sorry I'm doing it I have to do it you know I had
to do it to him I had to pull it the Bjorn I'm getting Molly walk oh my god
I'm getting jumped they jump in me not right okay hold on a minute hold on a
minute right everyone let's regroup let us commence force by becoming one as a
team take a big breath in and exhale all your brain cells so we commune via the
one brain cell we share amen you know what bastion you know what we don't make
her I can see you actually sniffing my way sorry I know you just love my helmet
I'm sorry to break it to you but no see that we don't know no I think I got that
reef and killed him I don't like right I'm doing better I'm not peeking that
sorry I'm not peeking although there is that really funny me well actually it's
a bit insensitive but isn't that the point of memes sometimes it's like that
it's like call me JFK because I'm peeking that sniper or something like that
is pretty outrageous I'm only allowed to joke about it because I played fuck you
I'm making everywhere ah why are you so good that's that I'm opening up my
can of mini-sprite fuck you my bird I'm like I'm trolling so hard you know what
it is my turret as well will fire at Zarya willy-nilly and like completely
level her up
bro I literally can you see you you're on your stick I literally cannot see you
brah I need to put my glasses on just to kill this replaying bro I got her but
oh my god that was like oh look for the needle in the haystack motherfucker you're
skinny how am I supposed to snipe you mommy raise should you get a little
accolade if you get me to say something if I rage in the game
you know special actually would be stream sniping my expect and we don't make
her to start coming from there you know I can fake it's just muffled in the
background can I have my ink right now please please
I don't know it's the time to do it cuz I'm good oh I am causing us to die
who does mommy hate so stickling no I'm a fidget I show you I'm gonna make
your beef cake links you're gonna be mad my nice chunky boy and then you're
gonna have to lie down in your big belly actually maybe hold on a minute I
remember I used to put my turret right oh Denny you worry lads I'm the I'm the
tank see this I hate French people
I can't win I can't win I actually can't win a fucking
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'll literally such an anchor this is
in fact oh wait what you got play oh how oh when the fucking ozampic moment
happens bro damn straight what did I even do nothing the turret must have done
all the work I wasn't even looking so as I literally look the other way her
screams feed back in through the mic right so what I do I go not leave game
show lobby did it just cycle you wait but how do I know who played by no what
did it just cycle you is it cycling you oh does it know how to say click we press
back to lobby where show lobby invite move it did cycle no it's not say fun
back to lobby we start match back to lobby oh it's right there okay right and
then can whoever right so then so did I just need to like one by one who's a you
you you you you you you you you then you you I'll I'll tell you what don't wait if
you played recently because I can't tell so like back out if that makes sense so
and all and then you can just come back in next time does that look correct you
can make it a 66 soon or more my fellow American lobby team bouncing off team one
please there can be ten of us on each team how much 12 right how do I put voice
comes on match voice chat oh my god I'm chatting so much shit whenever someone
kills me I'm not even kidding oh you must fix or discard your changes no is it
because it's not free for all it must be this right I let that wait it'll lose
66 you can't have to be okay 66 tonight okay we're doing better at least right
someone's missing from the other team two moons done right okay and then we can
all chat shit as well chat shit game mind how about not that game oh you know
we'll just play it fuck it we'll just play it I'll survive and does that seem
right did anyone play like recently that hasn't okay there's only about eight
refills but there's two spectators as well right I think I'm gonna play this one
and then do another one then everyone would have had a chance to double kind
of treatment I think that's even is everyone you can add match to it did I
not do it present no not present sorry lobby enabled match voice chat can is it
on right now no it can't be on space oh well something happened those
wait what switch me with cyclone wait did cycle and consent to that who is
Ched gay and cycle and okay move and cycle okay done is there anyone speak up
or forever hold your piece is it anyone else they switch no I think okay I think
this one's okay as I said we'll work on the honor system when it comes to custom
games I can't be spamming everyone's name done it would take me like five
minutes to set up you must realize mama that this game is a way for the
reflings to take out their frustration on you take responsibility and let them
in con you you're gonna ink on me in game some of the TV again is right I
promise to my team I will not be a detriment okay okay let's see if the
match chat work I want to start chance it hold on hydration check right if I'm
not a detriment to my team I'm gonna be the little heel slag I'm supposed to be
I was destined to be a heel slag I said what's it right how do I get into the
social it oh my god it works but no one's here one two they're coming oh right
wait I'm gonna wait until everyone comes in and I'm gonna start chatting shit
about the enemy team right press escape social and then click the red match chat
and then we can all hear each other oh yeah oh my god it's gonna oh my god we
can touch it you're 800 paying there's an enemy team you're going down your
fucking shit you're fucking awful your trash you speaking of trash you may as
well be a dumpster baby that's where you belong whoa actually that was really
that was a bit too far there's only two enemy oh there's a third enemy I'm me
waiting on sorry I look at this you have to enable you have to enable what enable
what enable it two tanks per team otherwise one person can't select a
role you the role select wait so who has this wall oh yeah we're gonna have to
redo the game wait there's just someone who can't play yeah hold on let me be
doing a game to download completely is it okay for me to still add you even if
you're done live streaming or even add you in general I only ask cause oh no no
I'll play overwatch again back to lobby right let's try that again no I'll play
this again and I don't add people offline because of these I make account
specifically for stream sniping and and all that jazz and you can add me when I
do stream snipe stuff but I don't play offline on these accounts like these aren't
my what I need to do modes no presence 6v6 sure who is that surely they have a
default 66
am I are we really forced to play 5v5 no it's kind of the truth I don't believe
it I think it has to be I think it has to be motherfucking 5v5 because none of the
lobbies are gonna accept it are you serious I don't know who got kicked out
though I'm so sorry that's so frustrating I'm so sorry to the two
refunds I got booted out that's so frustrating can you remove a rose lock
how do I do that lobby
team balancing off I assume that means swap teams are for my mental
max spectators to do I mean if you want more or show although it might start
confusing me a lot of players who are in queue no use experimental update match
enabled pause game on player disconnect data reset on minimum weight wait I can
artificially sabotage you guys wait what no that's not what that means
game modes no limits it's not even there the most all have limits if you use
this game wouldn't you can play 66 wait what is that random what I do with that
code hold on I'm gonna disband refunds don't panic don't panic create and then
what a lobby code add AI no how do I use a code
recent audience favorite filter search browse auto-join it must be great go
sentence must be and then workshop codes
create setting modes oh and what now
oh my god
import code on the right oh oh oh what did it do did it do scour me 66 okay and
now what right uh-huh right and then I need to enable match tax that's most
important thing because I need to be able to chat shit get match chat on and not
save I want to go against mommy what you don't want to fucking help me win fine
get the fuck out right right as I said please do the honor system I'm gonna
cry if you don't I'll I'm literally gonna throw up because I can't keep track of
custom there's one women's to do even you waited a very long time I wasn't in
match before you can swap me out I wasn't in match before you can swap me
out you mean you what you were or you weren't I didn't get in what's your name
what you mean baby what's your style
well I need like you in put me in spectator an honorable reason I guess I've
been and then
hmm whose name I'm sorry I'm not tracking anyone's name okay right you
filled up that's good are we happy mommy turn on your match up by going to your
sentence social chat wait I can chat shit to use right now oh my god sorry I
need to write your names down what was that I'm gonna hold on I think we're
gonna flick like a actual game mode together because that's three new ones
that's not played with you on one-on-one in a match group oh my god can I chat
shit right now Cheshire get banged oh there's not any me I think they'll do
okay I think we've done it surely cookie I'm surely surely this is why I
seek this is why I desire I still can't join you'll need to tell me what you
know hmm you know what we're gonna hit them with a hmm what that's a lot of
words too bad I read them they're not gonna know oh wait hold on can I they're
gonna know what you know I am you suck enemy team
let's see if they've got any under the reef ones have any trash talking them
wait no one's ready the game's starting is no one able to load in is it my pain
be it isn't me am I the problem I have no idea if the enemy team is ready or not
enemy team are you ready I don't know there's something something oh my god
who's playing that Rissa you suck you're so bad oh look at that terrible
gameplay oh my god junk rap more like shit wrap oh my god please stop killing
my teammates tracer more like oh shit I'm done oh my god why can I win against
them brah I don't suck I
I'm that is this gonna turn into one of those streams where I can't go offline
until we get a W because I think it's about to I cannot win against the
reef ones right now brah yeah take that right no defense matrix that's fine
oh my god that's enough of you tracer I've had enough of that I've had enough
of that well the enemy junker quick junker queen coming behind that's right
junker queen I can see you you think I can't see you tiptoeing around the map
that's right that's me around the car no no fight me fight me junker queen
actually no didn't even a way you better be in voice chat that's right are
they in voice chat that's right if they weren't in voice chat that was really
embarrassing the whole point is to let me think of you it's not but it's not
funny if I believe that you don't hear it it's so mean okay I'm clearing up
yeah oh nice aim you suck oh yeah see that javelin of us so yeah that missed
my head it comes so skinny yeah defense matrix more like defense shape Danny
tell the refunds that I'm bush out hold on any any hill I didn't even know they
could still see my head I'm on a roll oh my god oh mercy you think you'd see you
you eat moth on wings I open a window and she would he go out so I need to tell
the refunds out again boys shucks it's so fun like mucking about with them right
who's miss it bro there's three refunds missing from the enemy team and two from
my team what's going on they actually hate me right press press pee then click
on the red match headset whoo the chat is disabled I hope it's claiming fucking
benefits what the fuck love you all wait oh my aim is fine no my aims actually
free tanks free tanks oh that's right I'm gonna I'm gonna come for your your
choices thanks you know you're losing she really wants to yell at them you need
to enable chat I have they're coming in I can see enemy and I can see friendly
what do you mean enable chat they're in here yeah see look the refunds are here
there you go I did it right I did it right I would just want to trash talk okay
we've got 15 seconds left I need to focus up whoo I'm not going to in that you
don't
bro there's too many of you there's actually too many of you whoo right if
they've got tanks they need to be junkrat I think I need to be no we've
already got a junkrat we don't have a tank of her own oh my god right I figured
out the problem I need to be Zarya and they have a nice tasty diva for me to get
all of my ultimate charge on I think they're tank tank tank tank tank yeah
did you enable tech shot okay take shot might be disabled but I'll fix it next
time right that's right feed the bubble mmm shoot the bubble mmm right stop stop
shooting the bubble enough oh
god 90 freaking charge already stop it stop it I hear I'm rain oh did you oh
shit it was an ASMR collab I mean I'm screaming over overwatch please turn
your volume down right now I'm getting stream sniped by the reeflings you're
more than welcome to join if you have overwatch and we're currently reeflings
are currently battling out and I'm trash talking them but I'm struggling to
win see that kid a cool kid a cool you're actually dead by a ball here I'm
just saying I was coming for you bro mmm thank you for the redirect Chibi you
hope you had fun with your ASMR collab was it fun did it work or was it like
there's an ASMR collab all right bro they pulled out the tank gun five seconds
straight didn't they I know I knew it yeah you're more than welcome to stream
snipe me I have my battle night tagged and pinned in the top of the chat I have
voice chat on so I can shit talk the reeflings you know what I think about
you I think you're a fake link I'm currently doing psychological warfare on
them a real reeflings would let me win
I can't even survive for a millisecond why are you like top 500 what happened to
casual gaming casual gaming's clearly dead in that you have to earn the win like
the best I can do is like junk rat hands all kind of mo kill yourself who said
who the fuck said that down the mic that was inappropriate we fling I don't know
who said that that was disgusting who said that's fucking wild I don't know
who said that that's a wild I'm not even sure I want to go against them again
the annihilated me how am I supposed to win fucking hell we're already going
for again I am a mercy aim ball are you winning in my white Valentino bag how am
I supposed to win not I'm fucking sticking with the reaper so as he seems
like he cans we've been oh no he's way alright he's reversed it okay maybe
it's just easier on attack copium
99 oh my god get that tracer no I see you tracer I'm coming for you you think I
didn't have my own pistol mm-hmm two moons more like my arson your face moons
thank you I'll be here all day I'm trash talking love I don't care get a mercy
get a mercy she's gonna read it oh you think you're the better mercy you're
just you're a fake mercy I'm the real person I'm so bad at trash talk
is it who momo's the only one that doesn't want to hear the trash talk excuse
me Eva excuse me I was cheeky I was cheeky I hear an enemy I don't know about
you but I hear an enemy oh my god I love hillbottom see this is the role I'm
supposed to take in life like I'm already got the github application open
right now this is clearly my role in life just being a good quiet we pocket
that's all I need to do just be a wee pocket mmm that's right get rolled get
smoked that's right you have no coordination because the reeflings in
the enemy team are too scared to even coordinate they're too scared to say oh
we should rip up tracer behind tracer on the pillow behind get her oh my god get
the junk of Queen oh right I'm all right no one's dying on my overwatch right
now oh my god tell him how you really feel Reinhardt tell him how you really
feel oh oh look at this MLG gameplay that's right I'm holding a beam to my
teammate oh oh you've never seen gameplay like this before top 500 there's
nothing been more riveting than watching a beam come from my staff okay they
can't handle it our heel slug because I'm so slow to understand things mommy is
like oh did I did I just beat you that's right take that take that loss take
that fucking loss yeah oh yeah you're gonna devol oh don't be so obvious I'm
getting I'm getting jumped I'm getting jumped I'm I knew that devol was coming
I knew that devol was coming you thought I didn't see it you thought I don't have
errors in this game I'm sorry you had to find out this way oh my god merci
upstairs merci stagger stagger that merci give her a good five seconds
before we kill her and then you can kill her oh that's right take that take that
mercy yeah that's right okay we're the real winners no don't fucking attack me
that's just no just cuz I'm not didn't chase me you got me actually I just
distracted the tracer through and we got the payload you're one HP bro bro you're
one HP open your mouth right now I'm a piss in it you were one and I bet you
yours bless it you said that you're having fun right it has to be best of
three right that's how skirmishes work we both have three points good job mommy
lots of head but why does Tracer get rewarded and what come surely surely we're
gonna win oh wait it's not finished I can't hear you oh right okay right back
in a lobby and show lobby back to lobby I'm gonna take the L and see we lost that
one right I need to enable the why can why why can we not take chat singing
because there might be a refill and that's too scared to shit talk to me but
right I need everyone to leave that was in the game I I'm like 99% sure I need
everyone that plays with me to leave and then I'll swap you out with the others
copium right social oh gosh sorry match what you need gamer tags you guys have I'm
renaming you all by the way and I'll let your shoes okay right bing boom bow once
everyone's had a shot with me in custom game I'll go back to regular game mode
cuz there's six players that haven't played an actual game with me right okay
and then damn no one want to be in squishy scene yeah they really said squishy we
take this person right how who's not played am I just assume how do I join
enemy team I have no idea do you wait you want to go against me fuck you then go
against me see how you see how see how you fear against the the greatest he'll
slag of all time okay how about the greatest he'll slag of Scotland that's
the best I got can you put me in spectator what's your gamer tag okay
Billy and Diddy at least certain if you played last game big big big for what
mercy oh oh sorry beg to join the enemy team I'm so sorry that makes a lot more
sense now that I've said it out loud who didn't play last game I don't know zero
are you with us amen I don't know I'm throwing you then right after gaming
kits any weren't in was anyone in that shouldn't be in right now that's what
she said that's what you said
scrawny and Reeveland versus sister in the imps what and me and sin have open
columns I don't even think you'd have your drums right more more you didn't
join voice chat whilst you were killing me so you're getting shat on women you
haven't had a shot I just I just I was just watching you get killed you know
what you didn't have to spectate you didn't even have to take that out but
you did it was such confidence I think cyclone so a silicone so I don't know
why I've got silicone on my mind right now right I think we're okay and then
we'll go back to playing regular games because there's quite a few
we've been a way to try the cheese and I fuck it let's go fuck it fuck it send it
hydration check refund hydration check I can't join to say I think it's max
there's like a max number oh we're going to Italy a whole whole Viva like Italy
I'm mean fuck you press R to change V to teleport press F and R to change
language for real oh okay I get oh no can't speak that
okay wait how to put it back to English English right and then in order to talk
to the refund there's only two enemy refunds I can shit talk but I'm a shit
anyway yeah you go whoa hello that's not me who did that is that me wait is that
me did we break hello did we break it is it you unpause match I don't know what
what I hate to make it do that I don't know what I hate to make it do that but
I'm did it no you want to feel the frost the skull and it's not really much
about others I'm gonna make you have balls shovel ups I'm gonna be so cold I'm actually on fire I'm
made from the hit video game overwatch and then tunes are banging thank you
Lucie oh oh oh you thought you could go Sombra oh and kill me sorry about the
refunds love me and they're protecting me and we're gonna kiss oh careful oh I
might just have ultimate enemy team refunds careful I might just ace all
over you oh shit I don't know yeah yeah do that come back I'm gonna ace all over
you no I'm not I'm gonna get frickin hacked where did she go where did she go
other shoes I can't really do I can't do that Lucie no take that fuck you no wait I
don't freeze people anymore hello hello I don't freeze people anymore they had
enough of that ability them other muscle turn out just my alt freeze mom there's a
sombra there's a sombra oh my god I'm trying to snake that frickin soldier he's
one potato did you how did Reinhardt perish himself did where I said Reinhardt
hurt himself to death it's a me you only slow them down the alt still freezes
I can smell you that refund thought I couldn't smell them pheromones that three
day old dank nice try replay nice try nice oh piss back okay I was a wee bit
just a wee bit that was a wee bit karma but come on I predicted the refund I
predicted so hard you make what you want to kill me more in game you think you're
no you don't you love me you want me to win you don't want the hate to flow
through me oh yo I'm okay thank god oh let me use all sorry oh right well let
them we'll let them have a chance okay but we're gonna play put we're gonna go
back to public matches after that because there's a few reeflings that want to play
or here on members that might want to play I don't that I didn't get a chance to
play like a game game and attack right mm-hmm attack what what have I not played
like sure I'll play attack together and you prove I'm a dog Brack correction is
needed again they don't know wait I'm gonna do more psychological warfare you
might as well just forfeit cuz you know we're gonna win three films they they
already know I'm coming for you it's psychological warfare they're gonna
want to quit because they're like oh I can't best moment if so before someone
kills you just pause the game I can literally pot apparently I can pause
the match like oh I'm coming I'm what the fuck so Jordan is so inaccurate what
is this what is this is someone hurting what is this sorry I'm oh my god I just I
just elevated I'm in a different strap oh where did that go my balls oh I just
write that I am I think I like this character hold on a minute don't write
her yet oh I saw that hard there's a sombra here it's a sombra here holy fuck
who's top 500 in this team goddamn GGs I'm I feel like I got carried very hard
thank you that was I'm not sure considering how last I was getting
curbstomped you know who's to play the game let's see it then
you are so wagon all right I have my chance a hundred percent in the mood to
don't want to right now right okay we'll go back to normal games and then we'll go
back to custom games that makes sense because there's some refunds that haven't
played a normal game with me that makes sense right so show and then it was right
you're still on good I had Billy and Diddy but I think you guys have gone off
line all right diddy you're here Billy's already gone off line so are you have
dot oh there you are and then I have either void or match I guess match you would be
slip myth mit mit mit mit yeah you that was right that was you oh sync was not
available oh no oh no there you go okay okay okay okay right we'll do this
public match and then I've got one more public match and then we'll go back to
fucking each other up in a custom game shall we? GGs, I'm off to go eat GGs thank
you for playing Reefblows. I'm honestly having a blast. I'm so sorry if I get like
a bit annoying when I get really excited but I just this it is just this fills
my heart and soul, you know?
My voice is too fucked because I've been screaming all day but it's the B&L version
of Fly Me To The Moon. Thanks for the stream, gotta go shopping now, gotta go
faster, faster. Enjoy your shot. Don't, adopt, don't shot.
I kept you alive as much as I could. My boy was re-in.
It's so hard to try and play around me because I'm just like hmm I have an idea
and then I start doing stuff that doesn't make any sense. Thank you Roly
Really annoying. Annoyingly cute. Annoyingly submissive.
Drinking my peach tea before work. I'm drinking my skinny can of spray. Full sugar.
Fully bad for me. This is definitely fun hopefully you do it again sometime.
Yes I absolutely will. As I said I thoroughly enjoy stream snipe stuff.
I like doing stuff together. It makes me so happy.
I'm so excited.
Another way.
Oh the artwork got released for Sheebers' legs on her Gamer Steps.
And other words. Please be true.
And other words. I love you.
Oh we will definitely be back here with Overwatch 2, right Mooma?
What are you talking about?
It's so funny watching you react to changes in Overwatch 2.
It's nice to see how evil powers in you find out something new.
Thank you Alan for this review. Yes! The heroes I'm not, I'm not even played Malg.
Whatever his name is. This one. Where are you?
I think I might have played Junker Coon.
I definitely have not played him though, not played him.
I don't know, obviously I played it custom with you. Venture, she's new as well.
Sojourn, I think I've been Sojourn and then Junker Queen.
But when Sojourn came out I was already limping off of the game.
Alari, I don't really recall you too much darling.
Life? He wasn't in the base game, I can tell you that much.
He wasn't in the base.
Rematron, I do remember when he came out because he was like,
Oh my god Rematron! He looks like Zenyatta!
Oh my gosh! And he's like the good monk and he's like a bad monk.
Basically. So Mo is Dutch by the way, always have fun.
He really be like...
That's how he picks up the leaves.
I really don't like Venture, they make me not just looking at them, they're so specific.
They added a guy called Sigma, yeah this is the only Sigma I know.
Wait, let's listen to his voice lines.
I truly hate that voice line.
Is he not going to Dutch?
Who would pay for this?
It's better to pee in the sink to sink in the pee, amen Sigma.
Neil?
Oh, I thought it was going to be a bit more like...
You know him? But it's just Neil.
You are my starlight.
You are my starlight, my only starlight.
You keep on shining when the sun's early.
Sorry my voice is fucking stuffed.
Is there no Netherlands?
Can you ask me to ex...
Frohle kerstfeest.
What?
Frohle kerstfeest, or what?
Feine kerstdagen.
Feine kerstvaarten, what?
Glorious.
Many find the universe.
Do me a normal, eh?
And then you'll do me crazy enough.
Do you do me crazy enough?
Do you do me normal?
No.
What?
Do me normal, eh?
And then you'll do me crazy enough.
I can't do that one.
Who lives on his head, has to stay out of the sun.
What?
Stay out of the sun.
Close your eyes.
I know it!
Yeah, I knew this one.
I've got it.
Ah, he conveyed it.
Wait, what's to the Spanish ones?
Sombra.
Your turn.
Give us some Spanish.
Where's the fun in playing fair?
Who wants to buy?
Feliz Navidad.
I know who's been naughty.
I know who's inked without permission.
Same voiceline.
I can be nice.
What's up, Pex?
Try and keep up.
I've got some sun.
You're taking these berries.
Assusta me pantheon.
Ah.
Mess with the best and die like the red.
You're squishing a bug.
I think you're in over your...
All the information you have to pay.
Good one.
You're just like...
De pelos.
Oh, it sounds like she's saying de pelos.
De pelos?
De pelos.
Mmm, muy bien.
Mmm, s, s.
I'm so bilingual.
Tri-lingual.
Quad-lingual.
Quintertingual.
I tried.
Who else speaks a lingual that you guys know?
German?
German.
Yeah, German.
Let's go.
Build a pyramid?
Is there no German?
Wait, there's no German voicelands?
Mmm.
The Throne of Venus.
Wait, have I played that?
Bro, send me up on that.
Oh, no, this is an actual game.
Sorry, we're not against the reflands.
Hold on a minute.
We have to actually use teamwork to play this
because I don't know what this is.
T.
Zen has some of the best voicelands.
I dreamt I was a butterfly.
In some Spanish countries, they have their
their way of saying a specific item,
place, or person, or anything to German.
It's not actually German.
You just don't want to pay for a clutch.
What does that even mean?
Right, actually.
Am I allowed to just mercy heal beam
for the last of this?
I mean, like, come on.
I've been a good girl, okay?
It's been seven hours.
We've been having a carry-on together, okay?
I've been a good girl.
I'll behave, I promise.
I'm gonna just mercy heal.
Look at these skills.
I know it's such invigorating gameplay.
I don't know why.
I just find it really satisfying having to manage
everyone's health and, like, keep everyone alive.
Like, I actually get throbbing after a good fight
that I kept everyone alive, which we would have lost
otherwise if it wasn't for my decision-making.
Like, I didn't mean to be a weirdo, but...
I said it, like, you asked.
Well, no one asked, but you asked.
I do hate when the maps are so open.
Well, that diva can perish.
Well, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
I don't know if Alari's a bit of a DPS or not.
I'll...
...
B-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d
Aw, I wanted to scar.
What is she actually on, sis?
Ooh, my God. It's the ABC maps.
Okay, right.
We need to progress up, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know whee, come on.
We do need to get forward, but how?
Right, let's go.
The diva has forgotten.
I think we're just going to have to lose this on like the next point because we're fighting on it.
Unless I'm mental enough. I don't know what.
I'm just feeling quirky. I just felt a little bit quirky.
If you don't get the balls to do something, something will work out.
Venture is Canadian? Mexican?
I didn't know what her thing in my barber was, but that's really interesting.
It's nice when they do mixes.
It's not just one or the other. I guess probably the difficulty would be finding a voice.
Although saying that Junkrat is American, like the voice actor for Junkrat.
They're getting you, they're getting you.
You're on your own, Junker Queen. Please be careful.
Junker Queen, you're on your own. We can't restock Junker Queen. Can you make it back?
Oh no.
Refling, no.
Don't do that. That was rude.
I'm trying. I'm breaking free.
We'll need to wait for Junker Queen to come before we move in.
I don't know if I can raise that, bro.
I don't know if I can raise that. That's right in front of them.
Maybe, maybe.
Let's go.
No, you've...
By a freaking molecule.
Maybe.
Well, we're already set up for this fight on this point at Point Delta.
You know what? Maybe it works out in here.
Where did your house go? I don't have res, I'm sorry.
I don't have res. Oh my god, the...
Not the diva actually doing what she's supposed to, which is mowing down the healers.
How frustrating.
I don't know how I kept you alive.
Unfortunately, I sacrificed myself for that, but we did...
I mean, that could have gone a lot worse.
I bet my soul sucked at me. That Mercy was like, nah, I'm not having that.
Hey, Mercy, that Moiro's like, nah, I'm not having that.
I like playing support. I'm not the best at getting kills,
that makes me feel useful when I play.
Bro, that's literally me, because I just can't aim for the life of me.
I'm like, this is going too fast for my brain to keep up.
I'd rather just...
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, it does not feel like...
That's it, I'm looking up the patch notes.
I need to know what healing per second I do.
I think I'll pick Moiro next game, probably that deal.
Unusualizing system.
Refling said, didn't you mind me?
I'm out.
Okay, the Ana got healed, which is good.
And then...
We're kissing, we're kissing, we're safe, we're safe.
She better not try and...
Damn, she does not like us.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I don't, I don't know what I'm doing.
I think, I think it's time.
I think it's time to go Moiro.
It is time.
It's time to be toxic.
No, but Stronny, you had your ultimate.
Wait, I thought the ultimate was 30% if you had it full.
When they changed that, I could have sworn they made it
so you had, you get to keep your ultimate,
because they were like, we're addressing the problem
where people don't want to swap their characters
because they don't want to lose ultimate,
but it's costing them like precious time basically.
They reverted the 30%.
I mean, I get that you shouldn't be like...
You don't want to go and leave me alone.
What's going on?
Bro, I can't keep up.
I suck at this game and I'm dead.
I am sucking terribly.
Sorry, we've won.
I'm sorry, I'm being an anchor.
I think maybe, am I allowed to blame it
on the endurance screen?
I'm going to be honest, I only scheduled into play
two hours of this, but I got a wee,
not me and Genji did the exact same thing.
Both of us are like, that's strange, we can't get up.
It was nerfed.
It's like going back to an old playground
and they took away the swings and feels like that.
Yeah, I didn't expect to play so long,
but I'm having such a blast.
I was like, more, more, more, more, more.
Obviously, it's really fun when I unlock a new character
just to play it like, just because.
See this diva constant, oh, I'm just walking,
I'm so sorry, Ana, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm tryharding.
I mean, at least we got this.
Oh, leave my Ana alone.
There we go.
Right, is this a comeback?
Hashtag, come on, oh fuck.
Man, I hate divas because they always eat my balls.
That was my healing, like, don't be so rude, you know?
If we could get rid of that diva, honestly.
Honestly, get rid of that, yes.
No.
I fated, but because of the lag it didn't register,
you literally heard the audio queued me fading.
Because I knew what I had to do next.
You wouldn't mind if divas sucked your ball,
I bet you wouldn't.
I'm so sorry.
You wouldn't mind if divas sucked your ball,
I bet you wouldn't.
I bet to leave for work, Nateshift,
have fun as well, get some dobes,
yeah, thank you for playing, if you say.
And thank you for farting, if you farted.
Oh wait, shit, this is the last point.
Whee!
I wouldn't let me get one alive, but I did stall.
I did what I had to do.
Sorry, Weflins.
I'm definitely not so awake.
My fellow Weflinks, I am not awake.
My fart work.
I'm going.
Are they doing it? Wait, hold on.
I'm doing a healing orb, bouncing it on that wall.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, don't make me the last one on this point.
Oh wait, the Weflins are doing it?
Oh my god.
No pressure.
Oh my fellow Americans.
Sorry, that's really stuck in my head right now.
It's my brain worm.
Oh no, it's an ear worm.
I don't have worms in my brain.
I have worms for brains, but I don't have a worm in my brain.
Right, I need this diva DMect.
I'm going to see her tiny little tight bodysuit.
No, you have to be kidding me.
I needed, I needed a kill.
I needed a kill, right.
Oh my gosh.
The comeback.
Scraped off my teeth.
Because I think we have the comeback.
No.
No way.
Reflins.
That was fantastic.
Fucking GG.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, that was so good.
I don't know how you did that.
Because I was such an anchor that entire game.
Oh my gosh, I'm so proud of you.
What the fuck?
You guys are so good at this game.
This is how I should just cheat in multiplayer games.
Oh my god, next you can carry me on that game that got review bombed
because Sony told the dev team to make you like
sign up with a phone number to play or something.
No, what was that?
What was the thing about Helldiver?
Are you squidding me right now?
I'm going to continue.
S-S-A-O-D-A
S-A-O-D-A
Thank you for the extended membership.
Hey, Stronny, I took the liberty of tweaking the 66.
It was better.
Let me copy and paste that code.
I'm going to go very quickly for a piss.
I'm going to go for a piss.
I'm going for a piss.
I think there is one Reflin.
Who was it?
Oh my god, please?
Can I just... Please let me see what I was...
Right, no, no, not German time.
Go to sleep.
Right, so that was...
I don't know. Who's that?
You came in. I thought you came in.
It was Boyd and Billy that didn't get...
Uh...
There's like two more.
Care about the battle pass?
Couldn't be less of a shy sort.
Um...
Okay, now they've gone a bit.
My poor Reflit.
Hidden Squid? Was it you that never got a game with me?
I'm going to admit there was someone with this profile picture
that didn't get a chance. Was it you Hidden Squid?
Oh, not to... I think it was you.
Fuck it again. I think it was you.
Joy?
I don't remember writing joy down.
Have you played with me?
You're in a game right now, so I can't invite you.
I just need to make sure...
Oh my god, you're open mic.
He's going to fart down the mic.
Boyd Ranger, you never got a shot with me, did you?
No, you didn't.
Um...
Wink, wink?
You playing this tutorial?
Wink, you never got a chance to play with me, I don't know.
Please do not fart down the mic.
You have open mic on this one.
I can hear you cutting about in the background.
Don't fart, they're going to hear it.
Um...
I'm just checking. I think Joy
is the only one
that I can see online right now that hasn't had a shot.
Right, I'm going to very quickly go for a P,
okay?
Helldiver is still good.
Sony required to have PSN again.
Oh yeah, that was a bit bizarre.
I remember that.
Okay, let me go for a quick PP.
I'll be a moment.
I'll be quick again.
Thank you.
No, I didn't wash my hands.
She saw me when I came out,
and she was like,
and I was like, give me another hour, Gimli.
She's gone, I'm already back.
I know anyone.
Right.
Who did I try and get in there?
It was Joy, you're in a fucking...
Right, that's it, you're getting whispered.
Do you want an yes-lag?
I don't even...
Oh no, I can't call you a slag.
Right, do you want an refling kiss?
Exo exo exo exo?
You need to
ditch your current
lobby
for me
to invite you into the group.
Oh, wait, because I called you a slag?
No, I didn't call you a slag.
I don't know.
Maybe the server didn't like that.
I don't know, the server didn't like that.
And thank you for the extended membership
again and the lobby code,
CODA.
Call him a slag.
That's all I'm going to say.
Wait, it doesn't...
Wait, can I not send any...
Can I not...
Can I not call any...
What?
Did he just fart?
Did you fart in my fucking movie?
Am I chat banned?
What's an internal problem, 7000?
I'm getting nervous.
How have I been chat banned?
I didn't do anything.
I think it's on your side.
Do this, press escape options social.
Escape
Options
Social
Next chat.
On, on, on, on...
I never can message you that you're a bunch of slags.
No, fuck!
He blew on the mic, perhaps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, mic blew.
Aw, I can't call you slag.
Magic getting a DM from your Oshi in the game?
Cog, what the hell?
Right, how...
Is there anyone else that hasn't had a chat?
I'm analizing, other than...
I'm just taking, if not, I'll just get randomly shown.
Did you play your own game, so I assume you played?
With me, I'm not sure.
I can't remember.
All the dates are blurring together.
I'm gonna get you in, because you literally waited from the start.
I'm pretty sure you waited 7 hours
just to play with me, and I feel really bad.
Tee hee, I feel terrible.
She's calling other reeflings slangs,
God, I wish that were me. Oh, no, I can call you a slag right now.
I assure you.
Oh, you just stopped playing?
Literally, I was like...
No, I'm not doing it. Get me out here.
Right, we'll play this game...
or not.
Who's taking a job at a time?
Oh, no, he did join you.
Oh, no, he did time out.
Are you coming in or not?
You literally waited for, like, Iber.
Iber, Iber, Iber, Iber, Iber.
He's away for a job at a bit, yeah.
He's actually doing a big fat and nasty shite.
Do you want us to see if he...
Yeah, whisper to me if you can.
Who'll be moaning?
Right, okay, let's go.
I'm gonna play...
Oh, no, I can't play Moog.
I hate it here.
Okay.
Oh, I heard myself in the background.
I can hear myself in the background.
You have open mic on, by the way.
You're still on, I saw you when I went to sleep.
Rise and shine.
Because...
We're playing with the refloons.
Like, I like mushroom snippets, okay?
It fills my soul, okay?
Wait, what?
Sorry for bullying you in Overwatch, but I was lashing out.
Not only because I'm not able to call you a puppy.
I didn't hear a mic.
But also because you called me a fakeling.
I had to correct you.
My headset just came out.
Oh my god, I can't hear anything.
Oh my god, hold on.
Quick, then.
Mic check, okay.
Okay, I can hear that.
Jeez, couldn't whisper.
Okay, I wonder if it's because my account's new.
They're like, hmm, this is a box.
Wait, did I not select...
Oh sorry, did I not select sometime?
Everyone pick a rule, pick a rule.
Any rule is yours.
Danes are working, but yours aren't.
Mommy, you might need to look at that.
How strange.
My milk isn't connected.
Oh wait, it finally works.
Oh my god, the refloons!
I did this!
I'm just gonna make my own sense.
They have, like, no idea what happens until I start
squirming down the mic.
Excuse me, wink, wink.
I did a rule, young man.
I did all.
Wink? No.
No, you've no selected it.
You need to click, you need to confirm it.
The big orange one.
Click all and confirm.
Ah, that's what I thought, bend over.
I had to confirm it, holding up line of production.
Come on, I've got XP to farm.
Oh, you've never played?
Nope.
The first Overwatch was better.
How can you not play?
You have no idea what you're about to be in for.
And before he gets the fucking tank.
Oh no.
It's Ogre.
It's actually Ogre, if he gets phone tank.
But not in a bad way, just so you know.
You have no idea what you're about to get in Nile, it kind of way.
He's going to the factory.
I literally, I just couldn't believe this game's shit.
Why does anyone play it?
It's nothing.
Stony, please.
I haven't had to make the phone.
Hmm?
Wait.
Favorite character in Overwatch, go.
The one that I come to the most, thank you.
I play Paladin.
Hopefully that trash is over.
Paladin? Wait, you're a world of Warcraft?
Yeah, buddy.
Oh no.
He's the best.
I've never got a chance to play World of Warcraft.
My mother thought it was...
I was going witchcraft in it.
I was against Jesus, wasn't it?
Eh, kind of.
Oh my god.
Wait, but wouldn't...
Which is weird, because her friends was a witch,
but she wasn't okay with me playing World of Warcraft.
She was fine with me playing Wizard 101, I guess.
His mom would think I'm an absolute slag.
Wait, are you not going to get in trouble talking to me?
You know, girls like me?
You're the least weird girl I have ever encountered.
Wait, what?
I mean, that's...
No.
Did I take that as a normie comment?
Did I just get called a normie?
Oh my.
Me?
Normie?
Don't mind if I do.
Ugh.
Let's do it.
Right.
It's attack.
Right, I'm going to show you the power of attack, Targaryen.
No, I'm going to try McCree.
Sorry, okay, I should do it.
I dead named him.
I swear, if I hear one,
we're going to fart in the background.
I'm going to cry.
Certified normie, literally.
Oh my god, we're at Lysha State.
Did he just win me already?
You're pretty good.
Oh my god, your profile picture is so cute.
It's when Jerry ate the cheese
and it becomes cheese shaped.
Thank you for becoming a member.
You're pretty good.
I'm not good at Overwatch,
but I'm going to be pretty good at physics.
Astrony, we all call him McCree.
Okay, right, I'm not getting cancelled, thank you.
Literally, I called him McCree
for the three years that I played Overwatch.
Please forgive, I'm sorry.
It takes me a while to adjust.
Oh my god, this microphone's going to snap off.
I'm going to snap this freaking twig.
Right, okay.
I need to get the aimbot up.
Okay, I missed completely.
I actually have decent things.
I'm not sure I'm supposed to spam it like this,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
Man, we've got a DMG.
Stuff's happening.
It's not happening by me.
Ah, sure you, I'm missing all my shots.
Okay, Ryan's barrier's about to go down.
Oh, your zen just got sniped.
Oh, I didn't even notice him there.
Oh, he was hiding in the wee subway car.
Oh my god, we didn't consume enough brain rot, TikToks.
Right, okay.
I can roll and it'll reload, and I've got a flashbang.
I don't know if it's magnetic anymore.
I just remember it being a magnetic thing.
Okay, right, no, that's not my problem.
Sorry, that's above my pay grade.
I'm going to wait until the refunds come right back.
We're in Mario's place.
They have drone delivery by the slice.
What, by the slash?
Please, video megastore.
Mihai!
Mihai, Mihai, Mihai.
Sorry, Mihai, 7.69.
Thank you for the extended membership, Reinhardt Supremacy.
You love Reinhardt?
I'm sorry, Anna, just...
Right, no, I've had enough.
I've had enough, right.
Who do I need to play?
It's going to have to be Torbjorn.
I'm sorry, the reason why I like Torbjorn so much
is survivability.
If I put myself in a really silly, billy place,
I can literally just press E
and get myself out.
Like...
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I can't even disappoint my refunds just because I'm...
No!
Right, fuck it, Hammer Time.
Discord, Hammer Time.
I just shit on my ass
and I put it on my face
because I need me
to press.
There's no way I just did that.
That was ridiculous.
Okay.
No, the hands...
Hands up, no.
Ash, go away!
Right, I'm backing off, I'm backing off.
It's so annoying.
Would you like a cold refreshment?
I want to ink.
I need to be able to ink in a minute.
I think that's what I need to be able to do now.
Right, we've de-mexed the diva.
Honestly.
Okay, I died,
but the ping saved my ult.
That would have been a decent...
That would have been a decent ult.
Oh!
The resentful of like,
appreciation.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, it's a hur.
A stone.
Uh, we better
in my life.
A wee bit of jelly in my life.
A wee bit of refland in my life.
A wee bit of tentacle in my life.
A wee bit of rape in my life.
I'm starting to lose it.
But not in a bad way, just in a...
I can feel myself get
very, very quite contrary.
Mary had a little one.
PING!
PING! Please, I'm begging ya.
I'm begging for a PING.
I'm just going to blame PING,
even though this is the best ping I've had.
180 latency.
Eating that bad.
I'm going to be honest, this is crazy.
I'm losing it.
A little bit.
But not in a bad way.
It's going to be weird.
I don't have any
gen mates to redirect into.
A wee bit of...
How can you come?
Mods, you know what to do.
Bruh, you're just...
You're begging for a...
Oh!
Right, one DPS down. Take your time.
Take your time. We've got it.
We've won this fight. I'm not even kidding. We've won this fight.
Right, I'm going to help put that up there for them.
That's a point.
Now get over it.
In there.
Okay, yeah.
As soon as you get your turret down at an advantage point,
it's ogre. Hydration check.
No!
Oh my god.
Right, momed down.
There we go.
There we go. We've got three minutes.
Maybe a cross platform raid.
A cross platform raid.
Oh!
That was rather rude, don't you think?
Nino, nino, nino!
Ah, this is a bit...
It's a bit too much.
A bit much.
Oh!
Hit one of the 360.
Just in case I'm playing the game, you know?
Go ahead and hit one of the 360.
Just in case it's me.
The strontius I'm taking over.
I can brainwrote on this for hours.
I was so surprised since then she still plays this game.
I didn't think...
She played it.
But you learn something new every day, you know?
Time to let off some feet.
That's what I'm coming for.
Well, I didn't really...
get what...
Didn't he mind me likes?
Oh, didn't he mind me?
Oh, Zen, you cheeky boy.
Best I can do is repurpose European servers
at 1,500 ping-mini.
Literally.
Tiny spanish literally.
Honestly, I don't mind because you guys are carrying me.
That's the main thing.
Mummy, can we raid in the fire?
Of course you can get in the fire truck!
Beep beep!
I hear footsteps.
Oh, it's there.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I hear footsteps.
Oh!
What's going on?
Ash is up there, but I can't seem to get her.
Oh, she got healed.
Oh dear.
My turret is getting engaged, so I can't put it down.
My turret keeps getting engaged.
Congrats, wins the wedding.
But seriously though, right there.
Okay, that's what I'm gonna do.
You got team kill!
Right before the end!
Oh, that's diabolical.
Diabolical, that was fantastic gameplay.
Oh, diabolical.
Oh, and I've got enemy achievement as well.
GG, oh my god.
World Traveler, have I played enough of the map?
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh, I've not seen that intro.
Why is she purple?
Yeah, poggers on the tanks.
Most of what?
Brog.
Yeah, I'm not gonna lie, they had a few bangers.
Wait, it wasn't me.
I couldn't hear anyone.
Oh, I was trying to talk.
Oh, I got sigma.
Right, I'm on my sigma balls.
I was trying to turn off my SFM labs.
What does that mean?
Right, we're gonna play sigma notes.
And then we're gonna do one more custom.
Yeah, I couldn't hear anyone.
Oh, sorry about that.
No, GG's, you guys did amazing.
Thank you for the play.
I'm doing custom after this next one if you want.
Tee hee.
Awesome stream.
Oh, yeah, you'll like the stream.
I bet you'd...
I should get removed.
Get removed, get removed.
Do you know how long it's gonna take me
to delete everyone on the friends list?
This has not had a...
No, don't...
I'm not ready to select a role.
Stop, back out, I need to add.
You.
I'm just checking.
I'm going nuts over
Hidden Squad.
I feel like you've not been in, but you might have been in
because I've tried to keep getting you in.
Woody?
Oh, Woody?
Probably, I think.
What's the matter, baby?
I don't know.
Right, okay, last game and then we'll do custom
and then we'll start fighting again
and then I'm gonna wrap it up because unfortunately
I'm getting a wee bit tired now.
Shawnee, did you know a group of cuttlefish
is called a snuggle? Is that real?
What is a group
of cuttlefish called?
It actually is called a snuggle.
They're so adorable.
Haven't been queuing at the same time
even if we play a whole stream.
I don't know, yeah.
Be honest, I did that with Reinhardt.
We got the dub, so 10 out of 10.
Gameplay, fantastic.
Beautiful, gorgeous, stunning.
I'm playing sigma balls, so everyone back off, okay?
I'm playing sigma.
The universe.
It sings for me.
All she believed, the universe.
Singing for me. All she believed.
All she believed.
Oh, thank you, Belle.
Oh.
A wee bit bring up, just a little.
Ooh, ah, just a little bit.
Ooh, ah, just a little bit more.
Oh, cuddly snuggly.
Right, I'm gonna
remove the gamer tag.
Unpin message.
Yeah, because we're wrapping up
stream after this one.
Wrap up stream just like how I
wrap up my
job for the sea.
What the fuck are you even on about?
I don't know.
Is there anyone I can redirect into
even though
I've been a naughty girl.
I've been
reluctant to
redirect into anyone that isn't
the allure. I'm like, I shouldn't
be like that because that's so mean.
I'll redirect into people that are doing
ASMR collabs with me. Fuck it.
If you're gonna be nice and do a cheeky
ASMR collab with me, I'll
redirect into people.
Oh, there's no time to waste
all my tears and tears.
Okay.
Sigma sounds like he's craving in a
short to 90%. Wait.
Hello.
I wish I was
waiting to put a refund on the spot
and be like, say something or do this
or do that.
Oh!
You know in the next custom
mode, should I make them bark for heels?
No, I'm a really rusty Genji.
It's been a long time.
So what you're saying is
Nanoboost got it.
Loud and clear. Nanoboost it is
even though I'm gonna play Sigma.
Should I
degrade yourself for me?
Bark like a dog for heels refund?
Hell yeah.
That's terrible.
That is terrible.
These are inside thoughts that
should never come to the light of day.
And yet here I am.
Plotting already. I've not even
got into the next lobby.
I really do like Juno's design.
I like how she's fully covered but it's
skin tight.
Vacuum sealed like space itself.
That kind of makes sense.
Bark, bark.
Rusty sword carrier.
I used to watch
ASMR videos of knife cleaning.
Like I would take a rusty knife
and they would like brush it down
with this liquid and then keep doing it
over and over until all the brush went away.
It's like my time.
Ah yes, Antarctica.
Hydration.
Form fitting.
Form fitting 10 of 10. Hold on.
Hold on.
Ooh.
Listen here.
I thought I was so scared.
Oh they did it here.
I muted it too.
And then I said in game, I said pretend
I farted down the mic and none of them
said anything.
Reflins, you're supposed to.
I'm ready to get into trouble.
You're not in voice chat, Reflin.
Two Reflins aren't in voice chat.
They're so shy.
Right.
Sigma doesn't look like he's changed.
No.
He looks the same.
The setup looks the same. Shield looks the same.
Big rock.
If you think you are graduating this overwatch gaming session
without kissing my rock, you're welcome.
He's the same.
What do you mean being a...
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
They're so aggressive.
What did we do?
The objective is a risk.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's...
It needs to take this.
Oh yeah, the flash sombra as well.
Oh my god.
I am the worst tanker this.
Oh no.
I think
the fartlings are shy.
My joke.
I can hear her.
Oh wait, I'm the tank. Hold on. I need to go forward.
Hold on a minute. It's me that has to go forward.
Not my teammate.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
Get out of the sky!
Right, they've only got one healer
but we are down to DPS.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even figure it out.
I can't.
Can you shove your granny off of us?
I just thought you should know that.
That's very important.
That you know about that nurse room.
They are literally spawn campingers.
That is how bad I'm doing as my job is a tank.
This is why I didn't touch tank with a 10 foot pole.
I used to be so confident
when it was 6v6 on Zarya and Rain.
I would always be the way Zarya
and then they changed it
and now I'm useless.
The game is about to finish.
I don't have my ult.
I've literally not even done my ult.
I don't know what to do.
The universe!
It's singing!
Right, I'm getting off this.
Sorry, I need to go on Zarya.
I...
I don't know who to go for.
Diesel?
Hmm, sorry.
I just feel confident.
I'm having a six tonight.
I love that song.
My mum used to sing that to me.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe everything isn't just an instant win.
Much sing.
But we're going to do a custom game after this.
And I'm going to show you how it is.
I'm going to show you how it is.
You think my muscles are pretty.
Pretty weak.
I'm sorry, I'm so strong.
I'm going to go chase Neil Pulse on real and true.
She's such a girl's girl.
I'm a tank main but mainly
Rain, Ball, Winston.
I cannot even do nervous noises
for what comes next.
I can't even do
10% battery on heads.
You never charged it!
I can't believe you didn't charge our heads
to play with mummies.
Right, let's
see how we
figure out with it.
Right, I was hoping to get
a wee bit more, but I've just killed her
because I'm not even kidding.
I've just killed her because
of my selfishness.
I think I'm just
bad at being true.
I'm trying.
Okay, okay.
This is what I need.
Give me a wee bit of energy and watch what happens.
I'm unfortunately out of heals.
But I just need a wee bit.
I love your thumb.
Aw!
Aw, thank you
for the super chat.
I'm glad you like the thumb. Do you like that I'm Reinhardt
and then I've not played Reinhardt once for this entire
8-hour stream?
Do you find that cute? Do you find that adorable?
Do you find that
naughty?
Have I been a bad girl
because I've not played Reinhardt?
Thank you, FMV.
I'm very kind of you.
Bruh, we're getting massacred.
They're coming for...
They're coming for me.
Okay, let me...
Let's retry that again.
I'm the silly Genji.
I can protect you!
I can protect...
Right, go top left. Go here.
No, don't. There's a fucking...
Winston here.
Okay, I'm high level
for once. I can go for Juno.
Please, that Juno is so...
gonna get it.
I'm 100 energy
and can do nothing with it.
I'm about to...
I'm...
Right, no.
Don't let yourself give into that
mentality. I'm an asset
to my team.
Even if the tank is the most
pivotable...
Pivotable member
of the team, okay?
And I might be
being an absolute detriment,
but I'm a good girl, okay?
I'm trying my best.
That's the main thing, right?
Why is she doing that?
A bra.
I don't...
Bob, if you could go way right now,
that'd be great.
No, I think...
No!
They dead.
Genji, they dead!
Yeah!
A wee bit, it's fine.
Hello, Henry.
No, I'm Irish. I'm Scottish.
They don't have a Scottish Overwatch hero
yet.
Because they better.
Alright, I'm using all...
Fuck this.
Well, their healers
are down, so that's the good news.
They don't have heals,
but they do have tails.
I'm so sorry.
I can only say I'm sorry.
It's not happening.
I'm not.
I'm rubbish.
Right, get me off a tank. I'm never again.
Like, I don't know what it is.
As soon as you're born with XX chromosome,
boom, tanks are just impossible.
Healing, absolutely fine.
DPS, maybe.
Let's be honest.
But yeah, tanks just out of the fucking DNA.
Oh!
Right, let me do the custom game mode.
What was the code?
I wrote it down. I wrote the code down.
For the custom lobby.
Right, get in my lobby.
Get in my...
No, don't read queue. Just continue.
Stop with everything. Stop! There's too much going on.
Right, I need to...
Come up to group here.
I need to remove group.
And then...
I need to play a custom...
Nice.
You didn't mean it, bless you.
Create.
Sentence.
Import code. Copy and paste.
Okay, lobby.
Make sure... Oh, my chat is on.
Right, and now what?
Fucking hell, you guys stream snipe fast.
Right.
And then we need six enemies.
Okay, we have one enemy.
I tried to join and invited instead.
Oh, I think...
Wait, can you guys not see it unless you're coming like this?
It mustn't be.
What is Johnny's balance?
I'm so sorry. I'm literally about to go offline.
This is my last match.
I'm so sorry.
You have such bad timing.
I've been playing for eight hours.
I'm sorry.
Develop memory glands.
What?
I'm silver five, so you go to the game trust.
I did the same thing.
Whoopsies, the last match.
I'm so sorry. Whoever gets in, gets in.
Whatever will be, will be.
I think he hasn't played left.
I don't know.
Is it Chuck E. Cheese?
I think it might be you that's not played.
Right, we're just going to do it.
Everybody, let's get to it.
Whoever's in the team's in the team.
Whoever's not...
Not a spectator.
I'm sorry.
Would you say...
It's going to take me so long
to unfriend everyone.
But I've never seen my friends look so full before.
That was actually, I have to admit, that's actually really cool.
I've never seen it so full before.
Feel like my...
Not my belly, because I'm not eating.
Holy shit!
I forgot to eat yesterday and to do.
I've only had liquid.
I ate a bag of crisps yesterday
because I forgot to eat
and I've started stream
and I forgot to eat
and it's been eight hours as well.
Oh.
I'm really not that wise.
I just...
That just hurt me.
Okay, let me go and match up.
I can't shite.
None of my friends are match.
I'll eat.
I'll eat after this game.
Left shift, run.
Oh!
The turning.
Absolutely not.
What's E?
Burning heal?
I heal on the enemy.
Nearby allies take reduction damage
and heal by dealing.
What?
That's like a healer's pat.
Am I going mental?
What does this do?
I don't know.
What am I doing?
Wait, I need to...
Oh, you need to hold them both down?
Sorry, hold on.
I'm spraying.
Oh, I didn't mean to rush into that.
I'm so sorry.
I just ran into the enemy team.
There's no getting out of that one.
That was just...
That was just me.
If you shoot left,
until it's burning every shot,
the headshot...
What?
Huh. It feels very spray.
Damn, our D.Va don't give a fuck.
She can bolt.
You're coming.
A starkish powder.
Did I eat anything on the stream?
Did I chew anything?
I'm actually the better tank.
No, stop it.
No, I haven't eaten anything.
I've only had liquids.
Huge tip, don't die.
Five head, honestly.
Right, so I have mobility
to go like this.
Okay.
Oh, it doesn't go on forever.
It's not like Reinhardt.
Oh, no, they didn't.
Stop that robot.
I'm spraying.
I'm just spraying.
Is that an enemy widow?
When did you
become a widow?
Yeah, they have a widow.
Rub.
Speaking of the widow,
I think she just sniped me.
Another huge tip.
Shoot the other team right.
Left gun, burn,
right does crit.
End people's burning.
So I just combo them, right?
He heals you if you shoot burn at him.
Oh, my gosh.
I actually interspawn.
What do I do?
Oh, my God.
No, I can't leave this on a freaking law.
Are you serious?
I can't.
I can't even have this on a law.
Sorry, I don't, I won't tolerate it.
We're doing another one.
I refuse.
No!
Flynn!
You knew exactly what I was going to try and do.
Oh, my God.
Right now, going again.
I refuse to leave on a law.
Sorry, I can't carry.
No, you can't carry that.
I was doing absolutely terrible.
I'm playing characters.
What is that?
A bug.
Why are you a bug in my Overwatch match?
I'm doing backflips and stuff on this game.
Right, no.
Whoever was on the team, everyone out.
And the new ones in.
I'm not leaving on a freaking negative team.
No, I refuse.
How are you psychological?
Law or fear?
I'm not even kidding.
Right, if you're in, you're getting swapped out.
Oh, God, everyone's swapping.
Right, okay.
I'm out of play.
We're going to play King's Row and Winter.
Oh, my God, it's the Christmas.
I'm so excited to spend Christmas with you.
Oh, my God.
I can't wait to watch all the movies together.
I'm going to get so many snacks.
I'm going to be munching
like a little hamster.
How the fuck did you find it?
How did you find it?
I deleted it.
Right, how did I put enemies on that?
I haven't been in.
Who hasn't been in?
Who...
Who wasn't in?
Oh, God.
Would you woo me in?
Cheese, I think.
I pulled you in.
It's all blurring together.
Oh, my God.
Does that seem right?
I was in last game.
So who wasn't?
I've got...
You slag.
Oh, I said I was not.
All right, well, be careful with your words then
because you know I can't read.
Yeah, you better have panicked.
That's right, you better have panicked.
Honor system, are we happy?
Don't pull me, I was in last game.
Okay.
Honor system, was anyone here from last game?
Is it Sombra?
You can swap for me?
Did you have a shot last time?
I don't think you've had a shot.
Wait, there was another message.
I wasn't in last game.
Yeah, I was already in.
Okay, thank you for the honor system.
I said was me.
Isn't that Scottish for it was?
Yeah, but I can't read in general.
I've been reading words all day.
My brain needs to shut down.
Right.
Okay, we're going to win.
I asked Father Christmas
to bless me from above
to guide my reeflings
and my team
to enable us
to defend
successfully on Torbjorn.
Can't wait to finally spend Christmas with my mom.
I'm going to make you sing Christmas carols with me.
I'm going to make you sing Jesus music and stuff.
Oh.
The bells of heaven are ringing.
It was such a joy knocking heads at the end.
That was you.
You knew exactly what I was going to do.
I was going to try and run on to the point
so we could stall for a bit more time.
Hypnotize the opposing reeflings
to let you win.
I'm not boisterous.
No, that's it.
You're getting my reeflings and the enemy team
you will not best me.
I'm winning. This is psychological warfare.
Oh my god!
That fucking Reinhardt!
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
I can't save you if you're up there.
Okay, there is a somber creeper around unfortunately.
Did you see that Reinhardt?
He was pressing double.
No, I don't think so.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Reinhardt!
Stop!
My Christmas with the reef.
Do you think the Reinhardt won me?
Hold on a minute.
Reinhardt, stop coming for me.
You're throwing for your team.
You need time for your teams.
You're throwing.
Don't you want to win?
Huh?
Or are you really okay with Dom loss
from someone that's five foot three?
Ha ha.
Reinhardt, you wanted the smoke.
Oh my god.
I'm almost tied up with family most Christmas.
What I'm doing.
You don't want somber!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Get Reinhardt.
See all that hard work you put into that kill somber.
But I got Reinhardt though.
I got Reinhardt though.
I got a cheeky resurrection.
You might have got the erection.
Oh, that's from Sonic Heroes.
I know that reference!
Oh my god, Reinhardt!
Stop it!
Oh my god, that's what you get.
You naughty boy.
You're getting an absolute thank him.
Oh my god, please, I'm winning.
I'm sorry, but I'm winning this.
I don't care. I'm actually winning this.
I refuse to go offline until I win.
I don't care how many times you try and slam into me.
You know what, man, when I said that.
I actually didn't mean it.
Oh, surprise Reinhardt! Hi!
Hi, Reefling.
You know you won the smoke.
I'm burning everything.
Ah!
No, I'm joking!
I don't actually mean to come to me.
Don't do it.
Ow, ow, ow, ow!
Okay, hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute.
I'm getting... oh, don't tell them.
Don't let them know.
Don't let them know your next move!
Saved!
Real.
Actually real and saved.
Oh my gosh, right, they're going to try and...
Come in through the building.
Sombra, you...
You're like a wet towel from...
Oh, that's like five days...
Five times used over.
That's what you are.
Oh, I can't get a raise.
I can't get a raise.
I'm coming.
I'm coming. Oh my god, he's literally right here.
Right here.
He's fucking here.
Is he not here?
Where the fuck's the rain?
Oh, he's back in the back.
Yeah, by, yeah, by, yeah, by.
Yeah, by, yeah, by.
Is it?
Right. No, they broke my turret!
Bro, the whole point of my turret is to do damage.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, come on.
I believe, I believe in the thing called love.
Just listen, listen to the rhythm of your heart.
If I do this...
High hopes for you.
You know, I'm starting to think they don't like my turret.
I don't know, I'm just getting like...
See that? See that?
I don't know.
I don't know if they can do it.
I'm being such an anchor right now.
Mercy is currently hovering above the point
to stop it from getting...
Oh my god, they're like...
There's two tanks and a healer.
I mean, maybe if they can...
Does she get the raise?
I'm about to, I'm about to ink.
No way, you get...
Oh my god.
Stop destroying my turret.
One, I'm...
I'm taking, I'm inking.
Get off my point, I'm inking.
I'm hotter than a furnace.
Right, that's right.
Oh, we did it.
Get beating, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Get beating, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Get beating, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Did she easy?
I missed a lot.
Nice to be able to feed her, you know.
Real...
I like the excuses.
Blame ping while you're at it.
Blame ping.
Say that your ping is like 100.
Or is it 15 or something?
Oh!
Cheeky bastard.
Oh my god, I won.
Right, now to start the endeavor
of deleting everyone.
Right, leave game.
No.
Yeah, leave the game.
Okay, now it is time to delete everyone.
If you are online,
it would make things a lot faster
if you could delete yourself.
Because I'm going to be here
for a little while.
Oh my gosh, and just like that.
Just like that.
Oh my god, oh my god!
They're doing it because it's registering.
It's registering.
Oh!
Oh, I'm out of a page.
Oh my. Thank you for helping.
Oh, you're actually...
You're doing it too fast, I can't keep up.
Deleting myself from mommy.
Okay, there we go.
I don't know how many are online, because I know some reflins went offline.
So don't worry if you...
Don't worry if you did your thing.
I hope I don't accidentally block someone.
I don't think I will.
Okay.
Oh my, you're doing it too fast.
I literally can't keep up. I need to pick up random.
Oh, quick, quick, who's going to win?
Me, I'm winning right now.
I'm winning, I'm winning.
I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry.
I enjoyed it!
Everyone was like, oh my god, overwatch, I can't believe it.
I was like, no one's going to show up.
They're not going to...
I was going to say that completely.
I was like, oh my god, no one's going to show up.
Because only a few people are going to tolerate it for me.
And I'm like, aww.
But you also got to thank you.
I'm really appreciative.
I thank the next...
Just to give you a heads up, I thank...
The next Streams Night Game.
Might be left for dead too, but there's a sequel.
There's a sequel that you don't know yet.
Because it only got us today.
I'm so sorry.
For any reflin or whatever.
As I said, I don't use these account
unless it's for stream sniping.
Like, this is literally a brand new account.
I ain't even got the heroes unlocked.
He says so much, he wants this to later.
So, no!
That's absolutely not what I'm saying.
I'm saying name it overwatch.
I'm going to go Betty Bang.
Oh my god, do you like my shit?
You know if you remove my shit,
I did not realise how much my boobily mooglies wrote?
Why is it so... hold on.
Thank you.
I just want to do that.
I'm going to pop that right back there.
Yeah?
Oh!
With my Torbjorn old Torbjorn.
Ready to work.
Thank you, tiny spany.
Thank you, chair.
I don't think I've played this long with in real life people.
What? No!
That's such a shame.
I'll play with you then.
Deal. Thank you, chair.
Thank you, island. Thank you, boy.
I don't know what that bloop means.
Does that mean there's a friend request?
I'm getting nervous. I keep hearing that bloop.
No!
Spank!
No, I don't use this account. Stop it.
She hasn't eaten in two days.
Yes, I'm going to go eat.
I'm going to make...
I didn't actually end up making the soup,
so I think I might freeze all the vegetables
or use them for something else.
I have passed...
I can maybe make cheesy
chicken
and vegetable...
like, roast vegetable pasta?
I don't think so.
So anyone make you happy so we'll play anything with you?
Yeah, even if you lost brain cells playing with me?
Yeah.
Thank you, the pretty lord.
Yeah, I would argue that's probably right.
I might just quickly take marshmallow
in case there's anything I missed.
That was major.
But I just want to say thank you so so much
for playing stream snake games.
If I wasn't an intense agony right now,
I'd probably cry from just how much fun...
Oh no, if I think about it too much,
I'm going to cry. Hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute, you're going to make me cry.
Are you feeling...
Oh!
Right, I'm tearing up just thinking about saying
thank you for playing games with me.
I call you a weakling
to torment you.
I'm a weakling, I'm greeting at the fact
that you'd fucking play that game with me.
No!
I'm not getting sniffily.
I'm getting a wee bit sniffily.
But I'm really happy.
I really like being able
to play with you
and do stuff with you. No, I'm not crying!
It just makes me really happy.
Thanks for the fun games.
Beloved, have a great night.
Have a good night too. Thank you Roonex.
That's the solution.
Yeah, it's nice
that we get to do stuff together
and goof off.
I know
not a lot of VTubers
will ever get this kind of thing
for themselves.
And I'm just really appreciative
of that.
You know how
sometimes you see someone being successful
they've got this going on for them
they've got that going on for them.
I'm there, I've got my reef lens
I've got the best end
and we get to play goofy games together
I get to scream down the mic
playing Overwatch
telling you I forgot to make you bark down the mic for heels.
Okay, next time, next time
I'll make you bark down the mic.
Literally
this was supposed to be a two hour stream
and
it was just non-stop
you're also patient as well
no one says anything mean
no one's like
oh my god I had to wait
I hated that
and all I got was a 10 minute game with you
because we played it so quickly
or whatever, no one's
it's just so nice
and I'm really grateful
I really am
I have a very nice feeling
my heart is very full
that is the descriptive
what I'm going to do
is go
offline and eat and probably pass out
tomorrow
the ring fit's going to be replaced
I
don't even know if I can do the members
stream chest because tomorrow
I'm going to feel a bit more sickly
whereas today I don't feel sickly yet
but no
I'll make you bark next
so thank you
reluctantly saying for this and for that
I'll make you bark next
I'm going to redirect
into
first super
first love proposal
first overwatch game
she's taken so many firsts in bleeding out
I can't
like as I said I'll play more free games
and I'll play different games of variety
in that
but yeah
thank you for letting me pop so many of your cherries
went quite nice
I am going to redirect
into
me
as always
please be respectful
I'll stop it
I'll literally go on about our word in you every single day
bruh
come on
thank you internet battlefile
but come on
a good person
I'm going to our word you if you don't let me win next
I'm going to psychological warfare
next
good person
you see me with rose tinted glasses
and all the stuff I come out with
honestly short in behaviour
but lovingly
yes lovingly
why of course
hmm
hi mommy I saw that you had a stream title
giving reflins new gamer tags but you can't see it
yes I'm not doing it today
em
I'm on my sin sister season
how about we call it that
I don't tomorrow
it's very likely I'm not going to feel very well at all
normally I would
hide it but
fuck it
em I'm just going to be honest
I am very likely to be very sick tomorrow
so I think tomorrow is going to be a two hour stream
and I will reschedule everything else
em
as I always do the thumbnail
and the title of that ASMR rewards stream will also change
so please don't worry
our little fights they're cute so fast
oh that's so bad
wait what how did I
did I not delete everyone
how did that
the one refling
to rule them all what
wait how did you come
Danny
I'm so confused
how did the they do that
is there something I'm is there something I'm missing
what is she
wait it still says I have
42 friends on battle mate
ah
ah we have to move them one by one
oh if they're offline
offline it doesn't display
in overwatch I guess
it says I have 39 right hold on
hold on
I'm deleting them and then I'll take a screenshot
and show you my darlings
I don't want any green ones
as I said I make specific accounts
for stream sniping
I think it's left
I forgot to I haven't played it before
but there is a little nice little twist to it
my only concern is
I might not get to everyone
because of the twist
so the only thing I can say is
disclaimer
sorry it's just going to go on
can I rub my brain cells
enough together
to maybe come out with a sentence
I don't know
or are you just going to
listen
to the tone of my voices
I don't believe
everyone was mad that
Juno's wee video
didn't have the same
quality we said it cheaped out
we did it
stylistic
we didn't groom mommy she groomed us
I like how that's the first thing I read
when I'm doing my wee delete thing
can't wait to Karma
charge her
wait what's that
in
in the video game
Shrani don't force it up to stream tomorrow
oh no no no you don't understand
I will happily
come on stream
and have painkillers and all that
that's fine
I really want to push myself
I think tomorrow I can actually tweet out
all my thumbnails and be like
I've streamed every single day for 3 months
which is an absolute hoot in the hauler
I can't believe that
it doesn't feel like it
like
like being able to be like
I have
I just removed sin
was that supposed to keep sin?
I don't know
hmm
was that supposed to keep sin sister
or my friends list
I know you can't see
anything right now
but
well I mean sins removed too
okay
the worst punishment for
Shrani is not streaming bro I think it's throw up
if I couldn't
there has been some days
where
before I've slept I've been like
oh my god I'm not sure
but
or like I need a break
to take time off to do background stuff
or whatever
but then I just know for a fact
if I actually did take a day off
I would be so mad at myself
I would be livid
not to be confused with it
is Mars livid
yes I'm allowed to make that joke
yeah I just
I would not forgive myself if I took the day off
and
I feel like if I did take a day off
I would actually just wrought as well
rather than get the work done that I was
in quotation marks supposed to do
right yes last person there we go
okay here we go
I'm taking a screenshot and I'm gonna
you're gonna hear the bidu that's me
that's me I told you that's me
and my pp always goes bidu bidu
and then I'm gonna save the image
and then I'm gonna drag it into
Vtube studio because it's actually hell of a lot faster
I dragged something into Vtube studio
there you go boom
yeah you like that
that's the scuttlefish that's me
and then it says find new friends
to start your journey
and get everyone from the battle net as well
that's why that person came
online on overwatch
and
yeah there we go and now it says your friends
list is empty as well
sorry you can't see because of me
I'll just stick that on me why not
yeah there you go
there you go
there we go
sure why not all about cleavage number
hurt anyone
there you go
it's like proper empty empty it doesn't register
we haven't got anyone on battle net
who's in my computer
mmm mommy needs it
Rotmax and please don't put yourself in a position where you have to take
off then take care
I'm gonna go eat because
I really have forgotten to eat for quite a while
whoop dee
em
brilliant Guinness clink
fuck a 2 rat all that nectar
em yeah I can't confirm
I've either Rotmax and
gaming Guinsel
or the most productive man on earth
working 12 hours a day
than having a tour or gym session somehow do
literally everything I'm saying
real
I'm like oh my god today
I'm gonna do this and this and this behind the scenes
and then I'm like
no I don't think I will
it's a long sensor
oh my god it does it looks like I have a
oh well
whoop
right
I'm gonna go eat
I'm gonna go rest
I might even be so devious and have a nice
hot bath actually wouldn't mind
wouldn't mind a hot
steaming bath
and then a Rotmax on peck tock
and make ya wound
that was a hoot in a holler though
thank you so so much for that stream
snipe as I said I believe
it's left for dead I could be wrong
I don't have my schedule I think it's left
for dead
I think it's during the week as well
I'm picking the stream snipe days
like through the week and then weekend
so no matter what
yeah you can come in on line left for dead
no matter what you can
come in
it doesn't matter what day you're working I'll rotate
around it so if there's a stream
that comes up and you're like oh I can't join
because da da da da I'm
rotating between the days until we hit
weekends again week days
certain days because like I used to work
I used to work Wednesdays
to Sunday
so I would have Monday, Tuesday off
and the world
is so quiet when you have
the day off like during the
weekday type thing
in the end
I'm friends with the ground
Sean if you move
in the right way we can get a peak
am I funny
like I said
a dibs wash on her back can we join
in oh you didn't mean
left for dead you meant the bathtub
I just got it sorry I'm slow
I'm slow you meant the bathtub
this isn't a
this is a bathtub
okay I got it I got it
I got it
right
I called dibs on washing
her front
I don't know
no no I think
I think ketchup season one in this one
actually I don't think any of you is allowed
in the bathroom this time
another time another time
okay it is time
to redirect
just home to try hard
right let me just make sure it's
set up if it's not set up I'm gonna
agree but if it is set up then
oh happy
time
oh she's playing the monkey game
monkey monkey
monkey
right I'm gonna let you guys
kiss
okay bye bye time
unfortunately it's bye bye time
extra flavor
don't ever fix your lips to say that again
Ruthlyn
you're stunlocking me
don't do it
I'm kind of done
I called dibs on her hair
there's so much I don't know why
wait no my hair is not long
oh well it's getting longer now
okay
I love you lots
they give you a kiss for how many
teams
I have team noobie boobie
rebound showping
nuca cola
dart sins imps
ice gang screamers while we ink
fun and fair to team zen
that does not happen
team chat myself
team microphone blower team honey
team painkillers
team b
burr go mol pay or shilings
team scouts honors koaine
team
world of warcraft team warkin
team man
team sigma nuts
why? team 005
team
patient
wait yeah and then team
it looks like
R-E-T
R-Y-S
there's no S
on that right
oops
I don't even remember what team I was on
hold on I'll tell you
um
if anyone else wants me to tell you what team you were on
chair you were on team chat
myself because someone spoke down to me
I didn't expect it
it's the me
I miss my team name
you never got one actually
and I stopped doing it when
we were doing the pickups
how about team pop and cherry
since that seemed to pop all your cherries
I think that's
team well
team zen for the W
how did that rate and that was
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 21 22
there was 22
official teams and then the late
kummers
but we are with kummers so it's fine
okay 22
8 9 10
11 12 19
19 19 20
love you
I had lots of fun hopefully
I can pick another game that you like
or a free game or
something in the future that we can play again
together
I will try and make some weekend stream snipes
as well because I do know the majority is only
available on the weekend but I do try and
stream a wee bit longer
when I do stream snipes to give you a chance
especially for those of you who sleep to me
or if you're Aussie
cause it's 4 am
but
you know we're doing good
okay I think you missed one
oh and
team pop your cherry
I guess technically
infiltrator
Rui and Joy
would probably make team a motion
cause it kind of sounds like a motion you would give to someone
so that's another case
Cinco, Billy, Diddy
I just call you
uh
what would I call you?
Cinco? Like I said Cinco Cinco says
I'll call you pretty fly for a white guy
and then I have void rager
dot gar
it was like
mashin re
girl
I definitely did not say it right
that one was like
I guess I would call you team
team
team struggle bus
cause I'm pretty sure I struggled against you
when we played against each other
I'm like 99% sure I played against you
team
have you played Halo Infinite? Is that the multiplayer Halo?
if so
I might add it to the list of games that we're going to play together
I was on your team with tank
there you go
there you go tank
but maybe I'll just call you team health
cause we had so much health
you were tanking all the blues
team health
Halo Infinite is free player
doesn't crawl have multiplayer?
I don't know what crawl is
right I'm not going to stall any longer
cause I'm probably going to pass out if I don't actually eat
I love you lots
as I said I'm going to redirect into Maeve
as always please be super duper
respect for
we're all about the respect
I thank you so so much for everyone that stream sniped
everyone who was cheering us on as well
I know there's lurkers that are a bit too shy to join
but thank you for being a part of the fun
I really appreciate it
and I'll talk to you later alligator
and I'll see you in a while crocodile
as I said the thumbnail is going to change
for tomorrow
and the membership stream is going to be delayed as well
to make
way for
the card shop demo tcg
cause it's not out yet but we can play the demo
and I think it looks really cute
so we're going to give it a shot
thank you very much
I'm going to see you tomorrow
I'm going to eat and then
and then bath
and then sleep
and then deal with the day
something like that
okay
thank you again for playing with me and cheering me on
I really enjoyed today
so thank you for making me happy
you made
you made this Scottish little squiddle happy
okay even though I'm a cuttlefish
I'll say squiddle just cause you know
Scottish squiddle, I love my alliteration
okay
alright no more stalling I need to go eat
I really do
and we play the card
shop and I'll show you how awesome the game is
see you tomorrow gear
bye